Willkommen zur Freakshow. Heute im Disco-Appeal.
Ein Fundstück aus dem Internet, das musste ich einfach verwursten und ohne Nachfrage verwenden.
Ah, wollt ihr auch was sagen? Dann ziehe ich euch eure Regler hoch.
Unbedingt, das war doch bestimmt KI generiert, oder?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das weiß man heutzutage ja nicht mehr. Man kann sich ja über nichts mehr freuen.
Das ist so ähnlich wie jetzt bei der EM mit dem Videobeweis.
Keiner freut sich mehr über irgendein Tor, weil alle erst mal gucken,
was die IT dazu sagt. Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Und das geht mir jetzt mittlerweile halt so bei Kunst-TM, so ein Teil würde
man jetzt aus einem KI-Musik-Tool wahrscheinlich schon annähernd auch auskriegen.
Wir hatten das ja hier in der Sendung und ich hatte ein paar Wochen darauf noch
eine Nachfolge-App quasi ausprobiert, die wirklich ganze Songs kann.
Das, was ich damals hatte, konnte ja nur Strophe, erster Refrain und dann war es zu Ende.
Jetzt kommen schon die ersten, die den ganzen Song durchkomponieren.
Da sind schwierige Zeiten.
Also ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich
habe das jetzt nicht als weiteres KI-Beispiel, sondern mir wurde das so,
zugespielt von Crafty Cuts und das ist irgend so ein UK-DJ, der irgendwie Sachen mixt.
Das klingt für mich noch ganz echt.
Die Frage ist, brauchen wir jetzt einen Videobeweis für KI?
Die Frage ist, braucht dieser Podcast einen Audiobeweis? Brauchen wir einen AAR,
Kontroversen müssen aufgeklärt werden Es muss festgestellt werden Wer recht hatte Das,
Ist so Ich wollte schon immer mal so ein Feature haben im Podcast Haben glaube
ich schon tausend Mal drüber geredet,
Quasi so ein Prediction Marker Also wir haben ja Chapter Marker Ja wir haben
theoretisch hier auch schon
Content-Marker, Behind-the-Scenes, davon hört und seht ihr nichts,
aber es gibt Content-Marker, in diesem Studio zumindest.
Jeder ist in der Lage, hier einen Content-Marker zu machen, aber was es noch
braucht, wäre ein Prediction-Marker.
Immer wenn irgendjemand irgendeine Aussage über die Zukunft macht,
markieren und danach maschinell erfassen, also sozusagen die Aussage als solche,
festhalten, damit man sich das auf der Webseite später anschauen kann.
Wer hat wann worüber eine Prediction gemacht?
Und immer wenn jemand der Meinung ist, über diese Vorhersage lässt sich jetzt
eine Aussage tätigen und die Antwort ist yay or nay, dann, weißt du,
kann man das einsammeln.
Also. Es gab ja mal so einen seligen Podcast, der hieß Die Wiki-Geeks.
Ja, sehr selig. Den ich damals mit meiner noch nicht Frau Claudia Krell aka
Wortkomplex gemacht hatte und wir hatten ja immer den heißen Social-Media-Scheiß der Woche mit drin,
wo wir wahllos irgendwelche damals im wirklich Tagestakt aufpoppenden Web 2.0
Dienste irgendwie durchgetestet und diskutiert haben.
Also die ganzen total armen Webseiten.
Genau, es ist glaube ich immer noch eine sehr coole Folge, wo wir irgendwann
mal dann alle, die wir jemals getestet hatten, dann nochmal in so ein Ranking
bringen, irgendwie so 40 Stück.
So wie auch immer, einer davon war, ich glaube er hieß K.
Serra Und dort konntest du Predictions hinterlegen in einer relativ einfach
zu verstehenden formalisierten Form.
Du konntest also sagen, ich wette oder ich sage vorher das XY und dann konntest
du das mit einem Zeitmarker versehen und sagen, erinnere mich in zwei Jahren
daran, wie das Ganze dann jetzt eigentlich ausgegangen ist.
Und dann bekam man auch wirklich eine E-Mail von diesem System,
dass jetzt seine Prediction abgelaufen ist.
Und alle anderen in dem System konnten darauf voten, ob sie das auch glauben
oder ob sie das nicht glauben.
Das heißt, du hattest zum einen ein ganz lustiges Live-Stimmungsbarometer,
was gerade so unsere Hörerschaft TM denkt.
Und vor allem nach zwei Jahren konntest du dann halt die Wahrheit abchecken.
Und konntest das dann auch dann markieren und hattest dann irgendwie einen Score,
wie oft du recht hattest mit deinen Predictions. Und dieser Dienst...
Der hat erstaunlich lange noch mir Mails geschickt. Also ich glaube fast bis
vor zwei, drei Jahren sind sogar noch welche bei mir aufgeschlagen.
Das dürfte also einer der am längsten überlebenden Web2-Dienste überhaupt gewesen
sein. Ich habe gerade eben mal gegoogelt, ich finde jetzt nichts mehr.
Ich auch nicht.
Wenn ihr da draußen den noch irgendwo in Erinnerung habt oder noch wisst,
oder vielleicht müsste man die Wayback-Machine mal anwerfen.
Ich meine, der hieß K. Serra.
Wie der allerdings genau beschrieben war, weiß ich nicht. Aber das war eine
super Idee. Das müsste man einfach mal wieder bauen. Irgendjemand müsste mal.
Genau, müsste man mal, aber ich finde sowas muss halt irgendwie ein Podcast-Feature sein.
Ich hatte das ursprünglich mal tatsächlich als Bestandteil der Podlove-Timeline,
spezifiziert, aber um die kümmert sich ja keiner.
Also von daher, ja, müssen wir zusehen, dass unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer uns
sozusagen hier an unseren Vorhersagen,
festhalten und darüber eine Aussage machen. Wie auch immer, Ihr habt es schon
gehört, welcome to the Freakshow. Hier ist die Freakshow. Hallo, herzlich willkommen.
Ich bin Tim, mir gegenüber sitzt Roddy.
Hallo.
Und während wir die Hypotenuse bilden.
Bitte was?
Na ja.
Bitte was haben Sie da?
Du bist der rechte Winkel in diesem Podcast und sitzt uns entsprechend gegenüber.
Wäre ja lieber der linke Winkel, aber nun gut.
Tja, der linke Winkel, was soll denn der linke Winkel für eine Perspektive hier einbringen?
Sei meine Ankathete.
Tja, den linke Winkel, den gibt es leider nicht.
Ja, womit fangen wir an? Ich würde sagen, wir machen erstmal ein paar Termine hier weg. Okay.
Sobald Roddy seinen Husten in den Griff bekommen hat.
Ich wollte erstmal ein bisschen Cross-Promotion machen, da ich mit meinem anderen
Podcast, dem Logbuch Netzpolitik, demnächst die 500.
Folge feiere. Und wir haben uns den Sommer schön zurückhaltend terminiert,
sodass wir dann bis zu dem Datum auch auf diese Zahl kommen.
Aber heißt ja nicht, dass wir nicht senden, sondern es ist ja schon noch ein
bisschen was zu tun. Also vier Sendungen gibt es noch bis dahin.
Ja, viermal werdet ihr noch wach.
Heißer, dann heißt es Logbuch Netzpolitik LNP 500 live am 31. August 2024 in Berlin.
Ich muss ja jetzt mal sagen, ich bin ja ein bisschen enttäuscht,
dass ihr nicht die Folge 512 dann als die besondere Folge ausgerufen habt.
Das war tatsächlich eine Diskussion und ursprünglich dachte ich auch, es wird die 512,
aber es gab dann einen Zeitraum der Nichtverfügbarkeit von Linus und dann hat
sich das alles so nach hinten gestreckt,
dass wir nicht mehr sicherstellen konnten,
dass wir das Kontingent dann auch erfüllen können.
Deswegen das, ja, aber ich meine wir haben auch schon mal,
100 war schon, war nicht live, aber war schon mal speziell und 200 und so. Naja und 256 natürlich.
Zahlen. Ich meine am Ende muss ja nur das passende Zahlensystem dazu denken,
dann wird aus der Zahl schon wieder irgendwas Lustiges.
Auch eine 500 kann Spaß machen. es geht ja vor allem darum, überhaupt mal wieder
zusammenzukommen, weil wir haben das jetzt schon, eben das letzte Mal war das
250 gemacht, das war halt alles noch vor Corona, also es ist halt einfach,
fünf Jahre her, dass man überhaupt mal wieder so auf Tuchfüllung gegangen ist
und ich merke das auch an mir, dass ich eigentlich mit diesen ganzen,
Realkontakt-Events nicht so richtig hinterherkomme, also Hörertreffen und so weiter,
alles ist alles ein bisschen ausgedünnt.
Das sollte nicht so sein, finde ich.
Moment, ich muss aber noch die Ankündigung zu Ende bringen.
Also das Ganze ist in der Urania, im Humboldtsaal der Urania,
das ist im Westen, also im Westen sagt der Berliner, wenn es im West-Berlin ist.
Und am 31.
August startet Einlass, ab 17 Uhr können wir rein und ab 19 Uhr soll es losgehen.
Ja, und wir haben dann interessante Gäste am Start und ihr könnt die Tickets
jetzt kaufen und ich würde euch das auch echt empfehlen, weil der Ticketshop
ist jetzt schon eine Woche online und ist ganz gut nachgefragt, sagen wir es mal so.
Und von daher solltet ihr euch vielleicht nicht zu lange Zeit damit lassen mit
eurer Berlin-Reiseplanung.
Das ist eigentlich das, was ich dazu zu sagen habe. Es sei denn, ihr habt noch Fragen.
Keine Fragen.
Nö.
Keine Fragen, euer Ehren.
Ja, zum Thema Live-Event. Ich war am Samstag bei 10 Jahre Ming korrekt.
Ah, warst du da. Okay, erzähl mal.
Ja, war sehr gemütlich und war sehr nett.
Bei den Wühlmäusen.
Wühlmäusen, genau.
Auch im Westen.
Tief im Westen.
Tief im Westen, genau.
Also Nikolas und Reinhardt hatten schon Angst, sie würden da nicht hinkommen,
weil das ja doch relativ nah am Olympiastadion ist.
Und da war ja was im Olympiastadion.
Was war da? Da war dann das Deutschlandspiel oder was?
Richtig. Es war eine sehr lustige Veranstaltung, weil sie tatsächlich das Publikum
vorher aufgefordert hat.
Das Deutschlandspiel war doch in Dortmund.
War das ein anderes Spiel?
Ja, war ein anderes Spiel.
Egal, auf jeden Fall,
hatten sie die Leute aufgefordert, dass sie doch bitte schön Tore gerne reinrufen.
Was dann auch während der Show passiert ist. Das war doch sehr lustig.
Ah. Ein Tor, ein zurückgenommenes Tor, noch ein Tor und dann zum Schluss das
dritte, was dann das zweite war, ein Tor.
Okay, und war das jetzt irgendwie eine neue Show dann?
Naja, das war so im Prinzip der Dia-Abend für zehn Jahre, der Podcast und was
so in den zehn Jahren passiert ist und so weiter und ein paar Experimente,
die sie eigentlich nicht mehr machen,
größtenteils wegen Sicherheitsdingen, haben sie halt dann doch gemacht. Okay.
Okay.
Also an dieser Stelle noch Gruß an Mirko. Neben dem saß ich, aber ist egal.
Ja, mehr gibt es dazu glaube ich nicht zu sagen.
Ja, dann habe ich noch eine Veranstaltung im Köcher, die noch ein bisschen unter-announced ist, Ralf.
Und zwar ist geplant im Oktober die Subscribe mal wieder aufleben zu lassen.
Das wäre dann die Elfte.
Die 11. Genau. Nach langer, langer, langer Pause.
Die 11.
Ja, sehr langer Pause und genau, bin ein bisschen im Verzug mit dem ganzen Announcen
und so weiter und da gibt es jetzt noch keinen Ticket-Shop, das soll aber hoffentlich bald soweit sein,
wenn die ganze Kalkulation steht.
Wer noch nicht genau weiß, wovon wir reden, also die Subscribe hieß irgendwann
mal vor langer, langer, langer Zeit Podlove Developer Workshop.
So hieß es ganz am Anfang.
Ich überlege gerade, war das auch die Abkürzung dann?
Nein, es gab noch keine Abkürzung. Es war einfach nur der Podlove Developer
Workshop und es war halt wirklich ohne die Developers.
Da kamen dann auch sehr viele Developers und Developers, Developers, Ich weiß nicht, 50...
Leute in der Größenordnung und Ziel war damals, diese ganze Podlove-Welt irgendwie
überhaupt erstmal in Wallung zu kriegen. Das ist mehr oder weniger gelungen.
Und dann hat sich aber auch schnell
gezeigt, dass das mit diesen Developer-Workshops so allein nicht greift.
Du kannst jetzt nicht einfach nur Entwickler zusammensetzen und sagen,
jetzt lass uns doch mal überlegen, wie wir die Welt der Podcaster schöner machen können.
Und deswegen ging das dann über in den PODLOVE Podcaster Workshop, PPW.
Jetzt kommt ja das Ganze schon ein bisschen bekannter vor, nehme ich an.
Und das war dann wiederum der totale Knaller.
Also das hat dann die Podcast Community in Deutschland doch schnell zusammengebracht
und da ist eigentlich eine sehr lebendige Gemeinschaft daraus erstanden,
in der dann schon viele Podcaster waren und aus der heraus dann auch noch viele neue, Neue, große,
bekannte, tolle, unterhaltsame Podcasts herausgekommen sind.
Und das Ganze hat sich so ein bisschen verschmolzen, auch mit diesem Entwicklungsansatz.
Also es ist sowohl dort die Technik ein wenig vertreten gewesen,
du hast dann irgendwann mit dem Ultraschallprojekt begonnen.
Auf der allerersten PPW habe ich in der Tat die erste Version von Ultraschall vorgestellt.
Siehst du mal, ne?
Einer sehr schönen Keynote, auf die ich immer noch ein bisschen stolz bin und
die immer noch auf YouTube nachgesehen werden kann.
Wer mal sehen will, wie man wirklich Steve Jobs Rhetorik eins zu eins zu übertragen
hat, kann da was zu lernen.
Von Apple lernen heißt siegen lernen. So sieht es nämlich aus.
Genau.
Und Ultraschall und Podlove und viele andere Projekte wie…,
Studiolink, über das wir jetzt immer noch streamen zum Beispiel in diesem Moment.
Das sind alles so Projekte, die in diesem Umfeld aufgewachsen sind und ja,
ich hoffe, das funktioniert auch wieder.
Ich habe eine super geile, tolle Mega-Location gefunden für diese Veranstaltung,
nämlich das Peter Edel, hier, tatsächlich nicht weit von hier,
entfernt, also von hier, von der Meta-Ebene entfernt, in Berlin, im Pankow und Ich.
Habe mich schon gewundert, was der Name sollte. Es kommt ein ganz besonderer
Gast, der Peter Edel. Nein, so heißt die Location.
Die Location ist nach einem Peter Edel benannt, genau und das ist so ein Kultur,
wie heißt das offiziell auf Google Maps? Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Es ist ein Bildungs- und Kulturzentrum.
Also das ist sozusagen auch entsprechend kommunal aufgelegt,
keine kommerzielle Bude und es ist eine super Location,
weil es einfach sehr viele Breakout-Rooms gibt, alles ist tiptop eingerichtet.
Das gibt es auch erst seit 2020 in der Form.
Alles moderne Techniken, super schöner Hauptsaal, der früher mal ein Brauereigastsaal war.
Einer Brauerei, die es da mal gab, die es jetzt nicht mehr gibt,
aber es gibt wahrscheinlich trotzdem was zu trinken.
Genau, und das Ganze soll stattfinden im August, Entschuldigung,
ich vergesse, was ich gesagt habe. Oktober.
Oktober, genau.
August war die andere Veranstaltung. 18. bis 20. Oktober 2024.
Und ja, ich hoffe, dass ganz viele kommen. Sonst rechnet sich das auch nicht.
Und ja, wer schon mal da war, soll auf jeden Fall wiederkommen und wer Lust
hat auf tolle andere Fellow Podcaster zu treffen oder auch generell nur Interesse
hat eigentlich an Podcasting-Kultur,
würde ich mal sagen, kann da auch immer eine Menge mitnehmen.
Unternehmen oder technisch den Bereich Podcasting in irgendeiner Form interessant
findet, also sowohl was jetzt so Audio-Technik, Studio-Technik betrifft oder halt auch Software,
Podlove und diese ganzen Welten sind dort auf jeden Fall auch vertreten und
ich gehe davon aus, dass auch alle Developer dort vertreten sein werden.
Solche, die es schon sind und solche, die es vielleicht noch werden können.
Und das ist so ein bisschen die Idee.
Also Podcasting quasi sozusagen als Gesamtevent zu feiern.
Technik, Community, die Podcaster selber.
Das ist jetzt kein Podcast-Festival im Sinne von, wie das jetzt sonst so gemacht
wird mit irgendwie deine Lieblings-Podcasts auf der Bühne.
Sondern das ist, hatten wir auch mal das Konzept, aber es geht da eigentlich schon ums Machen.
Also nicht ums da machen, sondern ums Machen an sich.
Genau, was mir immer wirklich gut gefallen hat an unserem Format war die Mischung
zwischen, fand ich, mit relativ viel Liebe und Herzblut hergestellten Vorträgen
auf der einen Seite und dann Barcamp-Sessions auf der anderen Seite.
Also dass man also eine gute Grundlage hatte von, okay, du wirst immer über
das, was jetzt gerade wirklich so aktuell ist, auf dem Laufenden gehalten,
aber du hattest dann eben auch immer genug Freiraum zu gucken,
okay, mich interessiert eigentlich Thema XY, warum wird da nicht drüber geredet?
Und ich finde ja Barcamps funktionieren sowieso eigentlich immer,
also ich kenne keinen Barcamp, auf dem ich war, was wo nicht hinterher die Leute
irgendwie gesagt hätten so, ja war cool, das funktioniert und bei Podcasting
ist das für mich immer ein totaler Selbstläufer.
Also Daumen hoch zu dem Format, ich fand das schon immer gut.
Also so ein Workshop Wochenende mit Podcastern, das hat einfach den Vorteil,
da sind einfach, also man findet relativ wenig Leute, die so komplett aufs Maul gefallen sind.
Also das ist sozusagen auch ein Festival der Redekultur.
Das heißt, man kann sich da einfach super unterhalten, weil die Leute sind so
mit ganzen Sätzen vertraut. Auf keinen Fall.
Vielleicht, weil es denen, die schon mal da waren, noch nicht in Erinnerung,
ist oder auch, weil die, die noch nicht da waren, damit vertraut sein sollten.
Vielleicht kurz was zu dem Format.
Also die Veranstaltung beginnt am Nachmittag des Freitags, also der 18.
Freitag. Mit anderen Worten, im Idealfall schafft man es am Freitag am Nachmittag
dort zu sein in Berlin, also 15 Uhr rum.
14, 15 Uhr rum und wir werden dann wahrscheinlich, nichts ist hier in den Steinen
gemeißelt zu diesem Zeitpunkt, aber das ist einfach mal so das Konzept,
was sich so über die Jahre als sehr brauchbar herausgestellt hat,
starten im Hauptsaal und noch nicht so mit diesen Workshops-Sessions,
sondern erstmal alle zusammen und dann machen wir so ein paar richtungsweisende,
Vorträge, die Keynotes.
Naja, die, wie soll ich sagen, Beiträge, die alle interessieren sollten und
die vielleicht auch mehr erstmal so das allgemeine Verkehrswesen im Podcasting.
Adressieren und berücksichtigen.
Gerade auch, weil so viel Zeit vergangen ist, seitdem wir das letzte Mal das
rekapituliert haben. Also dann immerhin fünf Jahre.
Und die Podcasting-Landschaft hat sich auf der einen Seite extrem gewandelt,
auf der anderen Seite finde ich auch nicht solche Solche Dinge.
Und auf jeden Fall ist der Auftaktabend natürlich wunderbar,
um überhaupt erstmal zu checken, wer ist denn hier überhaupt da,
mit wem kann man sich denn unterhalten.
Das heißt, es wird also viel Meet & Greet geben mit ein bisschen Food for Thought
und dass auch so ein bisschen so ein Agenda-Setting betrieben ist und dann organisatorisch
auch nochmal die letzten Lücken im Programm zu füllen.
Einiges wird schon vorher festgelegt werden.
Das heißt, wenn Leute Lust haben, ich möchte gerne darüber reden,
ich möchte gerne darüber was machen, dann sammeln wir das schon vorher ein und
platzieren das vielleicht auch schon mal in so ein Programm.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall auch noch genug Luft da und vor allem ist dort in
dieser Location auch genug Kapazität da, um dynamisch noch vor Ort auf Ideen
zu kommen mit, oh, da würde ich aber gerne nochmal eine Session zu machen.
Also es sind mehr Räume verfügbar, als wir überhaupt bespielen können.
Teilnehmende haben.
Ja, so schlimm ist es nicht, aber der Platz ist nicht das Problem,
sondern das ist eine reine Frage von Angebot und Nachfrage.
Genau, der Samstag geht dann, achso, es gibt Essen, also mit dem Ticket erwerbt
ihr sozusagen auch gleich das Essen.
Ihr müsst da nicht irgendwo hingehen, das ist da in der Gegend auch sehr angemessen,
weil drumherum ist es dann doch ein bisschen dünner mit den kulinarischen Angeboten.
Da ist Natur, Tim, Natur.
Da ist auch Natur. Also man kann natürlich direkt zum Weißen See,
das liegt direkt am Weißen See, sehr malerisch gelegen.
Aber wenn man jetzt so die Hauptstraße dann runter marschiert auf der Suche
nach guten Essensgelegenheiten, da wird man jetzt nicht so fündig werden.
Deswegen machen wir das so, wie wir das immer gemacht haben.
Es gibt also ein Catering und das heißt, es ist für ein Abendessen dann gesorgt.
Es ist am Samstag für so ein Minimalfrühstück und Mittagessen,
Abendessen und am Sonntag auch nochmal Minimalfrühstück.
Und, also Minimalfrühstück heißt Stulle schmieren, ist das Material da,
man kann sich sozusagen ein bisschen selber versorgen und.
Genau, und dann noch Mittagessen am Sonntag und am Nachmittag des Sonntags wird
sich das dann halt irgendwann auflösen und so 15, 16 Uhr ist in der Regel,
ist der Platz dann auch schon,
geräumt, so und wer halt an dem ganzen Wochenende teilnehmen kann,
der kauft dann sozusagen sagen, ein Ticket für alle Tage, aber es gibt dann
auch die Möglichkeit nur für einen oder zwei Tage das zu machen.
Das muss man dann halt bei der Bestellung angeben, dann wird es ein bisschen
billiger, aber da halt das Essen immer dabei ist. Ticket jetzt ohne Essen kaufen
geht nicht, macht aber auch nicht so viel aus.
Es wäre auch billiger, also es wäre nicht billiger, wenn man drumherum versucht
sich irgendwie Essen zu holen und so kann man das dann auch gemeinsam machen.
Es wird einen Raum geben, wo dann auch Projekte sich platzieren können,
also wo wir so Ecken einrichten können,
damit Projekte sozusagen auch dauerhaft präsent sind und sichtbar und ansprechbar
sind, also alle Projekte, die in irgendeiner Form interessante Sachen machen
im Podcasting-Bereich und der Rest ist eigentlich,
erledigt sich meist von selber, also da ist dann immer eine geile Atmo,
gute Leute, einfach immer wieder interessante Gespräche und ich denke diesmal
gibt es dann halt auch viel dramatische Wiedersehensszenen zu beobachten.
Das ist jetzt aber kein Versprechen, oder?
So eine offene Baustelle war immer das Abendprogramm. Du hast den Job.
Da war es immer nicht so ganz einfach, irgendwie eine Balance zu finden zwischen
ein bisschen, was muss schon passieren.
Erik schlägt gerade im Chat vor, die große Ultraschall-AI-Keynote.
Ja, den Job hat Ralf auch.
Du weißt schon, du musst mindestens 100 Mal AI sagen. Ich führe Strichliste.
Was dann brauchbares Format ist.
Ja, also ich denke, als Abendprogramm hat sich auch das wir hängen alle zusammen
rum und reden mal über irgendwas auch ganz gut etabliert, aber das sehen wir dann,
das wird dann davon abhängen, wie der Zuspruch so ist.
Der Content dafür wird hoffentlich dann auch bald online sein auf subscribe.de und,
Ja, das ist glaube ich im Wesentlichen das. Ich musste jetzt diese Ankündigung
auch mal machen, damit ich da jetzt auch vorankomme.
Damit du Druck hast.
Ja, ich brauche, also das ist, ich habe einfach gemerkt, dass das für mich auch,
also diese, man glaubt ja immer, man wird durch diese Corona-Pause einfach so
mühelos durchmarschiert.
Das ist nicht der Fall also es hat irgendwie dieser Break hat schon was ausgemacht,
wobei ich halt auch damals schon so ein bisschen,
na wie soll ich sagen ich hatte auch schon so ein bisschen das Gefühl die ganze
Podcasting-Geschichte ist auch ein bisschen auserzählt, so, trotzdem wir hatten
ja auf dem letzten Kongress,
in Hamburg, Chaos Communication Kongress gab es ja wieder diese Sendezentrums-Ecke,
wo dann halt auch mal viele wieder zusammengekommen sind, nachdem es ja auch
den Kongress seit drei Jahren nicht gab.
Und dann gab es halt so eine Runde, wo halt rumgefragt wurde, wie sieht es denn aus?
Subscribe? Yay oder nay? Müssen wir das mal wieder mal machen?
Und dann war eigentlich der Zuspruch relativ klar.
Sodass ich mir halt dachte so, okay, gut, dann machen wir das dann.
Und dann habe ich es so ein bisschen von der Location abhängig gemacht und Und
bin dann auf dieses Peter Edel gestoßen und es ist halt einfach wirklich ein Traum.
Der Ort ist ein Traum.
Ja, das macht einen guten Eindruck. Ich glaube auch, das wird schon gehen.
Irgendwas wollte ich jetzt gerade noch ein... Achso, genau. Ich habe mal,
falls irgendjemand da draußen immer noch nicht überzeugt sein sollte,
ich habe mal eine URL reingeworfen zu den ganzen Aufzeichnungen der relevanten
Talks auf YouTube laufen, die über das Sendezentrum.
Das ist also eine Dachorganisation, die hier Tim, Claudia, ich und Dennis Mohart
mal zusammen gegründet haben, weil ziemlich alles von Tag Null an halt durchs VOG,
also Video Operations Center vom CCC aufgezeichnet worden ist.
Und da bubbert natürlich mein Bibliothekars Herz doppelt so laut,
dass es endlich mal eine fünftige Dokumentation und Wissensmanagement gibt hier auf der Ebene.
Da kann man mal reingucken, wie diese Talks so funktionieren und was da alle
so zu finden ist und was für eine Breite das hat.
Da sollte Neugier entstehen, wenn man da mal ein bisschen stöbert.
Genau, das ist glaube ich ein ganz interessantes Zeitdokument,
auf jeden Fall kann man dann alles nachhören.
Also es sind natürlich nicht alle Workshop-Sessions aufgezeichnet worden,
sondern wir haben halt so die Main-Tracks, die auf den Bühnen geplant werden,
die nehmen wir auf oder zumindest den auf der Hauptbühne nehmen wir auf und
wir müssen uns nochmal entscheiden, ob wir noch einen zweiten Raum brauchen.
Auch immer aufnehmbar machen wollen werden und optional konnte man,
glaube ich, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, hatten wir noch ein Setup,
dass wenn man jetzt so eine Workshop-Session macht, dass man sagen kann,
wir wollen zumindest, dass das Audio aufgenommen wird.
Wie das diesmal konkret sein wird, kann ich nicht sagen, wird sich zeigen.
Das Ganze ist eine Community-Veranstaltung, das heißt, alle machen mit.
Das ist ganz wichtig, sonst funktioniert das nicht.
Orga ist dann im Sendegate bei Zeiten. Werden wir da eine schöne neue Rubrik aufmachen?
Genau, Sendegate.de, da kann
man jetzt schon am meisten Informationen finden und auch Leute finden.
Das heißt, wenn ihr Bock habt, irgendwie daran teilzunehmen,
wir packen da noch einen Link rein in Sendegate, dann könnt ihr euch da schon auch mal melden.
Und die, die sich im Vorfeld, ich hatte das ja schon vor einiger Zeit mal über
die Social-Media-Kanäle unserer Wahl verbreitet und so eine kleine Umfrage gemacht,
wer denn so kommen wollte, da hatten sich schon mal so 150 Leute gemeldet.
Die kriegen auf jeden Fall auch nochmal eine Mail, sobald die Webseite steht und es richtig losgeht.
Wird jetzt ein bisschen tough, das so über den Sommer zu machen,
aber ich glaube, wir kriegen das irgendwie hin und ja, dann hoffe ich,
wird sich das alles ausgehen.
Kosten werden ein bisschen steigen, weil wir halt jetzt hier auch mit Miete
zu tun haben, um die Kosten niedrig zu halten, haben wir sozusagen das absolute,
Minimum an Personal, von der Location.
Ich habe denen also hoch und heilig versprochen und angekündigt,
dass da nur nette Leute kommen, die total cool sind und alles noch besser hinterlassen,
als sie es vorgefunden haben und überhaupt total nett sind und eine Freude,
da begrüßt zu werden und ja, ich hoffe natürlich, dass es auch genau so passiert,
sonst stehe ich ein bisschen doof da.
Aber ich bin da eigentlich ganz zuversichtlich.
Bisher ist es dann doch immer noch sehr gut gegangen. Ja, ich glaube,
wir hatten richtiggehend keine Verluste bisher in dem wertenden Umfang.
Nee, das stimmt, tatsächlich. Das wäre auch ganz gut diesmal wieder.
Wenn wir schon bei Ankündigungen sind und du sagtest, man sieht dort keine Podcasts auf Bühnen,
dann habe ich jetzt noch eine Ankündigung für eine Veranstaltung,
wo man Podcasts auf der Bühne sehen kann.
Und zwar das Potsdock, das ist praktischerweise genau in dem Monat,
wo die anderen beiden Veranstaltungen nicht sind, im September und zwar vom 13. bis zum 15.
An einer neuen Location am Dümmersee. Wo der Dümmersee ist, müsst ihr selber
nachschlagen aus Berliner Perspektive kurz vor Belgien.
Im Westen.
Im Westen, ja ich sag ja kurz vor Belgien.
Ja, wenn man Camping-affin ist, ist das von Vorteil, weil ich weiß nicht,
wie viele Indoor-Übernachtungen man da tatsächlich buchen kann.
Aber es gibt sie und wenn die noch nicht ausgebucht sind, könnt ihr auch eine
Indoor-Übernachtung da buchen auf dem Gelände.
Also um vielleicht mal eine grobe Orientierung zu geben, der nächstgrößere bekannte Ort ist Osnabrück.
Der Dümmersee ist da, was weiß ich, so 50 Kilometer nordöstlich,
ja, nord-nordöstlich davon.
Und kurz vor… Und Osnabrück ist in der Nähe von?
Ja, Osnabrück kennt man noch. Ich bitte dich. Osnabrück ist zwischen Bad Bentheim und Bad Eulnerhausen.
Ah, da. Ich weiß von Osnabrück nur, dass es ehemals der größte deutsche Brückenbahnhof war.
Aber seit es in Berlin den Hauptbahnhof gibt, das ist der größere Brückenbahnhof jetzt.
Okay, verstehe. Naja, also der Dümmersee ist genau zwischen Münster und Bremen.
Okay. Aber das sind auch große Strecken. Ich sag doch, kurz vor Belgien.
Ja, das ist ja so ein schwieriges Niemandsland. Da geht es ja dann auch schon,
ich weiß nicht, ist das schon Emsland?
Oder ist das noch Münsterland? Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht.
Nördlicher Teutoburger Wald. Naja, also auf jeden Fall sieht das sehr hübsch aus.
Und Podstock ist, sagen wir mal, eine vergleichbare Community Querschnitt wie
die Subscribe und versteht sich noch mehr als gelebtes.
Wir machen jetzt Podcasts und zwar so richtig mit alle schauen zu und machen mit.
Genau, richtig mit Bühne und so.
Und mit Grillen und Pizza machen und so weiter. Und da bist du ja auch immer
ganz vorne an der Front, wenn ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Letztes Mal stand ich, glaube ich, nur vier Stunden am Pizzaofen.
Ja, siehst du mal. Und das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen das Outdoor-Event,
das Wohlfühl-Outdoor-Event und dann sind auch alle ordentlich eingetunt,
um dann auf der Subscribe nochmal in die Vollen zu gehen.
Wohlfühl-Outdoor-Event trifft es glaube ich sehr, sehr gut.
Genau. Und das andere ist das Wohlfühl-Indoor-Event. Also sozusagen für alle Bedürfnisse.
Genau. Gut, schöne Ankündigungen.
Dann haben wir, ja, Ankündigungen.
Wir haben uns ja in der letzten Sendung mit Ankündigungen beschäftigt.
Wir bauen eine Brückenüberleitung, Teil 597.
Naja, die war jetzt nicht so schlecht.
Oder? War nicht so schlecht, nein. Jetzt musst du noch die Brücke der Versöhnung betreiben.
Die Brücke der Versöhnung. Versöhnung. Das klingt sehr sozialistisch, wenn du mich fragst.
Ja, ach gut. Ich meine, wir haben was passiert.
Also die Apple Keynote war und es wurde halt viel angekündigt.
Und in den Kommentaren stieß, glaube ich, die Diskussion, die wir hier geführt
haben, ein bisschen auf. auf, weil,
Max und ich ein bisschen unterschiedliche Standpunkte, glaube ich,
vertreten haben. Wie denn jetzt dieser,
Wie denn jetzt sozusagen diese Ankündigung zu bewerten ist. Und während er halt
im Wesentlichen, da ist ja nichts zu sehen und da kommt dann wahrscheinlich
auch nichts mehr, These vertreten hat,
habe ich eigentlich mir die These vertreten, wenn die schon was ankündigen,
dann wird da schon auch mal irgendwann was kommen.
Und das ging dann so ein bisschen hin und her und hat sich für meinen Geschmack
ein bisschen zu sehr in die Länge gezogen,
aber aus meiner Perspektive kann man halt beide Standpunkte irgendwie vertreten.
Zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt wollte
ich aber dann auch mal zu dem zweiten Standpunkt auch mal übergehen.
Insofern gab Leute der Meinung, ich würde auf einem hohen Ross unterwegs sein
und keine anderen Meinungen zulassen.
Naja, wir haben da irgendwie 40 Minuten drüber diskutiert. Echt?
So lange?
Ja, ich habe mir das nochmal angehört und insgesamt war das so ein Segment.
Also das ganze Segment war noch länger, aber wir haben mal davon angefangen
und das Thema kam immer wieder auf, haben wir irgendwie so 40 Minuten abgespannt.
Ich finde, das hat dann dem Thema auch ausreichend Raum gegeben.
Naja gut, ich meine, ich kann Max insofern verstehen, als dass die Menge der
AI-Ankündigungen, auf denen keine Taten gefolgt sind, ja schon extrem hoch sind.
Also das ist so die Silicon Valley Vaporware Golden ist halt irgendwas zum Thema AI anzukündigen.
Also insofern den Standpunkt kann ich nachvollziehen, aber ich meine Apple ist
ja jetzt auch nicht irgendwer.
Klar gibt es da immer dieses Reality Distortion Field von Apple,
wo das dann am Ende nicht ganz so golden ist, wie es blinkt in der Ankündigung.
Aber dass sie gar nichts zustande kriegen, fand ich jetzt auch irgendwie eine steile These.
Also ich habe mit der Sendung im Nachhinein doch auch ein bisschen gehadert,
aber ich glaube, das war jetzt einfach keine Sternstunde der Podcast-Moderation
auch, was wir vier da insgesamt gemacht haben.
Das hätte man, glaube ich, irgendwie in zivilisiertere Bahnen leiten können.
Das war, glaube ich, auch der Hauptkritikpunkt dann, was im Blog so kam,
dass es auch viele Leute abgeschaltet haben, weil sie es nicht mehr ertragen konnten.
Was ich natürlich als ehemaliger Medienwissenschaftler super spannend fand,
war, dass sich diese beiden Teams oder Camps dann auch genau in den Kommentaren abgebildet haben.
Das heißt also, die einen wollten abschalten wegen Tim, die anderen wollten
abschalten wegen Max oder haben es dann auch alle getan demonstrativ.
Keine Ahnung, ob sie dann die nächste Kapitelmarke angesprungen haben oder wirklich
nie wieder Freakshow hören.
Das war's dann.
Aber ich habe jetzt, also wie viele Kommentare haben wir da?
60 oder sowas? Und praktisch alle drehen sich um das eine Thema.
Nee, nee, Bohrhammer ist auch ganz weit vorne.
Ja gut, Bohrhammer, Akkubohrhammer, der wird aber jetzt noch ein paar Jahre
laufen, also das Thema wirst du nie wieder los.
Aber das haben wir ja schon geklärt.
Ja, da gehen wir jetzt auch nicht weiter drauf ein, aber es ist jetzt nicht nur das Thema gewesen.
Ja, aber es ist schon auffällig, dass es wirklich diese zwei Lager gibt und
mit wirklich sehr, sehr wenig, beziehungsweise ich glaube, ich habe keine einzige
versöhnliche, brückenbauende Statement irgendwo dazwischen gesehen.
Also es scheint wirklich extrem zu polarisieren, was da passiert ist.
Das nimmt man dann einfach mal so hin für richtig.
Ja und ich glaube das hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun,
wie Apple an sich gesehen wird.
Weil es ist ja auch sehr en vogue, jetzt Apple generell jetzt scheiße zu finden,
weil sie ja einfach die Kriterien von Underdog nicht mehr erfüllen.
Und alles, was nicht Underdog ist, ist halt potenziell eine Gefahr.
Also ist ja auch generell so, kann man schon so sehen und das gilt in Teilen
sicherlich auch für Apple.
Ob sie sich jetzt allerdings in diesem Bereich von AI und dem ganzen Hype drumherum
da schon schuldig gemacht haben,
das würde ich so nicht unterschreiben.
Da sind sie eher der Underdog.
Ja, naja, da werden sie als Underdog angesehen.
Ich würde dem aber auch widersprechen wollen, weil sie ja nun,
wie sie auch, wie ich finde, zu Recht in ihrer eigenen Keynote auch darauf hingewiesen
haben und in der Medienberichterstattung danach auch nie müde wurden,
in Interviews und Podcasts, wo sie überall aufgetaucht sind,
dann auch nochmal einzuwerfen.
Die machen das halt schon ganz lange.
Also ich meine, so Sachen wie in den Fotos nach Dingen zu suchen und so,
das ist jetzt nicht dieses Jahr angekündigt worden, sondern das ist schon vor zwei,
drei Jahren und andere Features auch noch schon sehr viel länger.
Also das Beispiel Textzusammenfassung gibt es schon seit 20 Jahren in macOS.
Das hat nicht unbedingt auf Machine Learning basiert, sondern die haben die
darunterliegende Technologie ein-, zweimal ausgetauscht und werden es jetzt
voraussichtlich ein weiteres Mal tun, weil die Technologie besser geworden ist.
Aber diese Vorstellung davon, dass der Computer automatisiert Dinge auf eine
intelligente Art und Weise machen kann, war schon immer drin.
Also es gab zum Beispiel in macOS...
Ich glaube seit macOS 8, also wir reden von dem alten ursprünglichen,
da haben sie irgendwann diese Apple Data Detectors eingeführt,
die einfach so systemweit,
ich gucke in deinen Text, ist da ein Link drin,
ist da ein Datum drin, kann man da einen Termin draus machen.
Also da war schon immer irgendwie so etwas drin, was du versuchst,
systemweit dir irgendwelche Features zu machen.
So wie du heute ein Bild hast und sie automatisch OCR drauf machen und du einfach
mit der Maus rüber gehen kannst, Copy-Paste machen kannst und so.
Und das basiert natürlich mittlerweile weitgehend alles auf Machine Learning.
Ich meine, sie hatten Handschrifterkennung ja schon mit dem Newton probiert,
da war das aber noch nicht.
Ja, aber das würde ich alles noch nicht Machine Learning nennen.
Das war mehr so programmierte Heuristik.
Ich habe es nicht Machine Learning genannt, ich habe nur gesagt.
Ich finde das Beispiel schwierig. Was ich ein viel besseres Beispiel finde,
ist das, was die Apple Watch alles tut, um zu erkennen, ob man jetzt geht, Fahrrad fährt, läuft.
Oder was ich zum Beispiel auch ein völlig abstruses Feature finde,
ist zum Beispiel in der Health-App, da zeigt er einem an, ob man hinkt,
also asymmetrischen Gang hat.
Echt?
Das wäre für mich total einschlägig.
Und das ist, erkennt tatsächlich das iPhone nur dadurch, dass man es in der Hosentasche hat.
Und für mich ist das so, wenn das keine AI-Magie ist, dann weiß ich es auch nicht.
Also dafür programmierst du wahrscheinlich keine Heuristik.
Ja, oder diese Herzschlagerkennung, die halt nicht nur den Herzschlag zählt,
sondern auch diese Vorhofflimmern erkennt, etc.
Ja, dieses Zeug.
Also ein Feature, was ich erst vor ein paar Wochen gefunden habe,
aber seitdem fast täglich nutze.
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht, dass in iOS ein Übersetzungsprogramm fest eingebaut ist.
Ja, seit zwei oder drei Versionen schon lange.
Also wenn man irgendeinen Text markiert, dann hat man ja immer dann oben dieses
Kontextfeld und das kann man halt so durch die Gegend scrollen und irgendwann
hat man dann den praktischen Eintrag übersetzen und das ist nicht schlecht.
Du kannst jeden Text markieren auf dem iPhone und hast das als Kontextmenü.
Aber auch der Schlaftracker zum Beispiel, der ist doch garantiert auch AI. Genau.
Also das war eigentlich mein Punkt. Es gibt schon seit sehr langer Zeit Features, die,
Und quasi sich Daten anschauen und versuchen daraus irgendwas Sinnvolles zu
machen, wo der User eigentlich erst darauf hingewiesen wird oder was automatisch
im Hintergrund passiert.
Und mit der Zeit sind die darunter liegenden Heuristiken, die es vielleicht
am Anfang mal waren oder einfache Algorithmen oder was auch immer ausgereicht hat,
wurden dann Stück für Stück durch Machine Learning Algorithmen ersetzt,
die in zunehmendem Maße dann eben die neuesten Technologien,
Deep Learning und eben jetzt im aktuellen Schritt jetzt auch LLMs als Basis nehmen.
Weil das ist ja eigentlich der Kern der Ankündigung, was sie jetzt unter Apple Intelligence bringen.
Apple Intelligence fügt dem Betriebssystem ein LLM-Herz ein,
was durch verschiedene Plugs auf spezifische Anwendungen hin konditioniert wird.
Das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das, was dahinter steht und sie schaffen
damit im Betriebssystem,
nicht nur bei iOS, sondern halt auch macOS, also quasi für alle Systeme,
schaffen sie einen Mechanismus, die Fähigkeiten und Intelligenz eines einzelnen zentralen LLMs,
was halt dann auch lokal seine Tätigkeit verrichten kann,
wenn die Power entsprechend da ist.
Und dann nutzt man aber eben spezifische Ausführungen davon,
mit denen sie eben zahlreiche der neuen Dienste gemacht haben.
Während sie aber gleichzeitig, und das sind die, die jetzt schon in der Beta
auch noch drin sind, weil sie bisher schon immer da waren, gibt es auch noch
die Sachen, die jetzt nicht auf Basis dieser LLM arbeiten.
Die es schon immer gab, die in Fotos und so weiter drin ist,
die halt über andere Arten und Weisen, Machine Learning und dann eben auch mit
dieser Neural Engine in ihren Prozessoren irgendwie aktiviert wird.
Und dieser neue Teil, Apple Intelligence, der ist quasi so die heiße Kartoffel,
die jetzt halt irgendwie durch die Medien getragen wird. Was denn das nun kann?
Und davon haben sie gesagt, das dauert noch.
Und ob es jetzt dauert, weil die Software nicht fertig ist oder weil sie das
erst dann auf die Massen loslassen wollen,
wenn sie auch diese Private Cloud dafür am Start haben und ausgebaut haben und
eine entsprechende Kapazität haben.
Weil ich meine, wenn iOS 18 release wird, kannst du dir vorstellen, was dann los ist.
Also wenn einfach eine Milliarde User innerhalb von 24 Stunden alle mal was
ausprobieren wollen und da wird einiges ins Schwitzen kommen.
Wenn das jetzt sozusagen noch nicht in place ist, dann können sie das halt auch nicht shippen.
Aber ich glaube auch, dass sie die Software noch nicht fertig sind.
Je nachdem, wie sie den Rollout machen. Aber ich glaube, dass sie relativ viel
unter Apple AI subsummieren, was aber vorher an Technologie schon da war.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass das Core ML dieses Frameworks jetzt eine neue
Sache ist, sondern wenn man guckt, was die WWDC einem so an APIs,
an neuen gegeben hat, dann ist da gar nicht so viel dazugekommen.
Klar, sehr spannende Dinge, aber da war vorher auch schon relativ viel. Also insofern.
Also ich glaube, wir waren uns in der Sendung ja eigentlich einig,
dass der grundsätzliche Ansatz hier von Apple, wie sie jetzt dieses ganze Thema
KI angehen, ist total sinnvoll und zielführend und vielversprechend ist.
Das, wo sich die Lager aufgespalten haben und wo ich auch wirklich jetzt wenig
Versöhnungspotenzial sehe, ist halt die sehr unterschiedliche Einschätzung.
Kann das mit einer generativen KI überhaupt in der hier benötigten Präzision passieren oder nicht?
Und da hat dann in der Tat auch Tim recht so, da kann man jetzt noch zwei Stunden
die Argumente hin oder her schieben, am Ende des Tages muss man es halt abwarten.
Und die einen haben jetzt die Prediction, die anderen haben eine andere Prediction
und in einem Jahr setzen wir uns ja wieder hin und gucken, okay,
was ist nur eigentlich passiert.
Naja, aber ich denke mal, eigentlich scheiden sich die Geister im Wesentlichen an Siri.
Siri war bis jetzt eine Vollkatastrophe, da sind wir uns eigentlich einig.
Und dann hat Apple plötzlich das versprochen, was ein AI-Pin und was ein Rabbit
R1 versprochen hat und die sind ja beide großartig gescheitert.
Aber daraus jetzt zu schließen, dass Apple es auch nicht hinkriegen wird,
finde ich halt ein bisschen…,
vorschnell.
Ich habe noch mal in den Chat eine URL geworfen, hier zu der letzten Folge vom
WMR-Podcast, wo Max ja auch mit drin ist.
Da kann man sich noch mal anderthalb Stunden Max anhören, wo nicht so viel widersprochen
wird, sondern die beiden sind sich da relativ einig. Mit MS Pro macht er das ja zusammen.
Es kommen da nicht so rasend viele neue Argumente, die wir nicht auch schon
hier in der Sendung hatten, aber so das eine oder andere wird noch ein bisschen weiter ausgeführt.
Es bleibt spannend. Wir werden sehen, was da passiert.
Also ich war ja in der Sendung wirklich ziemlich deutlich, Team Max,
ich stehe da auch nach wie vor für, ich sehe einfach nicht, wie sie viele technische
Probleme lösen wollen, aber,
ich lasse mich natürlich total gerne eines besseren eines besseren belehren,
weil ich will das ja haben. Ich will ja diese Zukunft.
Ich glaube, der Holmeine-Mama vom Flughafenabteil ist, glaube ich,
der, der am meisten irgendwie sketchy ist und der wahrscheinlich am wenigsten
funktionieren wird und ein bisschen Bild generieren, das ist ja Standard.
Warten wir es ab. Aber du wirst es ja sowieso nicht kriegen,
weil EU böse und Apple will dir das gar nicht geben, was du haben willst.
Es kam ein wenig aus dem Nichts die Ankündigung von Apple, dass wenn iOS 18
und macOS, keine Ahnung welche Zahl haben wir da jetzt gerade.
Ich verliere komplett den Überblick.
13, 14? Wo sind wir jetzt?
14 sind wir ja, also 15, macOS 15. Ich werde Ihnen nie verzeihen,
dass Sie nicht die Gelegenheit genutzt haben, damals das irgendwie zu synchronisieren, aber egal.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es die Aussage von Apple, dass bestimmte Features Fast alle?
Nein, drei Features.
Ich channel jetzt mal meinen inneren Max.
Lass das. Die Hörer hassen das.
Nicht in der EU nicht ausgerollt werden vor Now.
Wegen DMA vielleicht.
Und das umfasst alles, was unter Apple Intelligence läuft.
Es betrifft das iPhone-Mirroring-Feature und es betrifft das Shareplay-Screensharing.
Also wirklich alles Interessante aus der Keynote.
Vielleicht sollten wir kurz sagen, DMA, Digital Markets Act oder wie das Ding
heißt, das ist diese neue Gesetzgebung, die irgendwie die Firmen daran hindern sollen,
Monopole auf digitalen Marktplätzen aufzumachen.
Wir unterstreichen Marktplatz.
Freie Marktwirtschaft.
Genau. Welches dieser drei Feature genau hat was mit einem Marktplatz oder mit
Apple zu tun, wie es Geld verdient und wie es abgreift?
Naja, jetzt hat Apple mal einen Aufschlag gemacht. Beim iPhone Mirroring kann
man sagen, hey, wenn ihr das in macOS einbaut, dann müsst ihr das aber auch für Android einbauen.
Sagt das irgendwer? Hat irgendjemand die Fantasie, dass das ein Spin ist,
den die EU im Geiste ihres Dokumentes, die sprechen ja immer von ihrem Geist des DMA,
darum sei es alles nicht so in super konkrete Vorgaben gegossen,
aber dass irgendjemand den Eindruck hat, okay,
wir haben jetzt zwei Devices von derselben Firma und die machen ein Mirroring
von Daten, dass dann die EU sich hinschüttelt und sagt,
das müsst ihr jetzt aber auch mit Android machen. Das halte ich für abwegig.
Naja, also das Ding ist, dass der DMA ist nicht genau.
Der beschreibt nicht genau, was du machen darfst oder nicht,
sondern es ist eher ein diffuses Dokument, was halt irgendwie sagt,
ja, ihr müsst halt, das und das muss irgendwie ermöglicht werden und dann muss
das irgendwie alles fair sein und dann muss das so sein, dass irgendwie alles kompetitiv ist.
Aber es wird nicht konkret genau vorgeschrieben, was du zu machen oder zu unterlassen hast,
sondern es ist so, in dem Moment, wo du von der EU als marktbeherrschende Plattform
angesehen wirst, dann fällst du halt unter diese Regelung.
Aber es ist relativ schwierig zu sagen, was genau jetzt eigentlich getan werden
muss, um diese Anforderungen zu erfüllen.
Und das haben wir ja jetzt schon gesehen bei dem Hin und Her mit dem App Store.
Apple hat, nachdem DMA sozusagen beschlossen war und dann absehbar auch in Kraft
treten wird, angekündigt, okay, meinetwegen dann halt App Store irgendwie,
aber halt nur, und das haben wir ja hier auch ausführlich behandelt,
dann nur unter diesen Erschwernissen.
Und da hat Apple natürlich alle Register gezogen, die ihrer Auffassung nach
sowohl das erlauben, was gefordert wird,
aber ihnen aber auch noch sozusagen die Kontrolle über diese Plattform so erhält,
dass sie selbst damit glücklich sind.
Ja, aber in dem Wort steckt ja eben schon Markets drin.
Das heißt also jetzt gerade eben bei dem App Store ging es ja darum,
dass eben Apple mit einem Monopol Geld verdient und keine anderen in dieses
App Store. Das ist kein Monopol.
Das Wort Monopol spielt hier überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Monopol ist was ganz anderes.
Ja, aber der App Store ist ja die einzige Art und Weise, wie man zu dem Zeitpunkt
Apps aufs iPhone bringen kann.
Ja, es ist eine marktbeherrschende Stellung einer Plattform.
Darum geht es. Es geht um Plattformen.
Ja, aber es ging ja schon sehr konkret eigentlich jetzt um den App Store an der Stelle.
Ja, aber es ging nicht um ein Monopol.
Es ging nicht um ein x-beliebiges Feature auf dem iPhone.
Ja, aber der Monopol ist, wenn du der Einzige bist. Ja, genau.
Kein anderer konnte einen App Store auf das iPhone installieren. Also war es ein Monopol.
Ja, aber es läuft nicht unter Monopolrecht oder so, sondern es ist halt...
Du verstehst aber schon, dass der Geist genau so, um die wieder zu zitieren,
ja, der europäische Geist, zielte genau in diese Richtung.
Und es ging nicht um ein x-beliebiges Feature, das interoperabel zu machen,
sondern es ging darum, um Dinge, mit denen Apple als einziger Geld verdienen
kann, die zu regulieren.
So, weder das Mirroring, noch derzeit Apple AI, noch CarPlay, nichts davon...
Shareplay Screen Sharing.
Also wenn ihr uns regulieren wollt, dann kriegt ihr die guten Dinge nicht mehr.
Ich meine, genau, letzteres scheint mir da halt eher der Spin zu sein.
Also, zunächst einmal die Intensität, es geht ja nicht darum,
womit Apple Geld verdient, sondern es geht vor allem darum, dass andere auch
überhaupt die Möglichkeit haben, Geld zu verdienen mit der Argumentation.
Mit euren Regeln könnt ihr euch quasi jeden beliebigen Competitor einfach außen
vor halten, weil ihr halt arbiträre,
Regeln aufstellt dafür, wie man eben hier auf dieser Plattform sich auch präsentieren kann.
Und weil ihr so groß und so wichtig seid, und das ist auch eine Argumentation,
die ich zu 100% nachvollziehen kann, ja, es ist ja klar, wenn du heute irgendeinen
Business starten willst,
was in irgendeiner Form irgendeine Nützlichkeit hat im Zusammenhang mit Smartphones und Internet,
also alles sozusagen, dann bist du quasi darauf angewiesen, mit wenigen Ausnahmen,
wo sich das wirklich komplett elegant übers Web abwickeln lässt.
Was heißt angewiesen, ist schon ein bisschen zu großes Wort,
aber sagen wir mal so, es ist oft ein großer Vorteil, wenn du sowas auch mit
Apps im App Store lösen oder erweitern oder ergänzen und realisieren kannst.
Das ist klar, das ist so.
Und die Ableitung, die die EU jetzt sozusagen daraus zieht, ist, das Problem ...
Ist, dass es nur einen App-Store gibt.
Und gäbe es ja ganz viele App-Stores, dann würde sich das Problem ja von selbst
lösen, weil ja freier Markt.
Wo ich schon mal die erste Fußnote setzen würde mit, warum sind die anderen
jetzt eigentlich nicht böse, sondern nur der eine.
Aber okay, der Markt regelt, das ist ja, sagen wir mal, der weit verbreitete
Glaube. Aber ich habe da schon mal meine Zweifel.
Naja, in dem Gesetz steht ja Apple explizit nicht drin und wenn Google nicht
handelt, dann werden sie die früher oder später auch.
Google war ja schon immer einen
Schritt weiter, indem sie ja schon andere App-Stores immer erlaubt haben.
Trotzdem gibt es noch einzelne Regeln, die für sie jetzt auch noch gelten.
Oder sie waren einen Schritt zurück, weil sie es nicht auf dem Schirm hatten,
dass sie vielleicht mehr Geld verdienen, wenn sie es von Anfang an verhindern.
Gut, Google interessiert mich ehrlich
gesagt in dem Zusammenhang erstmal überhaupt nicht. Mich auch nicht.
Sie sagt ja nicht, wir sind die Billigsten, sondern sie sagt ja, wir sind ja die Besten.
Ob sie das jetzt immer sind, sei mal dahingestellt, aber das ist definitiv ihr Ansatz.
Wenn alle sagen, ja, ihr habt ja nur so und so viel Prozent Marketshare vom
Smartphone-Business, sagt Apple, mir doch egal, wir haben 99 Prozent von dem
Markt, in dem wir sein wollen.
Weil wir definieren sozusagen den High-End. Wir definieren den Bereich,
wo auch mehr ausgegeben wird.
Und weil dafür mehr ausgegeben wird, können wir da auch mehr liefern.
Und so wird halt ein Schuh draus für Apple.
Und deswegen mögen wir diese Plattform auch. Auch.
Weil da gute Sachen sind. Da ist nicht alles grün auf der Wiese.
Und das Gold glänzt auch nicht unbedingt immer so, wie man sich das so gerne wünscht.
Aber man kann auch nicht sagen, dass jetzt Apple in dieser Zeit nicht irgendwie
was geliefert hätte, sondern sie machen sehr gute Hardware, sie machen sehr
gute Software. It's not for everybody.
Aber es ist für die Leute, für die es ist, ist es halt auch wirklich sehr gut
und man ist automatisch auf einem hohen Niveau.
Sehr viel hat damit auch zu tun, dass sie ihre eigenen Systeme extrem gut integrieren.
Also dieses ganze Zusammenspiel von iOS, macOS, iPadOS, WatchOS,
alle sonst wie OS, dass das alles irgendwie so ein Ökosystem ist und so weiter,
das ist ja auch ein Feature.
Und das ist ein Feature ihres oder ihrer Produkte.
Das wird aber dann von anderen sozusagen gesehen als, Aber wir wollen da aber
auch mitspielen in eurem selbst geschaffenen Super-Öko-System.
Warum dürfen wir denn da kein Geld verdienen mit?
Wo man sich halt immer erstmal fragen muss, wieso sollten wir dich hier irgendwie mit reinlassen?
Das ist unser Business. Also, dieses ganze App-Store-Ding, das kam letzten Endes
auch erst so durch Apple.
Du hast vorher bei den Spiele-Konsolen halt ein System,
wo Spiele dann in so einem Spezial-Deal zwischen Konsolenhersteller und Gaming-Programmierfirmen
gemacht wurde, wo der Deal beileibe nicht so gut war, wie er im App-Store ist,
mit super queeren Verträgen.
Aber viele Geräte, die da draußen sind und die in irgendeiner Form Funktionalität
bieten, haben ja gar nicht die Möglichkeit, überhaupt erst mal andere da mit reinzulassen.
Und das schafft halt eine neue Situation.
Darüber ist dann das iPhone natürlich auch super populär geworden.
Smartphones an sich sind super populär geworden.
Und jetzt haben wir natürlich diese Smartphone-Revolution und auf einmal sind
die Dinger total wichtig.
Und jetzt stehen wir sozusagen vor diesem Problem, okay, jetzt ist es nicht
nur coole Geräte, sondern jetzt ist es sozusagen fast unmöglich,
überhaupt noch irgendeinen Service zu starten auf diesem Planeten,
wenn du nicht auch da präsent bist und dann wird es auf einmal schwierig mit diesen Regeln.
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie geht man damit um?
Die EU hat jetzt den Ansatz gewählt, klar, hier einfach noch einen App-Store und alles wird gut.
Meiner Meinung nach wird das ein sehr schwieriger Weg werden und ganz ehrlich,
ich wäre überrascht, wenn wir hier in fünf Jahren sitzen,
also erstmal wäre ich überrascht, wenn wir hier in fünf Jahren sitzen,
aber gehen wir mal davon aus, dass wir hier in fünf Jahren noch sitzen und dann
uns die Situation anschauen und uns fragen,
was haben die EU-App-Stores jemals für uns getan und ich habe so meine Zweifel,
dass wir das dann sozusagen als den großen Wurf feiern werden.
Maybe I'm totally wrong. Das ist nur meine Erwartung.
Was ich halt lieber gesehen hätte, weil es mir auch als Consumer mehr geholfen
hätte, weil mir helfen diese anderen App-Stores überhaupt nicht.
Nichts von dem, was der DMA verspricht und nichts von dem, was das DMA eingeführt
hat, habe ich mir irgendwie herbeigesehen. Nichts davon.
Keine einzige Regelung davon, sage ich. Die brauche ich.
Was ich aber gebraucht hätte, wären Aufweichungen dieser harten Regeln,
diese Verbote von links nach draußen, dieses ganze, wer kann Payment einnehmen und so weiter.
Das hätte man ja auch direkt auf App-Stores an sich anwenden können und sagen
können, ihr dürft sowas überhaupt nur betreiben, wenn ihr folgenden Anforderungen
genügt, baut das mal in euren App-Store rein.
Weil das ist ja auch ein Feature, dass du ein Interface hast,
um Software zu installieren.
Das ist ja eines der Kernfeatures eigentlich von dem Device und das wird halt
jetzt ein bisschen unterwandert und es hat auch,
auch wenn das beileibe nicht für alles eine Ausrede ist, aber es hat auch eine
Menge Security-Implikationen und Security auf dem Smartphone ist echt ein Thema.
Ich würde so ziemlich eigentlich alles unterschreiben, was du gerade gesagt
hast, aber darum geht es ja im Kern ja irgendwie gar nicht.
Weil das, was doch jetzt Apple hier macht, ist eben, wie ich finde,
ganz klassisches Derailing.
Indem sie jetzt völlig random drei...
Potenziell sehr populäre Features sich rausrufen, die nicht das allergeringste
mit dem App Store zu tun haben.
Und da jetzt halt mit einem Fähnchen wedeln, so, so, so, guckt mal hier die
böse EU, wir können gar nicht anders und sind die Händen mit Bleiketten eingeschmiedet.
Also ich würde es nicht.
Geht doch mal nach Brüssel und revoltiert dort.
Ich würde es nicht so krass sehen. Ich habe über das iPhone Mirroring gerade
nochmal nachgedacht, weil die andere Richtung ist ja auch interessant.
Es ist ja auch interessant, wenn ein Microsoft in die Lage versetzt wird,
ein iPhone-Mirroring auf einem iPhone zu machen.
Und dann fangen die Security-Probleme natürlich an, weil dann müsste sich ja
dein Windows mit dem iPhone connecten, müsste das wiederum über eine sichere Art und Weise tun.
Und weil ja eins der Features des iPhone-Mirrorings ist,
dass das Screen ausbleibt, beziehungsweise du weiterhin den Lockscreen siehst,
bedeutet das, dass du, wenn ein Angreifer tatsächlich in der Lage ist,
das iPhone-Mirroring zu umgehen,
du dann ein echtes Sicherheitsproblem hast.
Auch dem würde ich überhaupt gar nicht widersprechen, aber darum geht es doch hier nicht.
Meine Lesart vom DMA ist nicht, dass jedes einzelne fucking Feature von IOS
völlig offen für sämtliche anderen Plattformen sein muss. Das hat nie irgendjemand gefordert.
Es geht A um Geld verdienen und es geht B primär um diese Stopshop-Geschichte.
Ich habe das DMA nicht in voller Länge gelesen und würde deswegen,
kann zu deiner Aussage nichts sagen, weil ich nicht weiß, ob das da nicht drinsteht oder nicht.
Das ist schließlich ein fettes Dokument und ich bin kein Jurist aus guten Gründen.
Wir hatten vielleicht zur Klärung im Kopf,
es gab zu Beginn die Ankündigung von Apple, dass sie diese Web-Apps auf dem
Homescreen auch im Zuge des DMA rausnehmen werden als Feature.
Wo sich ja alle erstmal gefragt haben, was soll das denn? Das war die Ankündigung
von Apple. Habt ihr nicht mitbekommen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Erzähl nochmal. Ich kann mich dunkel erinnern. Doch, doch.
Also ich rede von dem Feature, dass du eine Webseite quasi zum Homescreen hinzufügen kannst.
Achso, ja. Und das haben sie dann ja wieder zurückgebaut. Genau.
Und das, um das zu verstehen, das ist jetzt nicht nur ein Link,
der sozusagen auf dem Homescreen liegt und wenn man draufklickt,
geht dann die URL im Webbrowser auf. Das war, glaube ich, ganz zu Anfang war es mal genau das.
Sondern einerseits geht es dann sozusagen in einem eigenen App-Kontext auf.
Das heißt, die Seite sieht dann aus wie eine App, weil sie quasi im App-Selektor
als eigene Entität auftaucht.
Kein Browser-Header und so.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass es auf dem iPhone iPhone bisher immer so war,
dass ja man zwar andere Browser anbieten darf, aber sie müssen alle dieselbe
Engine, die im Betriebssystem vorliegt, nämlich WebKit benutzen, aus,
wie ich finde, ganz nachvollziehbaren Security-Erwägungen, außerdem noch mit
dem schönen Nebeneffekt, dass dann zumindest alles gleich scheiße funktioniert.
Ja, also du hast keine großen Unterschiede.
Kleine Berichtigung, nein, Sie müssen nicht WebKit benutzen.
Sie müssen nur die JavaScript-Engine von WebKit benutzen.
Den Renderer auch.
Nee, den Renderer soweit ich weiß nicht. Es geht um den ausführbaren Code und
vor allen Dingen geht es um die Just-in-Time-Kompilierung.
JavaScript ist ja nur dann schnell, wenn du tatsächlich einen Just-in-Time-Compiler hast.
Der Just-in-Time-Compiler muss aber in der Lage sein, einen signierten Code
zu erzeugen, damit der Kernel vom iOS das auch tatsächlich ablaufen lässt.
Was alles in allem dazu führt, dass du den Just-in-Time-Compiler von Apple benutzen
musst, um JavaScript laufen lassen zu können.
Also das wäre mir jetzt neu, dass irgendeine andere HTML-Rendering-Engine in
einem Browser zum Einsatz kommen darf.
Der Chrome, der da runtergeladen wird, der benutzt auch WebKit.
Ich glaube, Firefox benutzt den eigenen Renderer.
Ach Achtung, ungesundes KI-Hype-Wissen. Ich habe gerade ChatGBT4 genau dazu
gefragt und er sagt, sowohl die JavaScript-Engine muss genutzt werden,
als auch die Rendering-Engine von WebKit.
Mag aber falsch sein. Nein, das ist so.
Details, auf jeden Fall, ich wollte ja kurz erklären, was das mit dieser Web-App
und dem A und der EU zu tun hat.
Also, das war Apples Ankündigung. Warum?
Weil durchs DMA ja auch vorgeschrieben wird, und das ist ja dann auch etwas,
was sie nicht nur in der EU, sondern auch jetzt generell erlauben,
dass quasi überall, wo man die eine Browser-Engine nimmt, da muss man auch eine andere nehmen können.
Weil Markt, dass das halt alles ganz schlimm macht, anderes Thema, aber weil Markt.
Und dann hat Apple gesagt, okay, wenn wir dieses Feature, nämlich das Feature
Link auf Homescreen öffnet eine Web und die findet in einem kleinen,
aber anderen Rahmen statt.
Also nicht optischer Rahmen, sondern der Environment-Kontext dieser Web-Anwendung
ist anders als der von einer Seite,
die einfach in Safari aufgemacht wird oder irgendeinem anderen Browser.
Und um das dann quasi gemäß der DMA-Forderung nach, wo der eine Browser benutzt
werden darf oder die Browser-Engine benutzt werden darf, muss auch jeder andere benutzt werden können.
Um das dann zu garantieren, müssten sie nur, um das sozusagen zu erlauben,
dafür nochmal ein eigenes Framework aufmachen, wie sich dann diese andere Browser-Engine
da reinplagt und wie dann die Notifications gemacht werden und so weiter.
Da haben sie einfach gesagt, das Feature benutzen, also das haben sie nicht
gesagt, aber es ist ja auch so, es benutzt ja kaum einer dieses Feature.
Da schmeißen wir das Feature lieber raus, als dass wir uns da jetzt auch noch
den Aufwand machen, dafür auch nochmal ein Framework zu programmieren,
weil es lohnt sich einfach nicht.
Dann gab es Gespräche irgendwie.
Es gibt da ja schon so eine Taskforce bei der EU, die in irgendeiner Form mit
diesen Stakeholdern dann oder beziehungsweise vom DMA betroffenen Plattform-Ownern redet.
Und dann dauerte es ein paar Wochen und dann gab es die Nachricht,
ja, nee, müssen wir nicht machen, wir lassen das Feature drin.
Eine Web-App, die also quasi über ein Homescreen aufgerufen wird,
ist immer WebKit, so wie das bisher immer war.
So, und jetzt wird es halt interessant, weil...
Da fragt man sich, warum? Wenn das sonst so wichtig ist, warum ist denn das jetzt nicht wichtig?
Das geht ja aus dem DMA überhaupt nicht hervor. Da steht ja,
das muss ja immer so sein und jetzt dann halt nicht.
Das heißt, das Ganze, was es eigentlich erlaubt und was nicht,
ist am Ende nicht gesetzesbezogen, sondern, ich sag mal, mauschelbezogen.
Es ist eine Aushandlungsgeschichte.
Betrifft aber potenziell alle Features, wo in irgendeiner Form vermutet werden
könnte, dass Apple oder welcher Plattform ohne auch immer, seine eigene Plattform bevorzugt.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu diesen neuen Features. Bei Apple Intelligence nehme
ich jetzt nochmal komplett beiseite.
Ich glaube, das ist nochmal ein ganz eigener Bereich.
Aber diese Screen, was heißt das? Shareplay Screen Control?
Shareplay Screen Sharing.
Screen-Sharing, genau. Was ja quasi so ein integrierter Remote-Access mit mehr
Intelligenz auf beiden Seiten, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Also diese ganze Übergabe und wer kontrolliert was und wer sieht,
wer mich kontrolliert und so weiter. Also es ist ja irgendwie so ein intelligentes
Protokoll, was quasi diese Fernbedienung nochmal mehr macht als nur reines Screen-Sharing.
So habe ich das verstanden aus der Kino. Ich habe damit ja nicht rumgespielt mit dem Feature.
Beim iPhone-Mirroring ist es relativ klar, da kommt dein iPhone auf dein Mac
und wie du vorhin schon richtig gesagt hast, Roddy, das ist ja nicht nur so Screensharing,
sondern das ist eben, das Telefon weiß, dass es fernbedient wird,
schaltet seinen Bildschirm aus,
es gibt Drag- und Drop-Features, das heißt, das ist mehr als nur Bildschirm.
Das ist sozusagen eine, überhaupt eine sehr interessante technologische Verquickung
der Betriebssysteme an der Stelle, weil du jetzt eigentlich so das erste Mal
siehst, dass die Betriebssysteme so,
also Dreck und Drop direkt in ein anderes Betriebssystem rein.
Das hatten wir glaube ich noch gar nicht, aber das ist das, was ich schon immer wollte.
Ich wollte schon immer mit Dreck und Drop etwas auf einen anderen Mac bringen
und ich hoffe, dass wir das auch für den Mac noch bekommen.
Gab es nicht mal Soink oder wie das hieß?
Da konnte man von einem Mac auf einen anderen Dreck und droppen.
Ja, es gibt irgendwelche Tools und Party-Sachen, die irgendwas machen,
aber sozusagen auf Betriebssystem-Ebene so mit maximaler Security-Absicherung,
dass das eben auch alles erlaubt ist, sowas zu machen, weil dieses ganze,
File-Sharing und so weiter, das funktioniert einfach nie und ist einfach awkward.
Egal, auf jeden Fall, ich kann halt auf das iPhone was drauf draggen,
sprich, das ist eine intelligente Verquickung.
Da ist etwas im iOS, Da ist etwas im macOS, im iPadOS drin, was diese komplexe
Interaktion ermöglicht.
Meine Vermutung, und jetzt nehme ich mal die Position ein von Apple hat legitime Bedenken.
Wie auch immer wir jetzt darüber urteilen, ob die legitimen sind oder nicht.
Aber sagen wir mal erstmal, sie sind nicht einfach nur böse und wollen alles kaputt machen.
Und hassen alle und wollen sich jetzt rächen und ihre User aufwiegeln gegen die EU und so.
Ich frage mich, wie das funktionieren soll, aber sowas liest man ja und sieht man an Reaktionen.
Ich nehme jetzt einfach diese Position ein.
Apple ist irgendwie ein Ruhepol in dieser Welt und denkt da ganz normal drüber
nach, zusammen mit ihrer juristischen Abteilung.
Jetzt haben sie dieses Feature und dann fragen sie, ja was ist mit der EU?
Dann kommt die juristische Abteilung sagt, ja, also wie wir das DMA lesen,
könnten die dann morgen vorbeikommen und sagen, wenn ihr das macht,
dann müsst ihr das für Android aber auch machen.
Es muss möglich sein, Android genauso zu mirrorn und genauso fern zu bedienen
und drag und drop und das muss da alles drin sein.
Und zwar müsst ihr es Google ermöglichen, in euer Betriebssystem reinzugehen,
weil ihr seid ja eine dominante Plattform und wenn das nur mit eurem Telefon geht,
dann ist das eine Ausübung eurer Marktmacht und ihr seid böse und ihr riecht nach Lulu.
Und Apple lehnt sich zurück und sagt, habt ihr sie noch alle?
Das ist halt einfach mal unsere Plattform und wir wollen einfach,
dass die geil ist und es muss doch nicht überall in jede Mauerritze irgendein
Side-Party-Heini reinmarschiert kommen,
der alles nur unnötig kompliziert und schwierig macht.
Weil das halt einfach etwas ist, man kann nicht jedes Feature gleich vom ersten
Tag an so programmieren, aber das schreibt ja die DMA dann sozusagen vor.
Das muss ja sozusagen, wenn du es auf den Markt bringst, dann muss das für alle
da sein und nicht in fünf Jahren.
Und dann sagen sie halt, also wenn das so ist, dann warten wir erstmal ab,
was die Taskforce jetzt sagt, ob die jetzt genauso salomonisch entscheidet wie
bei dem Homescreen oder ob die ein Fass aufmachen und dann sagen wir,
dann lassen wir es lieber weg,
weil den Stress machen wir uns auf gar keinen Fall, jetzt hier auch noch andere
Betriebssysteme da zu integrieren.
Da muss ich kurz einhaken, bevor du dich komplett vergaloppierst.
Also meine Erfahrung mit Legal-Abteilungen ist, die kommen tatsächlich an und
sagen, das und das und das und das könnte passieren, wenn wir das machen.
Das ist auch deren Job. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, eine gute Legal-Abteilung
sagt auch, wir schätzen das Risiko so und so hoch ein.
Sprich, mit so und so viel Risiko stört sich jemand dran, zieht uns vor den
Kadi und der Kadi verklagt uns für so und so viel.
Schlechte Legal-Abteilungen sagen einfach nur, es ist alles ganz schlimm, das könnte passieren.
Insofern, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass Apple eine Legal-Abteilung hat,
die sehr aufmerksam dieses neue Gesetz
gelesen haben und die all diese Was-Könnte-Sein-Szenarien entwickelt hat.
Also es ist eine Management-Entscheidung und keine juristische Entscheidung seitens Apples.
Und das ist halt das, was mir dabei so aufstößt. Genau wie bei der PWA,
die wären einfach dieses Feature gerne losgeworden, weil sie es halt generell
irgendwie lästig und doof fanden, dass es immer noch etwas gibt,
was keine echte App ist und über ihren App-Store läuft,
sondern dass du halt, wenn du einigermaßen clever deine Webseite baust,
hast du die als quasi App irgendwie.
Das hat Apple nie cool gefunden. Ja, das siehst du auch daran,
wie der ganze Bereich Notifications völlig darbt gegenüber, wie PWAs auf Android implementiert sind.
Da klappt das nämlich plötzlich alles sehr, sehr geil und völlig reibungslos
und Apple hat das nie wirklich umarmt, dieses Feature.
Und das ist genau der Punkt, PWAs, also Progressive Web Apps eben entsprechend
auf dem Homescreen abzusetzen und in diesen Spezialmodus zu fahren.
So und hierbei ist es jetzt eben ganz genauso.
Es spielt halt jetzt einfach mal gerade Apple in die strategischen Karten rein,
hier die EU zu pieksen und hier einen Aufstand zu machen.
Also ich kann mir wirklich nicht vorstellen, dass jetzt also Google oder Microsoft
genau gesagt hätten, ja warum können wir das denn nicht von Windows aus irgendwie
steuern? Ja warum geht denn das nicht mit dem Android?
Mir fehlt wirklich total die Fantasie dafür. für.
Und so proaktiv dann hinzugehen und zu sagen, wir können wirklich nicht anders.
Also schaut euch das an. Was sollen wir nur tun? Wir arme Provinzfirma.
Das haben sie aber auch nicht gesagt. Muss man der Fairness halber dazu sagen.
Sie haben gesagt, gibt es vorerst nicht, weil wir das noch prüfen.
Also sie können sich ja auch nicht hinstellen und sagen, wir versprechen das
auf jeden Fall und dann einen Rückzieher machen, weil sie merken,
geht halt doch nicht. Sondern,
Also das ist schon auch gutes Management, dass man sagt so, hör zu,
die und die und die Feature können wir nicht versprechen aus folgenden Gründen,
aber wir versuchen es möglich zu machen.
Man muss aber sehen, die EU hat jetzt schon wegen Apple Music einen reingewirkt,
da sollen sie zwei Milliarden Euro zahlen und sie haben angekündigt,
dass sie jetzt wegen Verstöße gegen den DMA jetzt schon.
Bei dem Store, weil sie da dermaßen viele Constraints rumgebracht haben.
Wir können gerne noch mal darüber diskutieren, wo jetzt konkret die Verfehlung
liegt, weil ich glaube, das wird schwierig werden für die EU,
das rechtlich nachzuweisen.
Trotzdem, die Kommission ist da jetzt erstmal ran und hat gesagt,
ja, wir sind jetzt irgendwie dabei, das zu bestrafen.
Die potenzielle Strafe kann sein, täglich 5% ihres weltweiten Umsatzes.
Das waren mal 4.
5. 5?
Naja gut.
Also sowas wie eine Milliarde Dollar pro Tag.
Dazu muss man natürlich sagen, es gibt noch keinen Präzedenzfall,
wo sie tatsächlich diesen Verfügungsrahmen je ausgeschöpft haben.
Nee, aber Apple wird natürlich jetzt einen Scheiß tun und als nächstes gleich
ein Feature ankündigen und sagen, das bringen wir jetzt auch noch raus,
dass sie da zehn Tage später dann gleich nochmal fünf Prozent von ihrem Umsatz
pro Tag abliefern dürfen.
Das ist halt eine Zurückhaltung, die kann ich sehr gut verstehen.
So, jetzt nochmal Apple-Hut auf.
Wie willst du denn bitte jetzt noch als Firma coole neue Features planen,
die sozusagen die Integration deiner eigenen Komponenten in dein Produkt irgendwie verbessern?
Also ich meine, du willst iPhone-Mirroring haben.
Aber ja.
Du willst wahrscheinlich auch dieses Screen-Share-Play, Dingsbums-Mirroring,
Sharing, was auch immer, wie es heißt, haben.
So, Apple Intelligence können wir gleich nochmal diskutieren.
So, aber ich habe auch ein Android-Phone, ich habe auch Windows-Rechner und
die will ich da nicht mit verbinden. Will ich gar nicht.
Naja, du vielleicht nicht, aber du willst es ja überhaupt erstmal haben.
Aber Apple sagt jetzt einfach, EU-Country ist uns einfach zu gefährlich.
Wir konzentrieren jetzt mal die Innovation erstmal auf andere Bereiche.
Und ich meine, es ist nicht so, dass jetzt Europa irgendwie besonders führend
wäre in Digitalien und ich habe nicht so den Eindruck,
dass das DMA jetzt sehr viel mit ihrem ganzen, der Markt wird es richten,
hier bewirkt in positiver Hinsicht.
Vor allem, dieses ganze Versprechen, was ja in dieser ganzen Debatte,
ich guck mir mal an, wie Leute das so debattieren,
es steht ja immer so im Raum, ja so, ja Apple ist ja total böse,
weil Apple ist ja schlimm für den Kunden,
so, wo ich mich jetzt frage, was genau ist denn jetzt eigentlich schlimm für
den Kunden beim App Store gewesen?
Naja, da gibt es schon Beispiele.
Ja, was?
Also es gibt relativ viele Apps, die es nie in den App Store geschafft haben,
weil Apple gesagt hat, nö, dürfte nicht.
Apps, die beim Review-Prozess rausgekickelt worden sind, mit völlig Kafka-esken,
nicht vorhandenen Beschwerde-Scheifen.
Wo ist jetzt der Schaden? Nenn mal ein konkretes Beispiel, wo du sagen würdest.
Das ist schädlich. Unterhalte dich mal mit dem Entwickler von Ice Cubes,
was deren Lebenszeit verbrannt hat mit völlig stinknormalen Updates,
wo jedes fünfte von Apple aus irgendwelchen Gründen ihm wieder um die Ohren geschmissen wurde.
Ja, okay, manches mag ja auch gerechtfertigt gewesen sein.
Im Nachhinein immer nein, ehrlich gesagt.
Gut, okay.
In der Frühzeit der Podcast-Apps gab es sehr, sehr viele Podcast-Apps,
die massiv Probleme mit Apple hatten.
Da gab es ja eine, die wurde dann nicht in den Store reingelassen,
weil der Reviewer hat sich irgendwie,
ich glaube, der hat sich WWDC Videos abonniert und das Vorschraubild dieses
Videos hat halt den Apfel gezeigt und dann haben sie gesagt,
hier Markenrechte verletzt, du darfst nicht bei uns in den Store.
Und solche Sachen, also da sind immer wieder, vor allen Dingen hat Apple immer
wieder gesagt, erklärt das mit uns und geht nicht an die Presse.
Und den Leuten ist nie möglich gewesen, das mit Apple zu klären.
Immer erst dann, als sie an die Presse gegangen sind und einen riesen Aufwirbel
gemacht haben, ging das bei Apple dann plötzlich doch ganz einfach und durch.
Das ist halt immer schlimm für die Entwickler vor allem. Es mag auch schlimm
sein für die Kunden, die sagen, das Feature will ich aber jetzt unbedingt haben. Vielen Dank.
Aber.
Lass mich mal fertig reden. Das eigentliche Problem da ist der Chilling-Faktor.
Als Firma, die du eine Third-Party-App für iOS entwickeln willst und müsstest, sagen wir mal,
zwei Jahre in Vorleistung gehen mit einem Team von zwölf Entwicklern,
Da hast du am Ende extrem viel Geld investiert, nur um dann vielleicht bei Apple
nicht reingelassen zu werden.
Und dann überlegst du dir das dreimal, ob du das machst.
Oder du gehst halt erstmal auf eine andere Plattform und verdienst da irgendwie Geld.
Und wenn du die Entwicklungskosten drin hast, dann portierst du das halt irgendwie
in irgendwelche App-Stores, die dich vielleicht nicht reinlassen.
Und das ist für mich als Kunde ein Problem.
Weil ich als Kunde diese Software eventuell nie zu sehen bekomme,
weil die Firmen sich dreimal überlegen, ob sie es überhaupt machen.
Okay, good point.
Auf der gleichen Seite sind natürlich diese ganzen Regeln, die sie versuchen
umzusetzen, verhindern wahrscheinlich 100 mal so viel Scheißsoftware,
die niemals das Licht des Tages hätte sehen sollen.
Also ein Blick in den App Store widerspricht dir da.
Genau, ist noch genug übrig, was dann hier hätte reinkommen sollen und so.
Definitiv. Nur, was ändert jetzt sozusagen das DMA da dran?
Das DMA, also es ändert erstmal daran,
dass du potenziell weitere App-Stores hast, die potenziell diese ganzen Regeln
nicht haben, sodass du potenziell, ich sage es immer dazu,
eher in der Lage bist, eine größere Investition zu rechtfertigen,
weil du weißt, du kannst den Kram hinterher in einem App-Store verkaufen.
Also jetzt mal anderes unternehmerisches Risiko ausgeklammert,
das kann ja trotzdem immer noch tanken, aber prinzipiell hast du erstmal die eine Hürde,
Apple mag dich nicht und denkt du riechst nach Lulu, hast du erstmal außen vor.
Weil der Third-Party-App-Store wahrscheinlich sogar ein ganz zentrales Motivation
hat, exklusive Titel auf seiner Plattform zu haben.
Ja, wie gesagt, potenziell.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt hier auch so einen Punkt, wo so die Argumente auch
irgendwie auf dem Tisch liegen.
Ich meine, es ist ja interessant. Klar, die Position kann man einnehmen.
Ich sehe halt, dadurch, dass andere App-Stores erlaubt werden,
eröffnest du sozusagen aber auch vielen Apps das Tor, was die vielleicht aus
gutem Grund auch nicht unbedingt in den App-Store gekommen sind.
Es gibt in dem Sinne überhaupt gar kein Kriterium dafür, was für Apps jetzt
überhaupt erlaubt sein dürfen oder nicht.
Also es gibt sozusagen kein, also vorher war das Problem, dass nur Apple diese Kriterien festlegt.
Und was mich eigentlich am meisten gestört hat, ist für die Entwickler,
es gibt keine verbindlichen Absagen,
also man könnte ja zum Beispiel einen Rechtsanspruch einführen,
zu sagen, wenn was abgelehnt wird,
dann muss das auch aus nachvollziehbaren, rechtlich formalen,
benannten Gründen geschehen, die sozusagen nicht nur Apple-Rules sind,
sondern die Market-Rules sind.
Dass man eben konkret für solche App-Sources macht.
Oder Entwickler haben das Anrecht vorher so einen Plan prüfen zu lassen und
sich den vorab absegnen zu lassen, ob das generell schon mal hingeht.
Also diese Problematik. Während wir jetzt quasi als Antwort haben,
na dann machen wir einfach Wild West.
So, dann mal her mit den Porn-Apps und den Wettanbietern und volles Programm
und dann läuft das schon. Bitcoin, volles Programm.
Du, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, ob ein Porno-Store, Porno-App-Store eine gute Idee ist.
Vielleicht ja, vielleicht nein. Wird es dort Apps geben? Wahrscheinlich schon.
Werden die erfolgreich sein? Keine Ahnung. Ich denke, auf das Experiment käme es an.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Was du ansprichst, hätte so ein Gesetz vielleicht auch
vorsehen sollen, dass es eine Möglichkeit gibt, sich einzuklagen?
Wäre auch mal eine interessante Frage. Also so nach der Art,
ihr lehnt mich aus blöden Gründen ab, scheiß drauf, ich gehe zum nächsten Gericht
und die sagen dann, Apple, ihr müsst aber. Aber ihr habt keine guten Gründe.
Aber das steht wahrscheinlich in dem Gesetz nicht drin, was wahrscheinlich auch schade ist.
Also der interessante Spin ist ja, danke für den Begriff Schilling-Effekt nochmal.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz erläutert, das wird ja teilweise auch fälschlich,
glaube ich, Mao zugeordnet, bestraf Vereinen, erziehe 100.
Also mach eine besonders abschreckende Gesetzgebung,
Überwachungsmechanismen sozialer Druck und dann werden die Leute sich schon
alle vernünftig verhalten.
Dass Apple ja gerade versucht, dieses Narrativ jetzt gerade gegen den EU-Store zu drehen.
Also der DMA hätte jetzt einen solchen Chilling-Effekt, dass Apple jetzt schon
bei den allereinfachsten Features plötzlich zusammenzuckt und Angst hat,
noch irgendwas zu chippen an Innovation.
Und schuld ist halt die EU durch den Chilling-Effekt.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob Apple jetzt dieses Narrativ tatsächlich fährt Oder ob
Leute im Windschatten von Apple segeln und diesen Chilling-Effekt jetzt postulieren.
Keine Ahnung. Aber das sehe ich natürlich genauso.
Also das ist auch ein Chilling-Effekt, wo man natürlich ganz klar sagen kann,
findet die Innovation dann außerhalb der EU statt.
Weil innerhalb der EU die Leute sagen, ja, aber DMA, vielleicht lieber doch
nicht. Kann durchaus sein.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein schwieriges Feld und es ist auf jeden Fall ein
Showdown und beide Seiten müssen sich hier glaube ich ein bisschen bekennen.
Man kann Apple auf jeden Fall vorwerfen, dass sie sich ein bisschen ohne Not
jetzt sozusagen in diese legislative Regelung haben drängen lassen,
weil sie schon auch bestimmte Dinge vielleicht etwas liberaler hätten handhaben können.
Nur, dann ist halt auch die Frage, wo fängst du an, wo hörst du auf?
Oft hört man ja auch, dass irgendwie die finanzielle Beteiligung,
das will ich erstmal sehen, dass die anderen Stores da finanziell sehr viel
besser abschneiden für die Entwickler letzten Endes, die da posten.
Weil für Entwickler in dem Sinne und schon gar nicht für kleine Entwickler ist
halt dieses ganze Gesetz nicht gemacht.
Nee, es ist auch, also wenn du jetzt Steam zum Beispiel anguckst,
der Steam Store nimmt auch 30 Prozent.
Nintendo nimmt und Sony, ich glaube für die Konsolen, für die Lizenznehmer,
die nehmen sogar mehr als 30, aber auch mindestens 30. Also ich meine, man.
Sogar der Epic Store nimmt sogar fünf.
Nee, der Epic Store nimmt weniger, weil sie ja versucht haben,
gegen den Steam Store anzustinken und eine der Maßnahmen war,
weniger Prozent zu nehmen.
Nur das rechnet sich halt nicht, wenn du einen Markt
Und wo du mit einer Werbemaßnahme richtig viele Kopien einsammelst,
während der andere Marketplace halt irgendwie relativ unbekannt ist und da halt niemand ist.
Da ist dann auch egal, ob sie jetzt 30 oder 15 oder nur 10 Prozent nehmen.
Also ich glaube, dass es so sehr wehtut, so von der Entwicklerseite aus zu sagen,
ja 30 Prozent passt schon, muss man aber trotzdem sagen,
okay, die 30 Prozent sind nicht wirklich das Problem,
sondern das Problem ist wirklich diese… Das sind ja auch.
Für die meisten gar nicht 30 Prozent, das sind 15 Prozent.
Für die Kleinen, ja, mittlerweile.
Naja, bis zu einer Million Umsatz.
Jaja, wenn du auf Kleinunternehmerregelung, heißt bei Apple anders, aber ja, es ist nur so,
das ist nicht das Problem, sondern das Problem ist, dass der App Store bei Apple
und der ganze Review-Prozess halt einfach extrem unüberschaubar ist und risikoreich ist.
Und wie gesagt, wenn du zwei Jahre an der App gebastelt hast und kriegst sie
dann nicht mehr in den Store, dann kannst du halt deinen Laden zumachen. Das ist einfach so.
Also ich empfehle dafür auch die letzte Folge vom Accidental Tech Podcast,
da führt finde ich Marco Arment das nochmal ganz gut aus, dass wir einfach alle
völlig klar in dieser Welt leben, ja in dem Apple iOS Store,
da sind diese 30-15% halt schon immer so gottgegeben und völlig richtig.
Warum ist das Ganze nie auf macOS so gewesen?
Also was macht denn iOS jetzt eigentlich so wirklich anders und unterschiedlich
zu dem, was wir halt auf dem Mac schon immer hatten, dass du einfach Dinge installieren kannst?
Ja, es hat viele technische Implikationen und Sicherheit und Security,
aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass MacBooks jetzt nicht irgendwie auch sicher
sein sollten und wollten.
Naja, also einerseits gibt es ja einen App Store auf macOS und aus eigener Erfahrung...
Aber da werden ja keine 30 Prozent gezogen. Doch, doch. Wenn nur... 15. 15?
Also 15 und 30 ab einem bestimmten Umsatz.
Naja, also 30 Prozent, wenn du aus der kleinen Unternehmerregelung rausfällst.
Als dieser Mac App Store aufgemacht hat, also ich meine damals hatte ich ja
noch eine App, die wurde verkauft und die habe ich also dann tatsächlich auch
zum Start des Stores in den Mac App Store bekommen.
Und ich muss sagen, der Umsatz über den Mac App Store war immer eine Größenordnung
über das, was du mit einer normalen Webseite und einfach so und klick dir hier
deinen Lizenzcode machen konntest.
Weil einfach die, wie viele Leute du erreichst mit dem Mac App Store halt eine
ganz andere Hausnummer ist.
Trotzdem hast du halt dieses, und das war halt Reviews, das war halt beim Mac
App Store immer so ein Problem. Problem, jemand findet einen Bug,
du behebst den, haust eine neue Version raus.
In der Sekunde, in der du sie rausgehauen hast, können die Leute,
die normal runtergeladen haben, auch direkt die Version haben.
Und da springt dann auch der Updater an und so weiter.
Bei Apple hängt das Ding dann erstmal in der Review-Queue fest.
Und es gab halt Zeiten, da war definitiv iOS Apple viel, viel wichtiger als der Mac-App-Store.
Und dann hing so eine Version halt mal vier Wochen in der Review-Queue fest.
Das ist irgendwie, und das ist halt so der Punkt.
Und dann hast du halt diese beiden Versionen, die du versuchst zu jonglieren. und also das.
Aber das hat sich ja auch gebessert und das sind ja sozusagen,
also das sind ja vorübergehende Probleme.
Ich kenne die neuen Zahlen nicht, ich weiß nicht.
Da wird wenig drüber geklagt.
Wie die Review-Zeiten jetzt beim Mac App Store sind, ich weiß, dass bei iOS,
durchaus sehr, sehr weit unten ist, ein bis zwei Tage, das ist überhaupt kein
Problem mehr, zumindest dann, wenn man Apple auch ordentlich mitteilt,
was man denn in der Version alles geändert hat.
Kann durchaus sein, wenn man nur sagt, Updates irgendwie ...
Bugfixes und sonst was, dass das halt ein bisschen weiter hinten in der Queue landet.
Wir haben ein bisschen aufgeräumt, geputzt und die Fenster sauber gemacht in dieser neuen Version.
Genau, das mögen sie überhaupt nicht.
Aber Produktmanager sind in der Regel halt auch einfach zu faul,
um sich Release Notes auszudenken. Aber das ist egal.
Ja, also die Diskussion, die bei ATP geführt wird, die verfolge ich natürlich auch mit Interesse.
Wobei man halt auch sagen muss, bei den dreien, sie verstehen auch nicht wirklich,
wie die EU funktioniert.
Also wenn sie da immer so vom Government reden und so, da rolle ich dann doch
schon so ein bisschen mit den Augen, aber wo sollen sie es halt auch hernehmen.
Also diese Sicht, dass das jetzt sozusagen so ein klarer Governmental Approach
wäre, dafür ist die EU einfach zu sehr Kompromissgehusche.
Und am Ende weiß man,
dass komplexe Gesetzgebungen der EU halt sehr verwässert sind und nicht so zielgerichtet
sind, wie das auf nationaler Ebene der Fall ist.
Was ich in der Tat mag bei denen ist, dass sie sehr häufig diesen Begriff reinbringen,
so how Apple is reading the room.
Das heißt also, versteht Apple eigentlich, was gerade so die mentale Gefühlslage
der EU und von EU-Bürgern ist und dann bringen sie auch irgendwie so,
also ich glaube die EU-Bürger mögen ihre Regierung da ganz gerne,
was natürlich nicht die Regierung ist.
Und ich habe dann mal meinen kleinen vor Augen, der ist jetzt fünf,
da waren wir hier auf dem Markt und das war direkt vor der Europawahl und irgendjemand
hat ihm eine Europa-Flagge in die Hand gedrückt und da lief er so laut skandierend
über den Markt, Europa, Europa, ja, super.
Wenn man irgendwie Kinder-Videos in dieser Welt noch posten könnte,
würde ich das jetzt mal hochladen, das ist wirklich episch.
Das könnte man sofort für jede EU-Kampagne einsetzen.
Ja, also dieses Reading the Room.
Also hat Apple da wirklich eine Sensorik dafür, wie die EU eigentlich tickt
und was Europäer jetzt wichtig oder nicht wichtig finden?
Naja gut, ich meine, wenn du dir das anguckst, die Amis haben zwei Parteien, ein Land zwei Parteien.
Europa hat was, 27 Länder und jedes Land hat irgendwie fünf Parteien oder so,
die irgendwie wichtig sind und irgendwie mitspielen.
Das ist halt einfach eine ganz andere Gemengelage.
Ich meine, dafür funktioniert es auch noch relativ gut und ich bin ja nun ganz
weit davon entfernt, in so ein EU-Bashing reinzugehen.
Ich finde nur generell, dass Europa sich einfach im Technologiebereich nicht besonders hervortut.
Also so mit dem Internet und all dem, also man ist mal schnell bei irgendwelchen
Debatten alles zu verbieten oder irgendeinem Hype ganz viel Geld in den Rachen zu schieben,
ohne dass da irgendwas bei rauskommt.
Das hatten wir nicht schon alles, europäische Suchmaschinen und AI-Projekte
und keine Ahnung, nix ist dabei rausgekommen und das liegt halt auch einfach
daran, dass wir hier gar nicht die richtigen Bedingungen haben.
Und ich sage dir, sowas wie das DMA schafft auch nicht unbedingt jetzt die Bedingungen,
die alle wollen, wo sie sich denken, oh ja, Europa, da müsste man mal jetzt
so ein Internetkonzern aufbauen, das wäre bestimmt genau der richtige Ort.
Naja, gut.
Tja, soviel zur Wirtschaftsförderung. Na gut.
Wollen wir nochmal, das haben wir eben ein bisschen übersprungen,
über noch die neuesten Erkenntnisse zur Apple Private Cloud reden.
Bevor wir das tun, würde ich kurz das EU-Thema noch verlängern und uns mal fragen,
weil das weiß ich nämlich jetzt auch nicht, warum, was könnte jetzt sozusagen
ein gutes Argument sein, also davon ausgehend, dass das nicht alles nur ein
böser Ploy von Apple ist, aber warum ist Apple Intelligence…,
Jetzt auch in puncto DMA ein Problem. Das kann ich nur nicht so ganz nachvollziehen.
Also da wäre jetzt meine Arbeitstätigkeit, da könnte ich es fast noch am ehesten verstehen,
weil man da sagen würde, okay, das ist ein Framework, wo viele Apps und viele
Firmen von profitieren würden, wenn sie auf die lokalen, in Klammern,
Modelle möglichst früh und umfänglich zugreifen könnten,
um hier quasi so das nächste App-Monopol gleich zu verhindern.
Weil Apple Music wird dann vielleicht in einer perfekten Welt doch andere Features
machen können als Spotify.
Also meine Vermutung ist folgende.
Nämlich, dass Apple hat ja großspurig
angekündigt, was alles lokal auf dem Device denn dann gemacht wird.
Und nur um dann hinterher nachzuschieben, naja, so manche Dinge müssen wir doch in der Cloud machen.
Das haben sie aber in der Keynote auch schon sehr klar gesagt.
Jaja, aber sie haben ja sehr, sehr viel darauf gebaut, dass sehr viel lokal läuft.
Was ich allerdings glaube ist, dass also besonders am Anfang werden sie wahrscheinlich
lokal gar nicht so viel machen,
weil sie überhaupt erstmal gucken müssen, wie sich der ganze Scheiß bewährt
und sie wahrscheinlich auch relativ schnell in schneller Abfolge neue Modelle
pushen müssen und anlernen.
Und deswegen glaube ich und ich glaube auch, dass je nachdem,
was für ein Device du hast, halt auch der Anteil von dem, was lokal läuft und
von dem, was in der Cloud läuft, unterschiedlich ist.
Und sie, glaube ich, einfach davon ausgehen,
dass sie ihre Cloud in Europa hosten müssten, um diese Features in Europa entsprechend
datenschutzkonform anbieten zu dürfen.
Und ich nehme mal an, dass sie im ersten Schritt darauf keinen Bock haben.
Aber sie haben doch so sehr laut darauf hingewiesen, dass ja eben dort überhaupt
nichts gespeichert wird, sondern dass es eigentlich nur eine quasi eine externalisierte
CPU ist, die zur Laufzeit halt Informationen hat und sofort danach wieder vergisst.
Alles richtig, aber die Daten fließen doch nach Amerika.
Ja, genau.
Egal, ob du jetzt Apple glaubst, dass sie nichts speichern oder ob du ihnen nicht glaubst.
Die Juristen, meine innere Juraabteilung sagt dir,
die Daten fließen nach Amerika und damit hast du dieses und jenes und folgendes
Problem in diesen und jenen und folgenden Gesetzen und das kriegst du nicht wegdiskutiert. Ja.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass bevor Apple nicht die entsprechenden Cloud-Server
in Europa installiert hat, am Laufen hat, wird Europa auch keine Apple Intelligence bekommen.
Da mögen es manchmal schon auch solche Faktoren reinkommen. Ich habe jetzt gelesen,
dass die ganzen Data Centers, die sie dafür aufbauen, komplett auf erneuerbare Energie laufen.
Alle tun das jetzt schon.
Ja gut, das ist...
Also nicht der Konkurrenzen, also von Apple meinst du?
Ja, alle iCloud. Ja gut, dann mag es sein.
Dass es natürlich auch in Europa irgendwie schwerer, Fragezeichen herzustellen wäre.
Nein, es ist weltweit. Ja, leichter.
Weltweit machen sie das.
Nein, das ist glaube ich auch nicht das Thema, sondern das Thema ist,
dass du sowas, also ich meine, viele Technologien bieten sie erst in Amiland
an und rollen sie dann woanders aus.
Bieten sie erst auf Englisch an, rollen sie dann in andere Sprachen aus.
Deswegen wirst du sehen, dass sie Apple Intelligence erstmal nur in Amiland machen.
Und wenn du dann dein neues iPhone mit dem neuen iOS in Jamaika kaufst,
wo das niemanden interessiert, dann kannst du natürlich Apple Intelligence benutzen,
weil das spricht dann mit den amerikanischen Datacentern und es interessiert
niemanden und alles ist gut.
Aber in Europa gucken die halt anders drauf.
Und ich glaube, dass Apple da auch dann einfach mal sagt so,
das wollen wir nicht anfassen, bis wir uns da nicht hundertpro sicher sind, dass das passt.
Es wird ein halbes Jahr später wahrscheinlich kommen. Aber ich gehe schwer davon
aus, dass sie in Europa entsprechende Rechenzentrumskapazitäten aufbauen müssen
und dass sie es dann auch tun werden.
Also es hört sich erstmal total plausibel an.
Aber es ist noch ein bisschen unklar, inwiefern das jetzt mit der DMA kollidieren
kann aus Apples Perspektive, aber irgendwas ist ja immer.
Naja, es muss ja nicht die DMA sein.
Doch, sie haben ja explizit gesagt, das Feature kommt erstmal nicht wegen DMA.
Auch wenn sie sowieso gesagt haben, es kommt sowieso erstmal nur in den USA
und ist auch erstmal nur auf Englisch.
Das heißt, die Einzigen, die dann quasi offiziell darunter leiden müssten,
ist Irland. Ausgerechnet.
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch eine GDPR zum Beispiel. Das ist jetzt keine DMA,
aber spielt in der Sache ja sicherlich auch mit.
Ja gut, aber sie haben ja nicht gesagt, nicht aus Datenschutzgründen,
sondern aus DMA-Gründen.
Es hat immer was mit diesem Plattform-Macht-Ding zu tun.
Da würde ich ihnen zugestehen, okay, das haben sie jetzt so gesagt und das ist
vielleicht auch vereinfachend gesagt und einfach nur quasi der Schirm unter
diese ganzen EU-Regelungen,
die komische Dinge von uns verlangen, die wir als Amerikaner gar nicht einsehen.
Also ist unklar, müssen wir nicht weiter drüber reden. Aber wir sollten dann
vielleicht wirklich mal über Private Cloud Compute sprechen.
Private Cloud Compute, das ist der merkwürdige Name, den sich Apple ausgedacht
hat für diese Apple Intelligence Backend-Lösung,
die quasi Requests, die sie eigentlich gerne auf ihren geilen CPUs lokal ausführen würden,
dann eben doch in die Cloud schmeißen, weil entweder du das auf dem Device machst,
was es nicht kann oder weil die Anfrage aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen gerade
nicht ausgeführt werden kann oder das Gerät generell zu schwach ist dafür.
Und sie haben dazu einen relativ langen Blogpost veröffentlicht,
wo sie beschreiben, was eigentlich ihre Ziele dabei jetzt sind und wie sie das technisch lösen.
Ich muss zugeben, mich nicht zu sehr reingelesen zu haben, aber als Abstract
vielleicht mal generell.
Sie bauen also eine Server-Infrastruktur auf, vermutlich, also Sie sagen ja mit Apple Silicon.
Das ist die Frage, welches Silicon das so sein könnte.
Naja, alles was Neural Engine hat.
Ja klar, aber was konkret? Also sozusagen welches Apple Silicon kommt da jetzt konkret zum Einsatz?
Ich habe da so eine Vermutung, was es vielleicht sein könnte,
aber man weiß es halt nicht genau.
Ich nehme an, sie werden den M4 nehmen.
Weil der M4 ist ja derzeit nur als kleine Version quasi verfügbar,
den gibt es ja nicht in Pro und gibt es auch nicht in Max und schon gar nicht in Ultra.
Nicht für Consumer, aber intern werden sie doch da wahrscheinlich schon was fertig haben, oder?
Ja, aber sie werden jetzt die Kapazität davon, von der neuesten Sache,
nicht auf ihre Server schmeißen.
Sie haben ja im Prinzip, also meiner Meinung nach, der wahrscheinlichste Kandidat,
wenn sie nicht wirklich was speziell dafür gebaut haben, wären die M2 Ultra.
Weil die überhaupt in Stückzahlen herzustellen, macht für sie Sinn,
weil sie die dann sozusagen billiger nutzen können. Ja, aber sie brauchen viele Cores.
Ja, aber die als Max, sprich die Cores einzeln zu benutzen.
Also ich glaube, wenn ein Prozessor nicht gut genug ist, um mit all seinen Neural-Prozessoren
den Kram zu machen, dann hilft dir auch der Ultra nicht.
Und ich glaube auch, dass der Ultra in der Herstellung ganz schön teuer ist.
Und dass wenn du den wirklich in Stückzahlen in ein Datacenter tun willst,
bist du wahrscheinlich besser bedient, wenn du ganz viele Module nur mit einem Max machst.
Gut, was auch immer. Aber ich denke, diese Generation, die abgehangene Generation,
die sie schon in Massen herstellen und mit denen sie jetzt nicht die allerneuesten
Fabs blockieren, die sie jetzt brauchen, um iPhone und neue Macs auszurollen.
Das scheint so, als hättest du recht gehabt. Heise hat damals geschrieben.
Behauptet zumindest, achso, die Gerüchte scheinen nun.
Scheinen sich zu bestätigen. M2 Ultra. Naja, also aus meiner Sicht macht das
Sinn, wenn sie den nehmen würden, weil...
Vielleicht hat er sich auch nicht verkauft.
Nein, natürlich ist ja klar, dass der Ultra nicht in großen Stückzahlen rausgeht,
aber wenn sie den halt in großen Stückzahlen für ihre eigenen Rechenzentren
produzieren, wird die Produktion ja für sie insgesamt billiger.
Deswegen macht es halt Sinn.
Anyway, bleiben wir bei dieser Private Cloud Computing, was es Also sie haben
eigene Server, das macht Sinn mit ihrem Silicon,
da haben sie alles unter Kontrolle und vor allem haben sie halt die ganze Sicherheitsarchitektur
mit der Secure Enclave und sie sind in der Lage dafür ein Betriebssystem zu
machen und das ist das, was sie in diesem Blogpost beschreiben,
was komplett stateless läuft,
was keinerlei Massenspeicher hat, wo ein Request reinkommt, einmal nur durchs
RAM fegt und wieder rauskommt.
Und die Besonderheit ist, dass halt der gesamte Code gesigned ist,
der auf diesem System läuft.
Das heißt, sie haben halt quasi so ein abgespecktes iOS genommen,
wo sie vor allem viel weggelassen haben, wo also sozusagen nur noch ein bisschen
Krypto und Performance und Core-Kram und Internet dabei ist und.
Die ganze Sicherheitsarchitektur basiert darauf, dass halt ausschließlich Signed-Code
läuft und dass du quasi an einer Signatur nachweisen kannst,
welches Image dort läuft.
Und wenn die Devices und die dort laufenden Versionen auf den Servern,
die werden regelmäßig gepostet,
die Telefone können sich diese Hashes reinholen und mit jedem Request kannst
du sozusagen sicherstellen,
ob der kryptografische Hash,
der dort zurückkommt von deinem API-Call auch wirklich einer ist,
der mit den Publizierten korrespondiert.
Und das ist sozusagen auch das Vehikel, mit dem sie ihre Software durch Dritte
überprüfbar machen, weil sie nämlich diese Images, also das,
was tatsächlich auf diesen Servern läuft, veröffentlichen.
Also du kannst quasi kryptografisch sicherstellen, dass das Image,
was Apple veröffentlicht, auch das ist, was da läuft, weil nur das,
da setzt es jetzt ein bisschen bei mir aus, das zu erklären,
aber im Kern gibt es quasi eine kryptografische Absicherung,
dass die Maschinen beweisen können, welches Image sie fahren und du kannst eben
genau dieses Image dann auch finden auf den Servern, runterladen und ein Security
Professional kann das Ding halt,
Boxen und treten und irgendwie analysieren, bis der Arzt kommt.
Du müsstest dann natürlich mit einer Testsuite drüber gehen und gucken,
ob du die gleichen Ergebnisse kriegst, wenn du die gleichen Anfragen machst.
Weil du kannst dich ja nicht darauf verlassen, dass das, was er behauptet,
was er laufen lässt, auch das ist, was er laufen gelassen hat.
Doch, du kannst, das ist genau das, was sie hier beschreiben,
dass du sicher sein kannst, dass genau der Code dort läuft.
Das mit dem Code-Signing ist ja jetzt auch keine neue Technologie,
die ist ja super abgehangen und da bin ich jetzt,
also außer macOS ist ja alles gecode-signed irgendwie und aber auch große Teile
von macOS sind gecode-signed und zumindest alles,
was im Kernel läuft und alle Extensions und so weiter.
Also das beeindruckt mich jetzt noch nicht so.
Davon wäre ich jetzt einfach mal ausgegangen, dass sie das so machen.
Wie das mit diesen Images ist, finde ich ein bisschen komisch.
Also weil einerseits bedeutet es ja, dass wenn Sie die Images veröffentlichen,
dass Sie dann im Prinzip auch Ihren Code offenlegen, dann ist es ja quasi Open Source.
Ja, also nicht der Source, sondern halt das compiled Ergebnis.
Das compiled Binary, aber ich meine, wer halbwegs was versteht von der Sache,
kann aus einem compiled Binary auch wieder Source machen. Aber das ist so.
Das tun Sie. Das machen Sie. Das ist Teil dieses Prozesses.
Die Frage ist, die sich mir dann noch stellt, veröffentlichen Sie dann auch
die Parameter der verwendeten Models?
Also sprich das Model selber, was da läuft?
Die Werte der neuronalen Netze etc.? Weil das wäre ja auch schon interessant, sage ich mal.
Das weiß ich nicht. Also ehrlich gesagt, mir geht die Beschreibung ein bisschen over my head.
Ich habe mir das nicht im Detail alles komplett durchgelesen,
sondern mehr so das Management Summary in mich reingezogen.
Das ist ein relativ langer Blogartikel mit viel Kryptokram, aber die wesentlichen
Features sind halt im Wesentlichen die überprüfbar.
Sie haben ein Modell gebaut, mit dem du eben sicherstellen kannst,
dass das Stück Software, mit dem dein Telefon redet, eine wohl definierte Version von Code ist,
wo auch nichts nachträglich nachgeladen werden kann, die also sozusagen keinen
Code Injection, kein JIT und so weiter erlaubt.
Und wo du eben genau sicherstellen kannst, dass das auch gerade eine offiziell
von Apple supportete Version ist, weil sie regelmäßig die veröffentlicht und
das halt runter bis auf den Note.
Auf denen das läuft. Das ist quasi ihr Versprechen und ich denke mal,
sie werden sich da schon ein paar Gedanken zu gemacht haben,
das mögen jetzt die Security-Experten, die da noch ein bisschen tiefer drinstecken,
bewerten, wie das ist, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt bisher nichts in der Richtung gehört,
dass jemand dieses Modell an sich anzweifelt.
Die gehen da schon sehr weit und so weit geht halt auch keiner.
Wir hatten ja hier in der Debatte in der letzten Woche, hieß es ja noch so,
ja, die anderen, die schreiben ja auch nichts auf die Festplatte.
Ja, mag sein, dass sie nichts auf die Festplatte schreiben,
aber keiner der Server, mit denen du da redest, authentifiziert sich dir gegenüber
und sagt, genau, ich bin diese Version und ich habe genau,
fahre genau dieses Image und du kannst das kryptografisch sicherstellen,
weil nur ich kann mit diesem Hash auf deinen Request antworten,
mit dem ich beweise, dass ich dieses Image bin.
So mal einfach gesagt, so funktionieren ja kryptografische Absicherungen.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Software ist in der Lage zu beweisen,
dass sie sie ist und du kannst exakt genau dann diese Software so vom Server
runterladen, testen und überprüfen, ob die Aussagen, die Apple darüber macht, nämlich dass,
wenn du dann ein Datenrequest reinschmeißt, dass da nichts passiert.
Außer der Antwort, nichts irgendwo anders hinfließt, das Ding macht keine Kommunikation
irgendwo hin und kann sowieso auf nichts schreiben, weil dann gar nichts ist zum Schreiben.
Wie sie das beweisen wollen, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber ist so.
Ehrlich gesagt, wenn das alles mal raus ist und man da mal gucken kann,
dann werde ich mir das nochmal angucken und versuchen zu verstehen.
Aber man kann auch sagen, das ist auf jeden Fall ein bold Move,
den sie da machen, weil sie quasi eine komplett neue Server-Architektur rausbringen,
die es so in der Form bisher noch nicht gab, meines Wissens.
Vielleicht gab es das im experimentellen, akademischen Teil so als Proof of
Concept, aber halt bestimmt nicht jetzt Large Scale mit wir bedienen jetzt mal eine Milliarde User.
Und generell finde ich das ja einen guten Ansatz, weil sie sagen ja gar nicht, vertraut uns einfach,
sondern ihr könnt uns so weit vertrauen, wie uns Security Professionals,
die exakt genau diesen Code unter die Lupe nehmen, vertrauen. So.
Und das ist halt irgendwie as far as you can go. Also darüber hinaus musst du
dann halt sagen, so ja nö, dann gehe ich lieber zu Google.
Die versprechen mir gar nichts, da weiß ich zumindest woran ich bin.
Gut, ich verstehe die Leute nicht, die Google vertrauen, aber das ist eine ganz
andere Diskussion. Ich auch nicht.
Das ist eine ganz, ganz andere Diskussion.
Ja, wie gesagt, also wenn da die Details mal wirklich offen liegen,
werde ich mir das mal angucken, weil ich das schon sehr, sehr spannend finde.
Und wenn Sie tatsächlich eine Möglichkeit gefunden haben, glaubwürdig zu beweisen,
dass das, was Sie behaupten, was da drauf läuft, auch tatsächlich da drauf läuft.
Also ich meine, darüber hinaus gäbe es noch Open Source. Ja,
Open Source ist ja schön und gut.
Ich meine, das ist wie bei Wahlcomputern, da kann die Software noch so Open
Source sein, wenn du nicht beweisen kannst, dass der Code, den du gereviewt
hast, hinterher auch auf dem Gerät läuft, hast du nichts gewonnen.
Und das kannst du halt, das ist auch nicht so einfach, würde ich mal sagen.
Also ich finde das irgendwie interessant, was da kommt Gut, wollen wir dann
Apple-Thema erstmal beenden?
Ich hatte noch einen Punkt Wir hatten in der letzten Sendung ja noch die Frage
Okay, könnte nicht jetzt dieses Cloud Computing oder Private Cloud Computing,
kompensieren, wenn das lokale iPhone nicht schnell genug ist?
Also diese 8 GB Gigabyte-RAM-Debatte, die wir da hatten.
Das wird es tun?
Apple sagt nein.
Apple sagt nein. Apple sagt, es ist derzeit nicht vorgesehen,
dass du auf einem 4, 6, was auch immer Gigabyte-Modell dann halt mehr in die
Private Cloud auslagerst, sondern sie sagen nein, diese lokalen Instanzen sind
so integraler Bestandteil,
der Strategie, dort läuft dann eben gar nichts.
Und da kommt eben genau das her, dass dann selbst ein iPhone 15 es nicht kann,
sondern nur ein Pro, weil das halt 8 Gig RAM hat. Das mögen sie irgendwann mal ändern.
Derzeit ist es so. Sprich, wenn sie LLM dann vielleicht doch irgendwie lokal
so runtergekocht kriegen, dass es dann auch irgendwie auf 6 oder 4 performant läuft.
Naja, ich meine, das ist halt auch ein Unterschied, ob eine UI in zig Millisekunden
reagiert oder erst einen Roundtrip zu irgendwelchen Apple-Servern in Kalifornien braucht.
Ja, derzeit gibt es den ja aber halt auch. Also man wird natürlich jetzt mit
gesundem Menschenverstand versuchen zu argumentieren, derzeit habe ich genau
dieselbe Latenz und Scheißergebnisse.
Dann hätte ich doch gerne meinetwegen die doppelte Latenz, aber sehr gute Ergebnisse.
Ja, das halte ich ja aus als Nutzer, aber so tickt Apple halt nicht.
Naja, es kommt natürlich noch ein Kostenfaktor dazu. Alles, was du auf dem Device
rechnen kannst, erzeugt keinen Aufwand in deinem Datacenter.
Und letzter Punkt, der mittlerweile bekannt ist, was für Trainingsdaten haben
sie eigentlich jetzt genommen, gerade für ihr sogenanntes Foundation Model,
was quasi ihr Basic LLM ist.
Und da ist dann also die Aussage, sowohl lizenzierte Daten als auch frei im
Internet verfügbare Ressourcen.
Also sprich, sie haben wie alle anderen auch das Internet abgegrast.
Man kann jetzt ein Opt-out machen. Das ist also jetzt dokumentiert,
wie du jetzt also in deinen HTML-Head reinschreibst. Nein, Apple,
ich möchte nicht für Trainings hier halten, was natürlich komplett pointless
ist, weil es ist ja schon passiert.
Für eine neue Seite kannst du das machen, aber für alles vorherige kannst du
davon ausgehen, so Apple hat es schon abgesagt.
Naja, sie werden ja ab und zu retrainieren, also neu trainieren und dafür werden
sie wahrscheinlich auch neu Aber ich die.
Debatte wirklich nie verstanden habe. Also das freie Internet sollte sich dadurch
definieren, dass es eben nur mal frei ist. Also da kommt ja wieder mein Bibliotheksherz durch.
Aber Copyright.
Die Künstler. Die Künstler, ja. Achso.
Ja, das ist schwieriger.
Ja, man veröffentlicht will aber nicht, dass es jemand sieht.
Das ist für mich auch nicht nachvollziehbar. Aber gut.
Ich finde auch dieses Trainieren auf gar nicht so problematisch,
muss ich sagen, wie die Zugriffe, die bisher schon immer möglich waren.
Gibt es sehr viel mehr Probleme mit irgendwie Kopien von deinem Inhalt im Internet,
die sich ohnehin nicht an irgendwelche Header halten.
Aber auf jeden Fall, die Frage ist jetzt beantwortet, ja, Apple macht das jetzt
nicht anders. Hier hätte man ja demonstrativ einen anderen Weg gehen können.
Wir machen jetzt einen Special Deal mit der der New York Times und mit.
Das Gerücht gab es aber, dass sie das auch haben. Also ich glaube,
dass das sozusagen eine Mischung aus allem sein wird.
Aber wenn sie jetzt irgendwie Wikidata scrapen, irgendwie kann ich nur sagen, ja, go for it.
Dafür ist es ja da.
Dass sie da jetzt keine detaillierte Liste machen mit, die haben wir so und
die haben wir so. Naja, mal gucken.
Das klingt mir aber auch sehr nach Einzelfallentscheidung, wann es okay ist
und wann es nicht okay ist.
Ja, braucht man vielleicht auch. Naja.
Gut, gut.
Dann erstmal Schluss hier mit Äppeleien. Wir haben jetzt noch ein paar Bereiche.
Ach nee, stimmt, eine Äppelei haben wir noch.
Wollen wir die nochmal abfegen, Roddy?
Dann haben wir das ganze Äppel-Thema.
Ich hab auch noch eine.
Du hast auch noch eine? Ich hab auch noch eine.
Ja.
Okay.
Aber dauert auch nicht lange.
Die steht aber nicht in der Liste.
Doch, die steht in der Liste. Ach doch, da.
Oh ja, Entschuldigung. Lalalalala. Na komm, dann machen wir die beiden Äppeleien
noch und dann reden wir über die anderen Sachen.
Können die Leute genug skippen und kommen nicht in Verwirrung.
Wer will zuerst?
Ich mach mal einfach meins, weil das geht, glaube ich, wirklich kurz.
Es gibt einen Dienst, den ich eigentlich sehr schätze, Backmarket.
Das ist eine Seite, wo man gut, in Anführungszeichen, gebrauchte Apple-Geräte,
auch andere Geräte, kaufen kann für verstörend teilweise günstige Konditionen.
Also da kriegst du ein iPhone 14 Pro für 25-30% unter dem, was du im Apple Store kaufst und,
ich hab ja selber eins genau von dort, als ich ihn gekriegt hatte,
war also der Screen komplett ohne jeden Kratzer und Akkukapazität auf 99% oder
Akkulebensdauer, also scheinbar wirklich kein Haken dran und alles super.
Ja, gibt's das schon? Echt?
Das kannst du noch nicht? Das gibt es mindestens fünf Jahre.
Und das ist von der ganzen Handling und so ist das alles richtig schön.
Also was ist jetzt da der Clou? Sind das jetzt einfach gebrauchte Geräte oder was?
Man weiß es nicht so recht. Also dafür, dass sie gebraucht sind,
dafür ist der Zustand eigentlich zu gut.
Also du kannst den Zustand auch mit so einem Schieberegler einstellen zwischen
irgendwie okay, gut, sehr gut und hervorragend.
Und ich habe jetzt hier ein gutes und das war, würde ich sagen,
irgendwo vom Laster gefallen als neuwertig und wurde nie eingeschaltet.
Anders kann ich mir den Zustand, wie ich das hatte, eigentlich nicht erklären.
So und Claudia hatte sich jetzt von da aus auch ein neues geholt,
auch ein 14 Pro und exakt derselbe fantastische Zustand.
Aber nicht alle iPhones sind gleich auf dieser Welt, sondern manche sind gleicher als andere.
Und was sowohl bei meinem 14 Pro der Fall war, als auch jetzt bei der Claudias,
ist, dass die eben nicht aus der EU kamen, sondern aus der großen weiten Welt.
Und mein iPhone kam aus Südkorea und das von Claudia kam aus China.
Was heißt das? Es wurde von da geschickt oder es handelt sich um ein China-Modell
mit den entsprechenden LTE-Konsequenzen?
Ja, ganz genau. Und dann fängt nämlich der ganze Hässel an bei der Geschichte hier.
Ich poste jetzt mal einen Link, das ist hier die Apple-Wiki mit den ganzen Ländercodes,
wo man also nachvollziehen kann,
okay, wir haben jetzt also hier einen iPhone 4 und das hatte die Nummer MC605LL-A
und hinter der Zahl, diese beiden Buchstaben, LL in dem Fall,
das ist dann also der sogenannte Ländercode oder Model Region Code.
Und dort lohnt es sich dann vorher mal nachzuschauen, was die Geräte denn eventuell
für Einschränkungen haben.
Die sind nämlich teilweise relativ wuchtig. Also beispielsweise jetzt Mainz
aus Südkorea, ja wohlbemerkt Südkorea, nicht Nordkorea.
Ja, das würde mich jetzt auch sehr wundern.
Hat seit zehn Jahren deaktiviert die Find My Funktion.
Ach, okay.
Und die ist jetzt bei dir auch deaktiviert?
Die ist bei mir deaktiviert und ich habe auch keinen Family-Tab oder Person-Tab
in meiner Find-Me-App hier.
Und was hast du jetzt gemacht? Das schickst du doch zurück?
Ja, das habe ich nach einem Vierteljahr gemerkt. Da hat es keinen Sinn mehr gehabt.
Also damit muss ich jetzt leben. Du kannst immer noch das Gerät als Device orten.
Und auch kann jetzt, wenn ich wissen will, wo ist meine Frau,
kann ich ihr Gerät orten, aber ich kann sie nicht als Person orten.
Ja, toll.
Aber das hätte ich jetzt auch bei Südkorea irgendwie nicht vermutet.
Wenn du ein Japan-Modell hast, hast du bei jedem Foto, was du machst,
ein lautes Klickgeräusch.
Also dieses klassische Fotoschatter-Simulationsgeräusch.
Und kannst es nicht abschalten.
Warum auch immer, ihr lieben Japaner. Ja, damit man weiß, wenn man fotografiert wird.
Naja, wir wissen schon warum. Man ahnt sehr schnell warum. Ja,
so okay, Chauvinismus off.
So und China, ja gut, da erwartet man dann natürlich so das eine oder andere,
aber das führt dann also dazu, dass dann also Claudia das schlicht nicht mit
einer eSIM aktivieren konnte.
Ja, also es hatte sich schön bei mir einen Frank Code gezogen und wollte jetzt
also ihr iPhone entsprechend einrichten, damit funktionierte nicht.
Und selbst der Datentransfer von ihrem alten iPhone funktionierte nicht,
sondern ist in der Mitte irgendwo abgebrochen.
So, die hat sie natürlich dann sofort zurückgeschickt.
Also da muss man wirklich hinterher schauen.
Grundsätzlich coole Idee, im Zweifelsfall vielleicht sogar irgendwie nachhaltig
vorbei. Also ich mich schon frage, wo kommen diese Teile her?
Ja, die sind also nicht original verpackt, sondern die kommen dann schon so
in irgendwelchen Transport-Bags daher.
Und diese Modellnummer, die stand auch beim Verkauf vorher nicht da,
oder? Du hast einfach irgendeines geschickt bekommen?
Also wenn man die richtigen Teile aufschiebt, dann steht sie da.
Aber bei Claudia war eine falsche angegeben. Wir haben Screenshots.
Sie hat das dann auch an Backmarket gemeldet und wahrscheinlich wird da jetzt
auch der Unterverkäufer aus dem Verkehr gezogen, vermute ich mal,
dass sie sich das auch nicht bieten lassen wollen.
Selbst wenn man es online vorher nachvollzieht, da war nämlich bei ihr Europa
angegeben, etwas weiterer Range.
Aber gekommen ist dann halt China. Und das geht dann natürlich nicht.
Aber was meinst du, wie viel Geld du dir damit jetzt gespart hast?
Also mit meinem habe ich ziemlich genau 350 Euro gespart. Cash-off gerade so.
Und für 350 Euro neue Gerät, dafür verzeigte ich da mal auf den People-Tab an der Stelle.
Tatsächlich? Das kann ich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen, wie du das jetzt wie
du, ne. Nie mal so einen Scheiß.
Nie wieder, wir timmen mich mit demselben Auge. Tu dieses iPhone weg,
ich kann es nicht ertragen.
Für 350 Euro, wo die auf das wichtigste Feature verzichten.
Also für 350 Euro redest du dir das schön.
Das ist eines der wichtigsten, besten Features überhaupt.
Ja, aber ich habe es ja gerade eben gesagt, ich finde ja alle Leute.
Ich finde sie nur nicht über den People-Tab, sondern über den Devices-Tab.
Du kannst auch durch die Röhrchen atmen, das funktioniert natürlich auch super.
Ich kriege alles, was ich brauche. Copium-Netzwerk.
Also, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
IPhone-Copium.
IPhone-Copium, ja.
Augen auf, beim iPhone gebraucht.
Okay.
Tja, das ist der linke Winkel. Alright, das ist ja eine traurige Geschichte.
Was hast du denn noch für eine schöne Geschichte zu erzählen?
Also, nachdem ich glaube das letzte Mal irgendwie klar war, dass mein bisheriges
iPad die nächste Major iOS Release nicht mehr sehen wird,
habe ich dann doch gedacht, na gut, dann kaufst du halt jetzt mal ein neues.
Und ich habe also ein iPad Air M2 gekauft, was vor ein paar Wochen angekündigt wurde.
Und es passierte etwas, was ich schon vermutet hatte, nämlich es ist in nichts
Wesentlichen irgendwie schneller als das alte iPad.
Also der reine Speed des iPads hat sich irgendwie gefühlt nicht verändert.
Klar, der Akku hält jetzt länger, weil der vom alten iPad schon so ein bisschen schwächelte.
Gegenüber was war im iPad? Gegenüber dem ersten Pro?
IPad Pro 10,5 Zoll. Das ist nicht das erste Pro, aber ich glaube,
es ist das letzte Pro, was noch ein Home-Button hatte.
Genau, und danach kam das, was ich habe, das L war, genau.
Und ich weiß nicht, da gibt es jetzt eine Sache, die sich geändert hat,
also okay, das hat jetzt USB-C, das ist jetzt aber nicht weiter von Belang.
Eine Sache hat sich geändert, die hat mich sehr, sehr verwirrt und zwar,
dass das alte iPad Pro mit dem Home-Button, Und da war das so,
wenn der Homebutton unten ist, dann sind die Lautleisertasten an der rechten Seite.
So, die obere Lautleisertaste macht lauter, die untere Lautleisertaste macht leiser.
So gehört es sich.
Was passiert, wenn man das iPad umdreht, sodass der Home-Button oben ist?
Dann sind die Tasten natürlich auf der linken Seite und dann macht natürlich
die untere Taste lauter und die obere leiser.
Was passiert jetzt mit diesem iPad? Ich habe immer noch Probleme, mich daran zu gewöhnen.
Wenn also der USB-C-Port unten ist, dann sind auch da die Laut-Leiser-Tasten rechts.
Die obere macht lauter und die untere macht leiser. So wie man es erwarten würde.
Und dann drehst du es, dann wird es umgeschaltet.
Genau.
You're holding it wrong. Ja, total. Aber ist das nicht eigentlich ganz nett?
Das ist übrigens ein OS-Feature, was sie eingebaut haben. Also das ist auch
bei meinem iPad später dazugekommen.
Das hätte eigentlich bei deinem alten iPad auch noch so sein müssen.
Aber warum solltest du es eigentlich in Anführungszeichen falsch rumhalten?
Nein, was besonders verwirrend ist, ist Landscape.
Wenn jetzt die beiden Tasten oben sind, dann ist es ja so, beim laut-leiser-Machen
wird dieser Balken eingeblendet.
Und der füllt sich von links nach rechts.
Das heißt, man macht mit der rechten Taste lauter, damit sich der Balken weiter füllt.
Es geht generell um den Balken und die Position der Buttons relativ zum Balken.
Es ist auch wirklich schwierig, sich daran zu gewöhnen. allerdings,
also Scroll-Richtung, das hatte ich sehr schnell drauf.
Das mit den Lautstärke-Tasten dauert noch so ein bisschen. Ich finde,
sie haben da einen Punkt, aber es ist dadurch, dass man das Ding halt auch beliebig
irgendwie drehen kann und immer wieder eine andere Logik greift,
ist es in der Tat schwierig.
Aber du hast ja jetzt auch den geilen Pencil, ne?
Den Pencil Pro?
Genau.
Und jetzt zeig mal diese Shadow-Nummer, das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Da habe ich jetzt erstmal gerantet, weil der Der Aufschrift Pencil Pro ist nur
dann richtig rum, wenn man Rechtshänder ist.
Wenn man Linkshänder ist, dann muss man sich das schöne Pencil Pro Logo auf
dem Kopf angucken. Aber okay, sei es drum.
Das sollte sich mitdrehen.
Das sollte ein Display sein. So gestraft.
Genau. Also was passiert, wenn man jetzt den Pencil in Nähe der...
Der Scheibe tut, dann sieht man also nicht nur diesen, der Schatten ist wirklich schwer zu sehen.
Ich seh den.
Ja, man sieht den, er ist schwer zu sehen. Aber man sieht halt auch den Punkt,
wo man schreiben wird, wenn man dann tatsächlich drauf drückt. Und?
Wer das noch nicht mitbekommen hat, also wenn man den Pencil irgendwo hin hält,
nah genug, dann wird auf dem Bildschirm ein virtueller Schatten des Stiftes,
so wie wie man ihn gerade hält.
Der könnte stärker sein. Als würde das Licht von oben kommen.
Den hätte ich gerne stärker.
Drauf gemalt.
Es wird sogar so eine Feder simuliert im Schatten.
Es ist abhängig davon, welches Tool du hast. Wenn du einen Pinsel auswählst,
dann sieht es auch aus wie ein Pinsel. Also du willst sozusagen ein anderes.
Wo kann man denn das Tool auswählen?
Hast du Procreate drauf?
Moment. Halt, halt, halt, halt, halt. Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Was du jetzt machst, geh mal in die Nähe und dann drückst du unten drauf. Auf die flache Seite.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich hier überhaupt eine Frage... Oh, schwierig.
Nochmal.
So, dann kommt so ein Kontextmenü.
Alles kaputt, mach du mal. Ja, ich habe vielleicht eine etwas komische Stifthaltung.
So, dann kommt nämlich dieses Menü.
Ach so, so ein Halbkreis-Menü. Und jetzt kannst du verschiedene Sachen auswählen.
Was haben wir da?
Stift, Feder, Radiergummi. Und das sieht man auch im Schatten, ne?
Das sieht man auch im Schatten. Na ja gut, das ist jetzt die Notiz-App von Apple.
Das ist aber ein Framework, was generell gilt. Also alle Programme,
die das irgendwie nutzen, haben dieselbe Funktionalität und dieser Schatten,
der richtet sich nach dem eingestellten Tool.
Dings ist, ist das und wenn es halt eine Fehler ist, jetzt kannst du noch drehen
den Pencil. Also auch die Drehrichtung ist sozusagen entscheidend.
Im Schatten zu sehen.
Das ist wirklich Magie.
Das ist abgefahren.
Das ist einfach, verstehst du,
das macht das DMA, macht dieses Feature wahrscheinlich im Herbst zunichte.
Kaputt. Das geht nicht.
Ihr müsst die Stifte genauso scheiße zeichnen wie alle anderen auch.
Das Einzige, was mir wirklich fehlt, was auch halt auch alle sagen ist,
warum, wenn ich das Teil umdrehe, habe ich nicht den Radiergummi.
Ja, das will ich auch haben. Das stimmt.
Also man hat den Radiergummi natürlich auch auf dem Schnellzugriff Ding,
aber nee, also das und diese Feder, die sich so dreht, also dazu kommt ja noch,
der Stift hat ja noch eine Drehungsausrichtung und die Feder hat eine gewisse Breite.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt irgendwie Du kommst da irgendwie.
Nicht in die erweiterten Settings rein, so sehr du dich auch mühst.
Keine Ahnung, das hat aber auch schon mal funktioniert.
Ich will es klassisch beschreiben, wir sind ein Podcast.
Also, wenn man auf die flache Seite des Pencils drückt, unten ungefähr,
sagen wir, drei Zentimeter vor der Spitze, dann gibt es so einen schönen Taptic
Device Tab, als hätte man irgendeinen Schalter gedrückt.
Und dann geht so ein rundes Menü auf und in diesem runden Menü gibt es ein,
hier gibt es noch mehr Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Ding.
Den kann man aber nicht drücken und das macht einen völlig rasend.
Warte mal, vielleicht muss ich hier nochmal drücken.
Oder bleib mal unten dann, ob du so presst du.
Ja, keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt.
Draufdrücken und gedrückt lassen, probier das doch mal.
Nee, dann ist er weg. Egal. Du kannst, wenn du willst, natürlich auch Procreate ausprobieren?
Ah ja, das gibt man ja. Also Procreate, das ist so die Flaggschiff-iPad-Zeichnen-mal-Kreativ-App-Sovo.
Aber hier ist jetzt kein Schatten drin und kein Punkt.
Nee, das hat Pro...
Procreate noch nicht. Da weiß ich nicht, ob das noch nachgeliefert wird oder was.
Also das wundert mich aber, weil die ja extrem quasi auch so Apple-friendly
und Best Buddies und so sind, dass sie das nicht von Releasetag an,
weil das ist ja jetzt schon ein paar Monate draußen.
Wochen, aber etliche Wochen. Da hätte ich jetzt von Procreate erwartet,
dass sie doch da als allererstes mit rauskommen.
Ganz ehrlich, ich habe Procreate nur so ein bisschen versucht,
habe dann ansonsten noch ein bisschen in der Notizen-App rumge...
Also was ich halt auch gerne mache, weil es auch ganz schön ist, ist in,
der Dateien-App kann man ja PDFs aufmachen und dann kann man in den PDFs mit dem Stift rumpinseln.
Das ist, wenn man irgendwie so Chor singt und Noten hat und so weiter,
dann kann man da halt einfach mit Bordmitteln in den Noten rumwurschteln und,
das macht sich eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich hab's geschafft. Aber,
trotzdem schwierig. Ich finde dieses Handling von diesem Menü mit diesem auf
der flachen Seite, da braucht man glaube ich sehr viel Übung für.
Das finde ich nicht wirklich intuitiv. Und den Schatten hätte ich mir mir echt
deutlich stärker gewünscht.
Der ist Eye-Candy, aber eigentlich wirklich nur für die, die wissen, dass er mal da ist.
Vielleicht kann man den auch irgendwo noch einstellen, das kann natürlich sein. Das weiß ich nicht.
Ja, Europäer, dass ihr immer so an Apple rummeckern müsst.
Also ich muss sagen, der Stift, der gefällt mir sehr gut, auch wenn ich ihn
nicht viel benutze, aber also ohne würde was fehlen.
Und dass der auch sitzt magnetisch gut,
lädt magnetisch also induktiv nehme
ich mal an der ist einfach also der ist wirklich flawless magnetisch praktisch
gut magnetisch praktisch gut das kann man das kann man zu dem stift zu sagen
und also ich meine es gab halt die möglichkeit den älteren pencil der aber irgendwie
nur über usb geladen werden kann aus irgendwelchen gründen.
Der ganz alte, ja.
Nee, nicht der ganz alte, sondern sie haben noch einen anderen.
Achso, ja, diese zwischendurch halt.
Keine Ahnung. Der hätte halt 100 Euro gekostet und für 150 bekommt man halt
den Pro und dann, weiß ich nicht.
Ich bin jetzt immer noch in derselben App, also immer noch in der Notiz-App,
allerdings jetzt im Textmodus, wo wir jetzt das Outline zu unserer Sendung haben.
Und da funktioniert aber dieser Punkt-Preview auch nicht. Also es ist noch nicht
so richtig konsequent so durchs OS durchgezogen.
Du, das kann durchaus sein.
Meinst du die Beta-Version ist noch nicht vollständig?
Siehst du?
Nein, das ist nicht die Beta-Version.
Das ist ja ganz normal.
Das ist noch die alte Release-Version. Ich habe tatsächlich jetzt auf dem iPad
die Beta noch nicht drauf.
Ich hatte ja die Beta auf dem Firmen-iPad drauf gemacht, aber das habe ich wiederum
mit keinem Pencil gepairt. Insofern kann ich jetzt zu Pencil und Marth Notes nichts sagen.
Ich habe das ja nur quasi mit dem Finger ausprobiert und da hat es halt einigermaßen gut funktioniert.
Aber Marth Notes hängt jetzt nicht so viel vom Stift ab.
Im Großen und Ganzen bin ich aber sehr zufrieden mit dem Ding und ein weiteres
Ding, was ich natürlich unbedingt ausprobieren musste, ich habe mir Assassin's
Creed Mirage runtergeladen.
Viele, viele Gigabytes kostet das und man kann ohne zu bezahlen tatsächlich
auch quasi so ein Demo-Ding, so ein Prolog, nennen sie das, spielen.
Das ist erstaunlich gut. Also da war ich echt erstaunt, wie gut und flüssig
das läuft, wie gut das aussieht.
Da würde ich nochmal sagen, wenn Apple sich reinhängt und in diesen Emerging-Markt
des Handheld-Gaming-Dings einbrechen würde,
So ein Mac Mini mit angebauten Controllern, mit einem ordentlichen Chip,
dann hätten sie da eine Chance, zumindest dann, wenn sie irgendwie auch sonst
die Entwickler alle auf Linie kriegen.
Also du hast mir das ja eben gezeigt und hast hier auch deinen Playstation 3
Control mitgebracht. Das sah schon toll aus.
Ich habe lange keinen Assassin's Creed mehr gespielt, ist mir dabei aufgefallen.
Die Grafik hat da doch nochmal den einen oder anderen Sprung gemacht,
auch wenn du sagst, dass es auf dem PC quasi nochmal zwei Umdrehungen besser
aussieht. Aber das ist schon eine wirklich beeindruckende Spielegrafik.
Also die Framerate könnte ein Tucken schneller sein. Also würde ich sagen.
So ungefähr 30.
Also so, dass es nicht nervt, aber auch nicht so, dass es jetzt so ultraflüssig ist.
Da ist sicherlich noch ein bisschen Luft nach oben. Aber grundsätzlich,
dass sowas jetzt auf so einem Tablet läuft, ist schon cool, muss man sagen.
Also ja, ich denke, wenn Apple wollte und wenn sie den Ball richtig spielen,
könnten sie so bei Switch und, wie heißen die anderen?
Da so ein bisschen wildern. Switch ist halt Nintendo.
Ja, aber dann gibt es noch das Ding von Steam Deck und so, also in der Gegend,
da könnten sie wildern, da könnten sie vielleicht auch irgendwie,
also ich will jetzt nicht sagen den Markt aufrollen, das ist vielleicht ein
bisschen viel verlangt, aber zumindest haben sie die Prozessoren und die Hardware haben sie.
Ganz einfach, die Hardware haben sie.
Ich habe jetzt in meiner Facebook-Timeline, wo ich immer noch relativ gute Werbeanzeigen
leider bekomme, ich weiß nicht aus welchem Grund, irgendwie targeten nehme ich da ganz gut,
habe ich jetzt pro Tag fünfmal so eine Konstruktion reingespielt,
wo man einen Controller,
quasi eine Controllerhülle hat, wo du in die Mitte das iPhone reinklemmst,
um dann damit Xbox Remote oder Playstation Cloud zu spielen.
Ja, und das ist natürlich dann schon ziemlich dicht dran an dem,
was ich ja immer einfordere.
Es muss schon irgendwie mit einem Controller zusammengedacht werden, so wie bei einer Switch.
Das ist halt einfach das Erfolgskonzept von der, dass du es wirklich so integriert
in einem Gerät hast und nicht alles so irgendwie nebenbei und zwei Sachen wieder im Rucksack.
Ja, also Spiele ohne Controller wird schwierig.
Also Maus und Tastatur schließt man jetzt natürlich nicht an ein iPad an.
Weil dann hast du halt so deine Xbox immer dabei. Das ist schon nicht so schlecht.
Ja, soviel zum Thema iPad Air M2. Passt.
Okay, super. Dann war es das jetzt wirklich mit Apple. Vorerst.
Da, da, da, da.
Was uns noch über den Weg läuft.
Ich kann ja mal kurz eine, ich weiß gar nicht, also die Geschichte ist eigentlich
gar nicht so spannend zu erzählen, aber ich wollte es trotzdem mal zum Besten geben.
Es gab sich ja mal zu einer Zeit, da wurde ja in dieser Sendung auch viel über
so Bitcoin und so ein Kram geredet.
Das waren noch Zeiten. Und ich bin auch ehrlich gesagt ganz froh,
dass wir das nicht mehr tun, weil das ist einfach mittlerweile alles eine wilde Welt.
Aber es gab ja mal so diese Phase und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch noch daran
erinnert, aber so ganz am Anfang, als das alles so losging, gab es diese erste Börse, Mount Gox.
Da gab es doch mal einen Song zu hier. Ja, ja.
Da gab es sogar einen Mount Gox Song, genau.
Den könnten wir ja noch mal einwerfen.
Die sind doch dann ganz fürchterlich gescheitert, wenn ich das richtig in Ordnung habe.
Die sind ganz fürchterlich gescheitert, weil das natürlich wie all diese ganzen
Krypto-Projekte ein totaler Scam war von Leuten, die irgendwie keine Ahnung
haben und die das irgendwie, ja weiß ich nicht,
sich da total verzockt haben und ich weiß gar nicht mehr so ganz genau.
Auf jeden Fall war das irgendein Heini, der diesen Laden in Japan aufgebaut
hat und von dort aus irgendwie betrieben hat.
Naja und auf jeden Fall war dann Mt. Gox pleite.
Ja, die sind irgendwie von einem
Black Hat gepentestet worden und dann war ganz viel von dem Kram weg.
Von den Bitcoins, oder? War das nicht so?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr, wie das überhaupt gelaufen ist.
Wo ist denn überhaupt dieser Mount Gox Song? Wo habe ich den denn?
Jetzt wo du es sagst, fällt mir das auch gerade wieder ein, dass wir irgendwann
mal diesen Mount Gox Song hatten. Finde ich noch.
Und auf jeden Fall hatte ich dann auch damals, zu dem Zeitpunkt, damit rumgespielt.
Und als halt Mt. Gox unterging, waren halt so ein paar Bitcoin von mir tatsächlich
mit in dieser Untergangsmasse.
Oh no!
Das ist jetzt alles zehn Jahre her. Wie, aber pfff. Naja, und ähm.
Und was dann passierte war, dass man als Owner von diesen Beständen,
also weil man da so einen Account hatte, dann aber auch tatsächlich irgendwann
mal nach, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, wann das losging,
es hat irgendwie ein, zwei Jahre, hat das irgendwie gedauert.
Ich gucke gerade mal, von wann hier die ersten Dokumente sind.
Von April 2014 habe ich das erste Mal so ein japanisches Zettelchen irgendwie zugeschickt bekommen.
An meine Adresse als Post sozusagen. Also an meine registrierte Adresse.
Nicht per Mail, sondern wirklich so ein Ding, wo ganz viel auf Japanisch draufsteht,
aber natürlich auch alles nochmal auf Englisch.
Notice of Commencement of Bankruptcy Proceedings.
So und dann halt so ein sehr formales, sehr japanisches Dokument,
was mir halt einfach irgendwie erzählt, dass also jetzt hier die Bankruptcy Proceedings von Mt.
Gox irgendwie sind und weil ich ja da irgendwie Kunde war und weil ich da irgendwie
potenziell irgendwelche Claims habe, naja, werde ich halt jetzt hier irgendwie
angeschrieben und dann ging das halt irgendwie so los.
Und man sollte dann halt sich irgendwie registrieren.
Und dem Ganzen folgte ein jahrelanges Hin und Her.
Also es passierte dann immer ganz lange Zeit nichts. Ich habe mich dann halt
irgendwann mal eingetragen und gesagt, ja okay, hier, ich hätte da auch ein
paar Bitcoin rumliegen, falls es da noch was für gibt und so,
ich bin dabei. natürlich nicht mit gerechnet.
Und dann ging das irgendwie bis zum, also ich hatte glaube ich so vier.
Vier oder fünf Mal in dieser Zeit, also gefühlt so alle zwei Jahre, passierte wieder was.
Also man kriegte immer mal wieder so E-Mails mit irgendwas, das passiert und
jemand hat sich getroffen, aber im Wesentlichen war es immer so,
ja, alles wurde nochmal verschoben.
Ach ja, übrigens, es wurde nochmal alles verschoben und jetzt ist die Deadline
für alle Claims ist dann und dann.
Ich habe mich dann immer, dann war das eine grausame Webseite.
Gut, also japanisch, aber eben auch alles auf Englisch. Das war schon insofern ganz gut gemacht.
Wir haben einen riesen Aufwand gefahren, um irgendwie diese ganzen Claims da einzufangen.
Zwischendurch wurde es so noch von irgendwelchen Bitcoin-Händlern angeschrieben,
ob du nicht bereit bist, auf deine Claims zu verzichten. Dann kriegst du das irgendwie abgekauft.
Und hätte ich zwar fast gemacht, Nacht, aber...
Da kam es dann irgendwie auch nicht zu, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich waren die
mittlerweile auch von der Polizei abgeräumt worden oder so.
Was weiß ich. Kennst du das Intro von Ritte der Kokosnuss?
Welche Lamas alles geseckt wurden von der Police?
Das suche ich auch mal raus, das erinnert mich sehr daran. Das müssen wir ja
auch in die Shownotes bringen.
Auf jeden Fall, es ging immer hin und her und dann eskalierte es halt immer
weiter mit ja und jetzt musst du hier deine Claims eintragen und dann musst
du das nochmal anwenden und dann musst du dieses und ich musste tausend Dokumente
hochladen und nochmal einen Pass und was nicht alles.
Alles und ich kann es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht alles sagen, was ich da so über
die Zeit aber ich habe immer so gedacht, da habe ich mich irgendwann nochmal
so eingeloggt, weil ich dachte mir, so passiert da eigentlich noch irgendwas vor zwei Jahren oder so.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich war überrascht, dass es mir immer noch gelungen ist,
mich da einzuloggen, meinen Second Factor irgendwie nie verloren habe,
dass ich immer das richtige Passwort hatte.
Ich konnte mich immer auf diese Webseite einloggen, das funktionierte auch und
Und ich hatte dann auch einen Eintrag und dann gab es aber dann immer so eine
schwer verständliche Zeile mit, ja, hier sind deine Claims, so und so viel Bitcoin.
Und hier in dieser Spalte, approved Claims, null.
Und ich habe immer nicht verstanden, ob ich irgendwas nicht gemacht habe oder so.
Ich habe einfach nichts drauf gegeben. Aber ich habe einfach das Spiel mitgespielt,
habe immer alles irgendwie versucht richtig einzutragen, wusste aber gar nicht
so richtig, was sie von mir wollen.
Ja, und dann vor drei Wochen oder so tauchte auf einmal Geld auf.
Hunderttausende von Euro.
Nein, leider nicht. Ich habe tatsächlich für diese Bitcoin noch Kohle bekommen.
4,50 Euro.
Nein, es war ein milder, vielstelliger Betrag, der mir überwiesen wurde.
Immerhin.
Immerhin, ja. Also der heutige Bitcoin-Wert wäre so das hundertfache davon gewesen.
Also zu dem Tarif hätte ich dann auf jeden Fall hier zumachen können,
aber soweit ist es nicht gekommen.
Aber das kam dann einfach so kommentarlos hin. Also ich hatte irgendwann mal
Bankverbindung angegeben, offensichtlich. Das konnte mich gar nicht mehr daran
erinnern. Und jetzt, tadaa.
Hat sich tatsächlich alle Leute irgendwie noch mit irgendeiner Kohle, ich weiß nicht.
Irgendeine Behörde hat einfach mal gearbeitet.
Ja und vor allem, wo haben sie die her? Also ich vermute mal,
sie haben dann irgendwie die Rest, sie hatten irgendwann mal so Rest-Bitcoin
gefunden und haben die dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie erst jetzt verkauft und
hatten dann irgendwie die Kohle, um irgendwie alle zu dem damaligen Kurs auszuzeigen.
Nein, immerhin, immerhin.
Insofern bin ich jetzt ein happy Bitcoin-Kunde, aber ich habe vor einiger Zeit
all mein ganzes Krypto-Zeug, was ich noch hatte, alles verkauft,
weil wir mit nichts zu tun haben.
Du bist kryptolos. Ich bin kryptolos.
Oder eher Kryptopleite?
Nö, ich bin einfach… Kryptolos glücklich. Am Anfang wurden mir so Bitcoin gespendet.
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt nie wirklich welche gekauft.
Ich hatte nur so Spendenbestandteile. Am Anfang war das dann natürlich entsprechend
mehr, weil das ja nichts wert war.
Und klar ist dann irgendwie immer mehr wert geworden. und irgendwann dachte
ich halt so, was soll der Geiz, irgendwie versilberst du dir das,
kannst du dir was von kaufen, alles gut.
Nur diese Bitcoin-Kohle bei Mt. Gox, die habe ich halt irgendwie schon vergessen.
Und offensichtlich hier, und Erik hat es natürlich sofort gefunden.
Wollen wir das mal kurz hören? Das ist Spiel doch mal.
Spiels doch nochmal Sam. Ich muss erstmal hier Cookies ablehnen.
Previously on Freakshow 129 Mount Gox von dem großartigen David.
Sehr schön.
Die Continuation, die hattest du jetzt.
Ja, ja.
So viel dazu zu Mt. Gox. Wer möchte weitermachen?
Was haben wir denn noch?
Naja, zwei kleinere Sachen, wenn ich das richtig sehe und dann wollte ich nochmal
ein bisschen weiter ausholen.
Ich kann mal nochmal über Autofahren reden.
Und zwar, wann war das dann? Vorletzte Woche. Vorletzte Woche.
Donnerstag hatten wir so einen, ich nenne es mal Außentermin von der Firma,
irgendwie mit, Team Day nannte sich das, mit Bespaßung.
Egal. Es war auf jeden Fall irgendwo in Potsdam und da bin ich dann,
weil ich nicht durch die Stadt wollte, bin ich dann den langen Weg außenrum,
wollte ich über die Autobahn nehmen und habe es also tatsächlich geschafft,
einen Bordstein mitzunehmen.
An einer Stelle, die relativ eng war, weil ich das neue Auto in seiner gesamten
Breitheit irgendwie noch nicht verinnerlicht hatte.
Was dazu führte, dass dann mal zwei Reifen, nämlich beide rechten Reifen kaputt waren.
So kaputt im Sinne von ungefähr anderthalb Zentimeter langes Loch drin an der Seitenwand.
Und ja, da war ich ganz schön aufgeschmissen, weil ich kannte das noch nicht. Den rufst du jetzt an?
Also rufe ich die Versicherung an. Die Versicherung, ja, sie haben aber diese
Extrapolize nicht hier und so weiter.
Sie müssten den Abschlepper selber bezahlen. Ich sage, ja gut, okay.
Ja, wir haben da für Sie einen Abschlepper rausgesucht. Dann dauerte das ungefähr
zweieinhalb Stunden bis der kam, weil er noch irgendwelche Leute von der Autobahn retten musste.
Und in der Zeit hatte die Versicherung dann die Werkstatt ausfindig gemacht, zu der ich da hin sollte.
Und just in dem Moment, als der Abschlepper kam,
rief mich also die Versicherung an und sagte mir, in welche Werkstatt ich soll
und der Abschlepper nur so, ja nee, das ist ja in der Stadt,
wir müssen ja in eine ganz andere Richtung, wir könnten sie da und da hinbringen,
aber nicht zu dieser Werkstatt.
Und ich so, äh, äh, äh, äh, und dann meinte ich so, ja gut, aber ich meine,
das Auto kann ja jetzt hier nicht stehen bleiben.
Ja, ganz langsam können sie schon fahren, können sich da hinten hinstellen,
da war irgendwie ein Parkplatz. Gut.
Bin ich da also hin und habe dann den Nachhauseweg mit den öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln bestritten.
Also wie gesagt, das war westlich von Potsdam.
Das war schon echt in der Pampa. Habe drei Stunden nach Hause gebraucht und
habe dann das erstmal sein lassen,
habe am nächsten Tag dann rumtelefoniert und weil die Versicherung mir versprochen hatte,
die Werkstatt, die sie für mich ausgesucht hatten, würde sich melden.
Ruf ich also die Werkstatt an, ja hier, ich wüsste, ob sie denn den Fall schon
hätten und er so, nö, hab keinen Fall.
Welche Versicherung? Ja, die und die. Ah, nee, von denen nehmen wir keine neuen Fälle mehr an.
Aber die Versicherung hat dich zu denen geschickt? Oh, wow.
Auf gut Deutsch, die Versicherung hat mir erst einen Abschlepper geschickt,
der mich nicht dahin fahren wollte, wo mich die Versicherung haben wollte.
Und dann hat mir die Versicherung auch noch eine Werkstatt rausgesucht,
die nicht den Schaden reparieren wollte.
Was für eine gloriose Versicherung ist denn das?
Hook 24.
Ach, guck an. Aber billig war es.
Also ich möchte ja jetzt nicht irgendwas empfehlen oder von irgendwas abraten,
aber Leute, die jetzt die Story hören, können sich ihre Gedanken machen.
Und ja, dann habe ich also tatsächlich auf den Schock angefangen,
erst mal Google anzuwerfen.
Wo sind denn da Abschleppunternehmen?
Und wo ist denn da eine Werkstatt? Habe da also rumtelefoniert,
die Werkstatt angerufen.
Wo stand das Fahrzeug jetzt zu dem Zeitpunkt?
Westlich von Potsdam, sagt dir der Name Golben etwas.
Also da, wo dir das passiert ist, da warst du nicht mehr.
Doch, da stand das Fahrzeug.
Ach, noch genau da. Keiner wollte dich da hinfahren, wo du wolltest.
Naja, der eine Abschlepper nicht. Und es hatte dann auch zu dem Zeitpunkt dann
auch keinen Sinn mehr, einen neuen zu rufen.
Und da der ja gesagt hatte, der Abschlepper, der da war, der mich dann nicht
mitgenommen hat. Also wie gesagt, der ist ja gekommen, aber er hat mich da nicht
mitgenommen, weil er wollte mich nicht dahin bringen.
Waren dir die Reifen platt?
Wie gesagt, anderthalb Zentimeter langes Loch, beide rechten Reifen, da war nichts mehr.
Und hat es Peng gemacht?
Na, Puff. Peng kann man es nicht nennen, aber Puff, ja.
Ja, dann habe ich ein bisschen rumtelefoniert, habe also eine Werkstatt in Potsdam
gefunden und auch einen Abschlepper in Potsdam.
Das heißt, du hast einen gefunden, also einen, den die Versicherung bereit war
zu bezahlen oder den du jetzt selber bezahlen musst?
Nee, ich habe gedacht, naja, nachdem die Versicherung den Abschleppern nicht
bezahlt, aber irgendwie dann auch zu einer Werkstatt mich haben wollte, wo...
Die dich nicht haben wollten?
Die, keine Ahnung, das wäre ja einmal quer durch die Stadt gewesen, fast.
Da habe ich gesagt, das hat alles gar keinen Sinn, ich organisiere das jetzt
selber und bezahle das auch selber und dann wird das dann hoffentlich auch.
Und von dort aus ging es dann auch bergauf.
Ich habe dann also tatsächlich einen Abschlepper gefunden, der das Auto für
nur 80 Euro zur Werkstatt gebracht hat, was glaube ich relativ wenig ist.
Und die Werkstatt, naja gut, die haben dann die gleichen Reifen drauf gemacht,
die VW auch bezahlt, die waren schon relativ teuer. und weil,
die linken Reifen sehr unterschiedlich stark abgefahren waren,
wollte er halt die jetzt dann auch nicht mehr auf die gleiche Achse tun, meinte das.
Also habe ich jetzt vier neue Reifen.
Gratuliere. Ich hatte ja auch einen Reifenunfall. Habe ich das hier eigentlich
schon zum Besten gegeben?
Mit dem Anhänger, ne? Ja.
Das habe ich schon erzählt?
Ja, das hattest du erzählt.
Ja.
Naja, auf jeden Fall weil, ja, Pengpuff Returned, so war es.
Ja, das war die Story soweit. Man lernt dazu.
Aber ich meine, was hast du jetzt konkret gelernt, dass du die falsche Versicherung hast?
Das werde ich nochmal in Erfahrung bringen.
Vor allen Dingen muss ich der Versicherung noch beibringen, dass sie jetzt den
Case zumachen sollen, ohne dass sie mich jetzt zurückstufen.
Weil sie hätten zwar dann die Werkstatt bezahlt, aber sie hätten mich halt dann zurückgestuft.
Dann wäre es wahrscheinlich alles noch viel, viel teurer gewesen.
Das ist eh immer so ein bisschen die Falle.
Ja, und 500 Euro Selbstbeteiligung hatten sie auch noch.
Also insofern, das hätte sich jetzt wirklich nicht gelohnt, das über die Versicherung abzuwickeln.
Habe ich die falsche Versicherung? Vielleicht, da muss ich dann nochmal drüber
nachdenken und entsprechend eine neue suchen.
Ziemlich DEVK in deiner engeren Auswahl.
DEVK, okay.
Bisher nur gutes Bericht.
Ja, soweit dazu. Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt 4x4 neue Reifen,
das Auto fährt wieder und zur nächsten Inspektion muss ich dann der Vertragswerkstatt
sagen, dass sie nochmal die Spur messen sollen, ob die noch okay ist.
Weil die könnte sich nämlich auch verstellt haben, dann kostet das auch nochmal
ein bisschen, wenn die die Spur neu einstellen müssen.
Aber hey, also Vorsicht am rechten Rand, das kann sehr teuer werden.
Der rechte Reihen, der linke Winkel.
Gute Botschaften zum Thema Mobilität. Ich halte hier immer und unaufhörlich
die Fahrradflagge hoch.
Und da habe ich was auf Halde jetzt schon seit vielen, vielen Sendungen,
was ich jetzt endlich mal reinwerfen möchte. Und zwar zeige ich euch jetzt mal
zwei Bilder hier im Chat und wir versuchen, die mal zu beschreiben, was wir da sehen.
Dann müsstest du mal den mal runter scrollen jetzt, Tim. Machst du mal auf den Beamer? Ja, da.
Genau, so. Also wir sehen ein Lastenfahrrad.
Ein Lastenfahrrad, wo quasi vorne so, in dem man normalerweise immer so eine
Box hat für irgendwie Kinder, Bierkisten, was auch immer. Da ahnt man irgendwie
so technische Geräte. Das sieht so ein bisschen nach Boxen aus.
Und dann ist links und rechts von dem Lastenfahrrad ist dann sowas ähnliches
wie Flügel, die irgendwie so...
Sieht aus wie Tapaziertisch.
Tapaziertisch, irgendwie sowas, genau. Und jetzt machen wir mal das nächste Bild hintendran.
Was sich da nämlich eigentlich drin verbirgt, ist folgendes. Achtung.
So, lad hoch, lad hoch, lad hoch, lad hoch.
Eine 5x2 Meter Auftrittsstagebühne.
Wie so links und rechts aus dem Lastenfahrrad rausklappt, wie so Flügel.
Genau, das Lastenfahrrad steht immer noch in der Mitte. Links und rechts hat
das jetzt aber seine Flügel von jeweils 2 Meter Spannbreite ausgebreitet.
Und darauf steht ein vollständiges Drumkit, zwei Gesangsmikros,
Platz für einen Bassist, Platz für eine Gitarre.
Links und rechts sind Subwoofer hinten aktive, die von dem Akku des Fahrrads betrieben werden.
Vorne sind noch zwei Monitorboxen, dass sich die Band auch selber hören kann.
Links und rechts über den Subwoofern ist eine kleine Lichtanlage,
womit man die Stage auch beleuchten kann.
Und im Hintergrund ist ähnlich wie bei so Wurfzelten, zwei Sekunden,
die sich so aus dem Nichts auffalten, hat man noch einen kompletten Hintergrund,
den man selber mit Bandlogo oder sonst was bedrucken kann.
Es ist einfach eine komplette fucking Musikstage.
Also man muss das so sagen, das Drumset und die Gitarren waren jetzt nicht auf dem Lastenfahrrad.
Die waren nicht auf dem Lastenfahrrad, aber quasi wirklich die komplette Infrastruktur.
Das Ediband.
Und sagen wir mal so, nicht jeder Schlagzeuger würde das als vollständiges Drumset bezeichnen.
Aber es ist hinreichend, sagen wir mal.
Also Drumset ist wie alle Technik nach oben offen.
Ach so, verstehe. Okay, aber das sind sowieso Snare und Bass und...
Naja, da ist eine Snare-Drum, da ist eine Hi-Hat, da ist eine Bass-Drum,
da ist zumindest eine Stand-Tom, eine Hänge-Tom.
Zwei Becken, das passt schon soweit.
Na gut.
Also die Firma, die das macht, ich glaube so seit drei Jahren oder so,
was sind die auf dem Markt? Veloconcerts heißen die.
Und sitzen in Wien, glaube ich, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Und hier mein Lieblingsbezirk natürlich, Pankow, die haben das für ihre Bibliotheken angeschafft hier.
Der Danilo Vetter, der probiert ja sowieso immer gerne solche Geschichten aus.
Und für irgendwie mal mobil in die Stadt hinein irgendwie wirken zu können,
ist es glaube ich für viele Kultureinrichtungen irgendwie eine ganz interessante
Geschichte. Ist natürlich nicht ganz günstig, kann man sich vorstellen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was da was jetzt der aufgerufene Preis war.
Aber damit ist man natürlich echt flexibel und sehr, sehr mobil halt unterwegs.
Was heißt nicht ganz günstig, also man muss das kaufen?
Genau, das ist also quasi irgendwo wird da auch ein Preis.
Ich meine irgendwas 15.000.
Euro oder so.
Hier steht, we will deliver the Velostage to your event.
Ja, gut möglich, dass man das von denen auch irgendwie leihen kann,
aber eigentlich ist der Gedanke der, dass man es kauft. Das wundert mich jetzt
auch gerade ein bisschen.
Book Your Velo Stage klingt eher nach Kontakt aus. Klingt eher nach Leihen und Mieten.
Also man kann es kaufen, ich weiß es, weil wie gesagt, Panko hat es gekauft und hat es zu stehen.
Kannst du auch zwei kombinieren, dann hast du eine Riesen-Stage bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Also, worauf ich hinaus will, ich glaube, dass gerade das Thema Lastenfahrrad
ist noch nicht auserzählt.
Ist noch nicht durchgespielt.
Das ist noch nicht durchgespielt. Ich glaube, da geht noch so das eine oder
andere an 50er Idee, was man damit noch, als ich das zum ersten Mal gesehen
habe, dachte ich so, wow, okay.
Ich sage mal so, die Freundin von dem Bassisten meiner Band ist Vorsitzende beim ADFC.
Ich kriege da so ein bisschen Angst, wenn ich das sehe.
Wer weiß, was wir dann für Konzerte demnächst spielen.
Aber reichen würde es.
Tja, so viel dazu.
Funktioniert hat. Dann wurde ich aufgefordert, das nochmal zu vertiefen.
Das Ding ist, das Ganze ist eher mal wieder so eine Selbstbesiegung in gewisser
Hinsicht, weil ich halt, es gibt so Sachen, die verstehe ich nicht.
Eine ganze Menge eigentlich, weil ich kann ja eigentlich nicht viel,
also nicht so richtig. Ich habe ja nichts gelernt oder so. Also ich...
Ein historischer Moment.
Naja, ich bin ja so ein dahergelaufener, so ein Internet-Hallodrie.
Also ich bin ja allen Ausbildungen aus dem Weg gegangen.
Ich habe zwar mal angefangen zu studieren, aber das fand ich langweilig und
dann, Berufsausbildung kam mir gar nicht in den Sinn und was konnte man noch
so machen? Das ist das eigentlich im Wesentlichen.
Und das hat mich aber alles nicht interessiert. Ich wollte halt nur mit meinen
Computern und Internet und irgendwie so, ich wollte einfach machen, was ich wollte.
Und das ist so mein Weg, den ich so gegangen bin. Das heißt,
alles, was ich gelernt habe, habe ich mir selber beigebracht eigentlich.
Oder mir vom Internet beibringen lassen oder wie auch immer bin da so reingelaufen.
Das heißt, das ist das, was ich meine. Ich kann halt nichts richtig,
weil ich jetzt nichts irgendwie studiert habe. Und ich bin ein,
was auch immer, ausgebildeter, keine Ahnung.
Und trotzdem ist es mir gelungen, mich mit verschiedenen Technologien vertraut zu machen.
Aber es gab halt immer so einen Endgegner, wo ich mich echt total gedrückt habe,
beziehungsweise wo immer ich probiert habe, mich dem anzunähern,
bin ich gescheitert. Und das ist Strom.
Hatte ich glaube ich auch schon mal. Elektrotechnik, ich würde es so gerne elektrotechnisch
verstehen. Das funktioniert nicht.
Elektrotechnik, das geht schon sehr weit, aber bei mir, das Ding ist immer,
wenn ich mich, also Elektrotechnik würde bei mir bedeuten, erstmal Elektro, dann Technik.
Ja, okay, d'accord.
Das hängt natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht zusammen und letztlich ist das jetzt
hier auch eher ein Weg durch die Elektrotechnik, aber bei mir ist es immer so, wenn ich was verstehe,
es gibt andere Leute, ich muss nochmal weiter ausholen, es gibt ja auch so Leute,
die lernen Sprachen, indem sie einfach in irgendein Land fahren und dann fangen
sie an zu reden mit allen und dann können sie das irgendwann. waren.
Vollkommen unmöglich für mich. Als ich irgendwie nach Mexiko gefahren bin,
um Spanien zu lernen, habe ich mich zwei Wochen an den Strand gesetzt und eine Grammatik gelesen.
Zwei Wochen lang habe ich da nur gesessen, habe mit niemandem geredet,
außer was jetzt erforderlich war, um Essen zu bekommen und Logis.
Aber ich habe Konversationen, bin ich aus dem Weg gegangen, weil ich noch nicht
qualifiziert dafür war.
Denn ich musste erstmal die Basics reinholen. Und die Basics waren,
ich habe wirklich diese langen Scheit Deutsch-Spanisch-Grammatik komplett von
vorne bis hinten jedes Wort gelesen und zwar nach
der Du-liest-nicht-weiter-wenn-du-es-noch-nicht-verstanden-hast-Methode.
Also wenn ich eine Seite gelesen habe und ich wusste nicht Bescheid,
habe ich sie so lange nochmal gelesen, bis ich sie verstanden habe.
Und nachdem ich dann mit dieser Fibel durch war, hatte ich eine wirklich gute
Vorstellung von spanischer Grammatik. Ich hatte alles drauf.
Ich hatte natürlich keine Erfahrung mit Reden oder sowas. Aber das war dann
für mich eine Basis, mit der ich arbeiten konnte.
Und danach bin ich eigentlich erst in eine Spanischschule gegangen.
Ich habe dann eine Woche One-on-One Unterricht genommen in Südmexiko,
in Chiapas und das Mädel,
so ein Schüler hätte sie auch noch nie gehabt, weil ich da halt reingegangen
bin und gesagt habe, ich kann so die Basics, aber ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Die wusste gar nicht, wie ihr geschah. Aber das hat super funktioniert.
Ich habe dann in dieser einen Woche alle meine übrig gebliebenen Fragen abgeklärt
und danach konnte ich flüssig E-Mails schreiben und auch reden.
Also ich hatte wirklich zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt Spanisch total drauf.
Ist dann leider komplett verloren gegangen, weil mein nächster Trip mich dann
eine Woche später nach Kuba führte und das war das totale Desaster.
Ich will dir jetzt nicht die ganze Story erzählen, aber über kurz oder lang
in Kuba war es einfach sehr schwierig, dieses Spanisch auszubauen,
weil der Kontakt mit den Kubanern vor Ort sehr anstrengend ist als Festtourist.
Und dann war mir irgendwann nur noch daran gelegen, dem aus dem Weg zu gehen.
Weil halt einfach die ganze Zeit, also wirklich permanent, also zweimal pro
Minute wegen irgendwas, du solltest immer irgendwas kaufen.
Entweder Zigarren oder Rum oder Frauen.
Ich war mal zwei Wochen auf Kuba auf einer Dienstreise von einer Bibliothek
und habe glaube ich auch den offiziellen Titel Freund des kubanischen Volkes. Ich war da.
Okay, die Geschichte ist vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht.
Die kann ich mal kurz erzählen. Also ich habe damals das GDZ geleitet,
Göttingen Digitalisierungszentrum für Massendigitalisierung gemeinnfreier Werke.
Und über die Goethe-Stiftung bin ich in der Tat dann nach Havanna gekommen,
dort an die Bibliothek, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der offizielle Titel war,
Zentral-Landesbibliothek, was auch immer, also die zentrale Bibliothek von Guba
halt. Und die hatten auch ein Digitalisierungszentrum.
Und da sollte ich halt so als Consultant mal rein, so mit meiner Westbrille
und mal gucken, was sie da machen. Und was sie halt hatten, war Flachbett-Scanner.
Weil das, was die hauptsächlich gescannt haben dort, waren, die hatten in Kuba
so ein ganz interessantes System, dass man so als Zivilist, als jedermann,
jeder Frau so Einlassungen an den Staat schreiben konnte,
was doch bitteschön alles verbessert werden müsste in diesem Lande und wo irgendwo
Potenzial ist. Ich glaube, das gab es in der DDR auch.
Da gab es, glaube ich, auch irgendeinen Mechanismus für. Also ganz gefährliches Halbwissen jetzt.
Auf jeden Fall haben die also tonnenweise einzelne DIN-A4-Blätter halt auf diesen
Flachbett-Scannern gelegt, wo man normalerweise einen FIDA nehmen würde,
um das automatisch einzuhalten. Gab es aber alles nicht.
So, und jetzt wollten sie aber eben auch historische Bücher damit scannen.
Hatten aber nicht unsere normale Ausstattung, in Anführungszeichen,
an normalen Bibliotheken für Digitalisierung, wo du dann so eine Buchwippe hast,
die ausgleicht, wo dann die Buchfalz gerade ist und ob du am Anfang des Buches,
dann ist die eine Seite des Buches ja viel dicker als die andere und wenn du
oben eine Glasplatte für den Flachbettscanner hast, willst du ja eine plane
Ebene haben, darum muss es dann mit einer sogenannten Buchwippe unten ausrichtig
werden, hatten die alles nicht.
So, dann habe ich denen also eine Konstruktion erfunden, dass sie quasi einen
Gabelstapler nehmen, den kleinen, den Flachbett-Scanner umdrehen,
von oben rauf und runter fahren lassen und unten dann quasi durchblättern können.
Gabelstapler?
Also sinngemäß. Ach so. Also halt einfach eine Konstruktion,
die einfach den ganzen Flachbett-Scanner, weil der ja nicht so viel wiegt,
rauf und runter fahren können mit Fußpedalen.
Das heißt also, sie haben quasi drei Pedale, eine auslösen, rauf fahren,
runter fahren und damit wären sie dann, also wenn sie es gebaut haben,
ich habe es nie erfahren,
ob das also jemals in die Umsetzung kam, aber das war halt wirklich der Ansatz,
okay, die haben jetzt genau diese Technik, an andere Technik kommen die nicht vernünftig ran. dran.
Ja, so eine einfache Rauf-Runter-Fahr-Mechanik werden sie schon hinkriegen.
So, das, vielleicht probieren sie es mal aus.
Und dann wurde mir also offiziell dieser Titel verliehen, weil sie endlich mal,
also endlich mal in Westler Gedanken gemacht hat, wie kann ich hier praktisch
den Leuten irgendwie helfen, ohne ihnen zu sagen, ja, ihr braucht halt Westi-Wiesen
und müsst diesen Zeutschel-Scanner für 15.000 Euro kaufen.
So, das war halt einfach keine Option.
Aber das war auch wild, dann war ich dann wirklich auf der offiziellen Südamerikaner
die amerikanischen Digitalisierungstagung, die dann da auch zu dem Zeitpunkt stattfand.
Welches Jahr war denn das?
Das müsste so her sein 17 Jahre, also als ich an der SOB Göttingen war,
im Digitalisierungszentrum, das müssen so 17 Jahre ungefähr sein.
Und dann war dann wirklich der kubanische Wissenschaftssenator,
Und hat dann eine zwei Stunden viel Castro-like Rede gehalten,
warum also Kuba das Herzstück der Digitalisierung und des digitalen Fortschrittes der ganzen Welt ist.
Du saßt da und kamst gerade aus diesem Digitalisierungszentrum und da hattest
du so, okay, so läuft es ja halt.
Aber das war super. Aber von daher habe ich einen sehr, sehr anderen Eindruck
von Kuba, als du jetzt halt.
Ich hatte auch noch mehr Eindrücke von Kuba, weil ich dann über einen Bekannten
dort, also über einen Freund von mir dort an einen Bekannten gekommen bin,
wo ich auch wohnen konnte.
Der hat dann schon mal dazu beigetragen, dass mein Spanischlernen dahingehend
scheitern musste, weil der sich wiederum durch das Lesen von Der Spiegel über
Jahre Deutsch beigebracht hat und perfekt Deutsch sprach.
Und er wollte dann die ganze Zeit mit mir Deutsch üben, während ich eigentlich
nach Kuba gekommen bin, um Spanisch zu lernen.
Und Spanisch war aber sowieso schwierig in Kuba, weil die da so ein komisches,
schnelles Spanisch ohne S sprechen.
Das war eh nicht das langsame, deutschkonforme, mexikanische Spanisch,
was ich gerade gelernt hatte. Also eine weitere Katastrophe.
Aber das hat er dann wiederum zur Folge, jetzt kommen wir wirklich weit vom
Strom ab, aber jetzt müssen wir da durch,
dass ich dann sogar noch, Dann hat er irgendwie, das war 2000 übrigens,
dass ich da war, und dann hatte seine Schwester, genau, seine Schwester war
nämlich an der Universität und.
Die hat das dann irgendwie, ich weiß nicht genau wo, aber es gab da eine Informatikabteilung
und die haben dann davon Wind bekommen, dass ich da bin.
Und haben so gehört, so ja hier CCC irgendwas und so weiter und dann sind die
irgendwie völlig wild geworden und wollten unbedingt, dass ich vorbeikomme.
Das gipfelte dann da drin, dass ich an die Universität von Havanna gegangen
bin und am Ende dort sogar noch einen Vortrag gehalten habe.
Und das hatte natürlich diese besondere Problematik, dass ich jetzt sozusagen,
weil ich wollte ja da auch unbedingt hin, weil das war nämlich der einzige Ort
in Kuba 2000, der einzige Ort, wo es Internet gab.
Siehst du wohl.
Es gab sonst im ganzen Land kein Internet, nirgendwo, nur in der Informatikabteilung
in der Universität von Havanna gab es Internet und ich wollte da hin.
Und dann war ich da und dann habe ich da tatsächlich einen Vortrag gehalten.
Aber die meinten halt so, naja, muss schon ein bisschen vorsichtig sein.
Da sitzen dann immer so Gestalten im Publikum. Und das war dann auch so,
dass da so Gestalten, merktest du richtig, wie so Leute, die so definitiv nicht
zur Informatikabteilung gehörten, da so mit Interesse so verfolgten.
Und ich habe dann erst mal so ein bisschen, ich habe halt so über Internet und
Privatsphäre und so weiter.
Und da müsst ihr total aufpassen, Weil die Amerikaner, die lauschen mit und
die hören euch ab und deswegen müsst ihr Verschlüsselung benutzen,
damit die Amerikaner euch nicht auf die Spur kamen. Und dann war irgendwie Mittagspause
und dann waren diese Gestalten schon nicht mehr da.
Dann waren die wahrscheinlich ganz zufrieden und dann konnte ich dann mit den
Nerds, die noch übrig waren, die richtig interessanten Sachen diskutieren.
Das war wirklich lustig. Naja, auf jeden Fall, oh Gott, Kuba.
Also, worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, ist, ich muss mich in etwas richtig,
ich muss es in der Basis verstehen.
Um irgendwie mich dem überhaupt nähern zu können.
Und ich habe dann totale Schwierigkeiten, also während andere schon anfangen,
irgendwas zu verstehen oder meinen, etwas zu verstehen.
Oder es vielleicht auch tatsächlich verstehen, sich aber keine Gedanken um Details
machen, die dann am Ende wichtig sind oder nicht.
Sterbe ich, wenn ich das Gefühl habe, ich begreife das irgendwie nicht.
Und bei Strom ist das natürlich ein weites Feld. Und, ja, weil dann immer so,
ja, und dann erklären dir die Leute immer so, ja, dann hier und plus und minus
und das fließt in die eine oder die andere Richtung, ist ja eigentlich auch egal,
weil Hauptsache Widerstand und was und so weiter und dann geht das schon.
Und ich so, wie, was, was fließt in welche Richtung, was fließt denn da überhaupt
in welche Richtung und was ist denn hier überhaupt los?
Und dann, ja, Elektronen, okay, Elektronen.
Also musste ich mich erstmal mit Atommodell beschäftigen, dann bin ich dann
so völlig in diese Quantenwelt abgestiegen, weil ich wollte natürlich wissen,
was ist, sind denn das jetzt eigentlich so für Dinge?
Und dann war ich ja auch irgendwie am Zerren und habe dann irgendwie da mit
diesen Beschleunigern und Elementforschern gesprochen.
Dann hatte ich so ein langsames Gefühl, okay, jetzt verstehe ich so langsam
die physikalischen Basics.
Elektronen wollen halt immer in die Löcher.
Und das ist irgendwie schon mal entscheidend, weil das ist ja auch wichtig,
um zu verstehen, warum ist etwas elektrisch leitend und nicht und warum reagieren
die Dinge so gerne und was ist ein Metall und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Ich wollte es halt einfach erstmal irgendwie haben.
Hatte natürlich praktisch jetzt von Volt und Watt und so weiter keine Ahnung
und um es auch gleich vorweg zu nehmen, ich bin auch immer noch sehr weit weg
vom Totalverständnis, aber ich habe den Kampf aufgenommen.
Und der Grund war, dass ich im Kampf mit meinem mobilen Stromsystem,
was ich in diesem Wohnwagen habe, aufgenommen habe, weil es nämlich nicht funktioniert
hat, wie ich das gerne möchte.
Ich habe nämlich, um es mir einfach zu machen, andere Leute bauen lassen und
das ist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht ein streblicher Fehler.
Der Vorteil war, ich hatte erstmal sofort was, was funktioniert,
was mich selbst sehr lange gekostet hätte, sehr lange gedauert hätte,
bis ich da überhaupt etwas beisammen gehabt hätte, weil ich das ja alles nicht verstand.
Aber dann ist immer das Problem, wenn andere Leute das für dich machen und irgendwas
funktioniert nicht, dann stehst du da und kannst es dir auch nicht erklären,
warum es nicht funktioniert, weil du es nicht begreifst.
Also musste ich irgendwie das Ganze von vorne anfangen und mit meinem minimalen
Stromwissen und all dem, was ich irgendwie so aus Chat-GPT so herausquälen konnte
und aus dem Internet und so weiter.
Weil es gibt immer so Verständnisprobleme.
Aber du weißt schon, dass ich Diplom-Ingenieur Elektrotechnik bin und mit einer
Eins abgeschlossen habe.
Keine Ahnung. Jetzt weißt du es.
Das erzählt Roddy in jeder zweiten Sendung.
Was? Nein, das hast du noch nie erzählt.
Doch.
Was?
Also wenn Ralf es mitbekommen hat. Ich bin ja 20 Jahre weniger.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Was du für Quellen hast.
Okay.
Naja gut, also ich nicht. und ich muss das ja irgendwie für mich selber machen.
Ich wollte ja auch was anderes hinaus, das war jetzt eigentlich nur die Vorgeschichte.
Die eigentliche Geschichte ist,
Dass ich jetzt mal mein Zwischenwissen so ein bisschen zusammenfassen wollte
und wir haben ja schon mal über deine Solarinstallation gesprochen,
aber jetzt einfach nur mal so in diesem Punkt, um so als Starter-Kit,
mentales Starter-Kit für, wenn man sein Wohnmobil, Fahrzeug, Wohnwagen,
Tiny Home, Off-Grid-Lifestyle in irgendeiner Form gedenkt zu machen.
Machen, wo fängt man mit an und was braucht man eigentlich?
Das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen die Welt, die ich für mich zusammengelegt habe,
um einfach irgendwie auch ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, weil ich habe immer
auf meine ganzen Geräte geschaut, dachte so, okay, ihr hängt da alle,
aber ich weiß nicht, wer redet jetzt hier eigentlich mit wem, wer ist hier der Chef,
wer hat hier eigentlich was zu sagen und wozu braucht man das alles? ist.
Naja, ich habe, muss man vorweg sagen, alle alle Komponenten sind Victron Komponenten.
Victron Energy ist ja ein Platzhirsch, kann man glaube ich sagen, auf dem Markt.
Also sicherlich nicht der einzige, beileibe nicht, aber so einer der großen,
das ist ein holländisches,
Unternehmen und Victron baut so ja nahezu alles Alles, was man benötigt,
um so ein System zu haben, was halt mit Solar arbeitet,
was mit Batterien arbeitet, Stromdistribution, Systemüberwachung und halt Wechselstromerzeugung baut.
Das ist so das Zeug, was man da kriegt. Das Einzige, was sie,
glaube ich, explizit nicht machen in dem Segment ist Wind.
Also so mit Windgeneratoren haben die irgendwie nichts zu tun.
Naja gut, das ist jetzt auch Wind auf kleinen Skalen machen jetzt auch die aller
allerwenigsten, glaube ich.
Ja, wobei es gibt auch da schon ganz interessante Sachen, auch für mobile Windgeneratoren.
Es gibt auch Leute, die an einem Bach wohnen und sich ein Wasserrad gebaut haben.
Genau, sowas gibt es auch. Aber das machen die auch nicht. Naja,
auf jeden Fall habe ich so ein Victron-System und muss halt erstmal so verstehen,
was muss man eigentlich bedenken, wenn man sich sowas baut.
Und wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, ich habe jetzt hier ein Fahrzeug,
also so ein Wohn, ein potenzielles Wohnfahrzeug, dann möchte man ja gerne Strom haben.
Und die Autos sind ja relativ schlecht mit Strom.
Also Strom hat man so ein bisschen...
Also die, die nicht so gut mit Strom sind, sind relativ schlecht.
Naja, die meisten, also die Fahrzeuge, die einfach nur zum Fahren gedacht sind erstmal,
nicht zum Wohnen, die haben in der Regel nur den Strom, um einfach im Wesentlichen
so die Systemfunktion, ein bisschen Komfort, Klima und so weiter zu bedienen
und die Batterie ist relativ klein und schlecht.
Ja, also die mit Verbrennungsmotoren.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber auch bei den Elektrofahrzeugen kann man ja die Batterie,
die fürs Fahren ist, jetzt auch nicht selten für was anderes benutzen. Es gibt Ausnahmen.
Es gibt welche.
Mittlerweile die auch so Schleppdosen haben.
Mit 230 Volt Schleppdosen.
Das ist natürlich besonders elegant, das stimmt. Aber was die halt auch nicht
machen, ist den Strom selber generieren. Die verbrauchen ihn halt einfach nur.
Aber sie sind zumindest in der Lage, ihn da zu reichen. Und Elektrofahrzeuge
stellen da sicherlich nochmal eine ganz neue Herausforderung an,
weil das möchte man natürlich auch gerne kombinieren.
Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, man hat jetzt so dieses typische,
ich habe einen Sprinter und will den ausbauen Projekt.
Dann möchte man halt gerne eine 12 Volt oder eine 230 Volt Stromverteilung haben
und man möchte gerne seinen Strom selber erzeugen.
Und das naheliegendste ist natürlich, diesen Strom mit einem Solarpanel zu erzeugen.
Also muss man halt schauen, was man so an Dachfläche denn so hat.
Und da geht dann so ein bisschen die Reise los, weil das im Prinzip so ein bisschen
definiert, zu was du dann später in der Lage bist.
Du kannst natürlich deinen Wagen auch immer über andere Quellen noch aufladen,
also entweder an Feststrom auf dem Campingplatz oder zu Hause, gar keine Frage.
Man kann theoretisch natürlich auch beim Fahren die Batterie noch laden mit
der Lichtmaschine des Fahrzeugs, auch wenn die in der Regel auch nicht so viel
liefern, aber die liefern halt zumindest.
Naja, 100 Watt kriegst du da schon raus.
100 Watt, ja, okay.
Ja.
Wie am wolkigen Tag. Genau.
Aber Solar ist natürlich interessant, weil man schon so auf,
sagen wir mal, wenn man jetzt so einen mittelgroßen Bus hat,
von so einem Sprinter oder so, also etwas größer als ein VW-Bus,
wo man das Dach an sich jetzt erstmal für nichts anderes braucht,
außer vielleicht für irgendeine Luke.
Dann kriegst du da heute, je nachdem, Panels drauf, die für,
ich würde mal sagen, irgendwo zwischen 600 Watt und einem Kilowatt in der Größenordnung so.
Wie viele Quadratmeter hast du da ungefähr? Vier oder so?
Also ich kann dir sagen, was ich drauf habe. Ich habe 5, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27,
28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 41, 42, 43,
44, 45, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50, 51, 51, 52.
52, 53, 52, 53, 54, 55, 56, 57, 58, 58, 59, 59.
60, 61, 61, 62, 62, 62, 62, 62, 63, 62, 63, 62, 62, 63, 62, 62,
63, 62, 62, 63, 62, 62, 63, 62, 63, 62, 62, 63, 62, 62, 63, 62, 63, 62, 62, 63.
62, 63, 62, Also 1 Meter mal 1,70 sind Standard-Panels, die man aufs Dach schraubt.
Achso, 1 Meter mal 1,77 habe ich. Aber mittlerweile setze ich 11,34 glaube ich als Breite durch.
Das ist irgendwie das, was man kriegt. Das ist das neue Format.
Auf jeden Fall, du musst halt nehmen, was bei dir passt. Und es gibt schon Panels
in verschiedensten Größenordnungen.
Und das ist jetzt quasi so der erste Check, den ich sozusagen gemacht habe.
Du musst halt mal gucken, wie viel kannst du der Sonne entgegenrecken.
Und dann gibt es eine Peak-Leistung.
Also das ist das, was theoretisch die Panels unter idealen Bedingungen, also jetzt Mitte Juni.
12 Uhr mittags, nein.
Nein, nein, nein. Mein Schlagzeuger, der arbeitet ja bei der Deutschen Gesellschaft für Solar,
der hat es mal beschrieben, das ist die Sonneneinstrahlung eines Sommertages
bei der Temperatur eines Frühlingstages und dem Spektrum eines Wintertages.
Das ist also völlig synthetisch und ist ein Wert, den du nie erreichst,
realistisch betrachtet.
Aber quasi sehr sonnig im Frühling wäre dann schon inreichend dicht dran,
also da wäre dann der Peak.
Was man nicht unterschätzen darf ist Temperatur der Module, wenn die zu heiß
werden, dann geht extrem die Leistung runter.
Er meinte mal, die Solaranlagen in Spanien haben im April ihr Fördermaximum,
weil danach wird es zu warm.
Also das ist so, klar man kann die jetzt schlecht kühlen, aber ja.
Also man kann nicht davon ausgehen, dass wenn da drauf steht irgendwie 600 Watt Peak,
dass du die einschaltest und dann machen die irgendwie 600 Watt,
sondern das ist sozusagen so das theoretische Maximum, was du erreichen kannst
und ich habe auch schon mal das Maximum mal erreicht, aber halt nur für ein
paar Minuten mal beim Zugucken.
Das ist aber auch egal. Letzten Endes wirst du irgendeinen Mittelwert erreichen.
Also man kann aus diesem Peak mehr oder weniger ableiten, was man wohl so da rauskriegen würde.
Das lässt sich berechnen und je nachdem wie lang die Tage sind und wo du stehst
und wie du stehst und so weiter, kriegst du halt was raus.
Aber es ist durchaus realistisch, dass man halt irgendwie so ein,
zwei, drei Kilowattstunden pro Tag einfach aus der Sonne rausfischt,
auch wenn jetzt nicht die idealen Bedingungen sind mit so einem Setup, wie ich das habe.
Und umso mehr Platz du hast, wenn du jetzt so einen großen Truck hast,
wo du so vier, fünf, sechs Panels drauf ballern kannst.
Naja, also mehr Solar, viel gut. Hut so, das ist so ein Ding.
Kannst du das mal irgendwie übersetzen in so Akkuladungen von einem MacBook oder sowas?
Also in irgendeiner Größe, mit der so Normalsterbliche wie ich irgendwie was verbinden.
Ja, okay, was ist denn dein, was hast du denn für ein Gerät?
Ich habe ein MacBook Pro 14 Zoll mit einer M2 Pro.
Ich glaube, die haben so um die 30 Wattstunden oder so. Also es ist nicht so. Ja, ja, es ist nicht so.
MacBook Pro,
Baujahr 23 M3 Ja.
Ein M2 Pro, aber ein M23 könnte hinkommen.
M14 Pro.
Also du kommst jetzt nicht genau aufs Modell an.
Ja, ich dachte mir nur, wenn du es mal genau wissen willst, dann gucken wir doch mal genau.
Also, Batterie 70 Wattstunden.
70 Wattstunden, naja, das Doppelte von dem, was ich sagte, aber es ist jetzt nicht besonders viel.
So, und du hast gerade von Kilowatt gesprochen, das heißt von 1000 Wattstunden.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das ist jetzt ganz wichtig, dass du aus einer Zeit ist Watt und Wattstunden.
Leistung ist, wie viel verbrauche ich denn jetzt gerade?
Wasserkocher, mach ich an, 1000 Watt. Wenn der 5 Minuten lang 1000 Watt liefert,
dann hast du wie viele Wattstunden verbraucht?
Keine Ahnung, 100 oder so? Weiß nicht, das muss jetzt jemand nachrechnen.
5.000 Wattminuten.
Whatever. Also, Wattstunden ist Energieinhalt und Watt ist Leistung.
Wenn ich eine Kilowattstunde Batterie habe, dann kann ich ein Gerät von einem
Kilowatt, also 1000 Watt, eine Stunde lang damit betreiben.
Oder 100 Watt, 10 Stunden.
Das ist so eigentlich jetzt erstmal, also Rundungsfehler, Verluste etc.
Also wenn du eine Stunde lang ein Kilowatt irgendwo reinschiebst,
dann hast du eine Kilowattstunde.
Das ist die Menge, die in einer Stunde mit einem Kilowatt zusammenkommt.
Die Energie, die du dann übertragen hast, das ist eine Kilowattstunde und das
ist die Größenordnung, in der du deine Batterie bemisst und das ist sozusagen
dein primärer Vorrat, den du haben kannst. Beispiel meiner Installation.
Ich habe zwei Batterien mit 12,8 Volt bei 200 Amperestunden.
Das bedeutet, ich habe ungefähr 2,5 Kilowattstunden pro Batterie.
Beide zusammen machen 5 Kilowattstunden. Das heißt,
wenn ich 100 Watt verbrauche, dann gehen 1 Kilowatt 10 Stunden lang und die
5 Kilowatt gehen dann halt 50 Stunden lang.
Also ich könnte 50 Stunden lang 100 Watt liefern.
Wie viele MacBooks kriege ich jetzt also an einem Tag aufgeladen?
Naja, du hast halt 70 Wattstunden, das sind also 0,07 Kilowattstunden.
Eine ganze Menge.
1.000.
Also eine ganze Menge. MacBook ist ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil das ja so wenig Strom verbraucht.
Aber wenn du sagst, du hast jetzt meinetwegen einen Föhn von 1.000 Watt.
Aber jetzt nochmal, schon ungefähr 100, oder? Liege ich da jetzt falsch?
Ja, ja.
Ich könnte das 71 mal vollladen.
Ja, das ist ja schon mal eine Ansage.
Ja, dazu muss man jetzt mal sagen, im Prinzip spalten sich Verbraucher in zwei große Gruppen auf.
Die einen, die Wärme erzeugen und die anderen, die keine Wärme erzeugen.
Und die, die Wärme erzeugen, brauchen richtig Strom und die,
die keine Wärme erzeugen, meistens nicht so viel, es sei denn,
es ist jetzt ein starker Motor oder so. So.
Und ein MacBook fällt definitiv in die Kategorie nicht so viel Wärme erzeugen.
Keine Ahnung. Also ich persönlich fände 5 Kilowattstunden fürs Camping deutlich überdimensioniert.
Da können wir gleich drüber reden.
Aber ich weiß ja nicht, was du damit machst.
Naja, kann ich dir sagen. Aber jetzt gehen wir nochmal zurück zum Dach.
Okay, aber das mit 4 Quadratmetern auf dem Dach. Ja, genau.
Also sagen wir mal, ich habe so ein Mittel. guten Tag, wo die Panels so ungefähr
die Hälfte liefern von dem, was sie so könnten.
Ich habe 720 oder 760 Kilowatt Peak so.
Das heißt, sagen wir mal so, 300 Watt ist absolut realistisch und an so einem
langen Sommertag, wenn ich das halt dann mal hochrechne, so 300 Watt mal 10
Stunden wären schon so 3 Kilowattstunden.
Da kann ich also meine Batterien fast voll machen.
Also Also wenn sie komplett leer sind nicht, aber wenn sie halt normalerweise,
also es ist immer die Frage, kann ich so meinen Batteriestatus mehr oder weniger
halten und das hängt natürlich auch davon ab, wie viel du verbrauchst.
Also muss man im Prinzip bei seiner Planung erstmal auch damit anfangen,
okay, was kann ich liefern,
wie viel Geld kann ich investieren, wie viel Platz kann ich auch bereitstellen
in diesem Fahrzeug, um das zu speichern in Batterien und was ist mein Verbrauch.
Und beim Verbrauch lohnt es sich, glaube ich, von Anfang an schon mal klar zu
rechnen, okay, was brauche ich eigentlich, was immer läuft und was brauche ich,
was unter Umständen viel Strom frisst, was manchmal läuft.
Weil was wenig Strom frisst und manchmal läuft, kannst du ignorieren,
sondern das sind so diese beiden Sachen. Ich habe zum Beispiel bei mir einen
LTE-Router, der läuft immer.
Und so ein Überwachungsgerät für die ganze Anlage, die diese Internetverbindung
nutzt, um regelmäßig da die Daten rauszuloggen und erreichbar zu sein,
damit ich mir das auch schön in der Cloud immer angucken kann,
wie es gerade meinem System geht.
Und wenn ich Licht aus habe, sonst keine Verbraucher anhabe,
sondern nur dieses totale Minimum, verbraucht dieses System 15 Watt.
Das heißt, diese 15 Watt, 24 Stunden sind schon mal 360 Wattstunden.
Schon gar nicht so wenig.
Genau, also im Vergleich zu den 5000 Wattstunden, die ich habe,
macht diese Grundlast auf 24 Stunden gerechnet, ohne dass ich jetzt was reinschiebe.
Also angenommen, es ist wirklich total zappenduster, Regen, dann kommt also
manchmal auch wirklich gar nichts an.
Also es kann wirklich so ein dunkler Tag, da ist dann einfach gar nichts.
Du stehst scheiße, du hast Bäume über dir, kannst gerade nicht woanders hin und so weiter.
Und 15 Watt ist jetzt aber auch auch wenig. Aber ich könnte mir jetzt,
ich habe dann aber auch andere Grundlasten, wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt noch
meine Starlink-Antenne noch mit dazu nehme.
Die verbraucht mehr, ne?
Ja, also ich habe die mittlerweile auch, lasse ich die nicht mehr über 32,
also wenn du normalerweise Starlink hast, hast du ja nochmal einen eigenen Router,
den musst du an 230 Volt anschließen, damit die dann wiederum 48 Volt für die Dings erzeugt.
Und ich habe jetzt mir einen 12 Volt zu 48 Volt Transformer,
so einen Step-Up-Konverter reingenommen.
Das heißt, ich versorge sie direkt aus der Batterie, ohne dass ich den Wechselrichter
brauche. Das heißt, ich habe diese Verluste nicht.
Also Wechselrichter ist das Gerät, was 230 Volt Wechselstrom erzeugt.
So, und dann kommen ungefähr, je nach Last, so 40 bis 50 Watt dazu.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt die Grundlast nehme, meine 15, die ich vorhin hatte,
und sagen wir mal großzügig 50 Watt nochmal für Starlink, habe ich schon 750
Wattstunden, die auf 24 Stunden sozusagen verbraucht würden.
Also noch kein Kühlschrank oder ähnliches.
Genau, da ist noch kein Kühlschrank dabei. Also wir hatten jetzt sozusagen diese 15 plus 50.
Jetzt nehmen wir mal nochmal einen Kühlschrank dazu. Wenn du dir heute so einen
modernen Kompressor-Dometik-Kühlschrank für ein Wohnmobil kaufst,
die kommen auch mit 12 Watt aus.
Die sind relativ sparsam.
Und jetzt die Frage, was brauchst du sonst noch? dann geht es jetzt vielleicht
mal darum, dass du vielleicht auch mal drin wohnen willst.
Dann hast du auch nochmal für, dann hast du Licht, das nimmst du natürlich LED,
das kann sparsam sein, dann nimmt das Licht, wenn du alles anmachst,
vielleicht 10 Watt und die brauchst du dann auch nur mal 4 Stunden.
Also das hält sich dann sozusagen sehr in Grenzen, das kann man schon fast ignorieren,
aber da kommen dann vielleicht auch nochmal so 20 Watt.
5 Watt noch mit drauf. Jetzt sind wir bei 82 Watt Grundlast.
Irgendwelche anderen Appliances, dann willst du noch deinen HomePod laufen lassen,
dann lädst du irgendwie deine Geräte nachts immer nach, was nochmal was ausmacht und so weiter.
Also vielleicht landest du irgendwann so bei 100 Watt und dann heißt es 100
Watt in 24 Stunden, das sind dann schon 2400 Wattstunden, die weggehen und dann
ist dein Akku nach zwei Tagen leer, wenn du nicht nachschiebst.
Und da muss man halt schauen, was kann ich mit Solar reinschieben,
damit ich auch sicher gehe, dass ich auch bei drei schlechten Tagen auch bei
etwas höherem Verbrauch was habe.
Weil ich meine, ich habe dann irgendwie noch eine Brotbackmaschine dabei,
die ist eine Stunde mit 600 Watt unterwegs, sind schon wieder 600 Wattstunden weg.
Macht Wärme, verbraucht viel Strom.
Genau, macht Wärme.
Der Föhn für deine vielen Haare.
Naja, dann willst du mal, irgendwas musst du ja essen, wenn du den Gaskocher
nimmst, okay, kommt das nicht mit rein.
Wenn du ein Induktionsstove hast, Dann wird es sportlich.
Oder, was weiß ich, ich habe noch so einen Sandwich-Maker am Start,
der zieht dann halt auch mal einen Kilowatt, aber das macht er halt auch nur ein paar Minuten.
Aber das sind so diese Großverbraucher, die so zwischendurch dann auch nochmal alle nagen.
Und dann wird das dann schon so ein Spiel, was ist genug? Weil das hängt dann
so ein bisschen auch davon ab, wie viel Luxus dir du leistest.
Du möchtest warm duschen, du möchtest warmes Wasser haben, du möchtest vielleicht
auch längere Zeit haben. Das gibt es auch über Gas.
Die Frage ist natürlich auch, will man überhaupt noch Gas?
Genau, ja.
Und es gibt natürlich Argumente für Gas, weil Gas ist so etablierte Technik.
Kriegst du überall deine Gasflasche getauscht.
Jetzt kann man natürlich auch sagen, ich will aber hier klimaneutral leben und
den geilen Lifestyle nur aus der Sonne liefern.
Das kann im Sommer ganz gut funktionieren. Wird im Winter mit einer Heizung, wird es schwierig.
Aber ich würde sagen, Kühlschrank ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Und so ein Induktionskochherd kann man auch machen, aber da braucht man dann
definitiv den Wechselrichter.
Den habe ich ja bisher noch rausgelassen aus dem Spiel, weil bisher haben wir
ja eigentlich nur das Panel,
aber die Batterie und dafür ist dann noch eine Technik erforderlich,
damit das Spiel überhaupt läuft, der sogenannte Solarregler.
Zum Thema Winter, im Winter hast du aber auch keinen Solar.
Nein, nicht keins.
Im Winter hast du halt so viel Solar, wie du bei.
Meiner Solaranlage auf dem Dach kommst. Im Januar und im Dezember ungefähr ein
Zwanzigstel vom Dach, als in den Sommermonaten hier.
Ja, man muss sich halt mehr zurückhalten.
Roddy zeigt gerade hier einen Chart von seiner eigenen Anlage und es reicht
also von 0,2 im Winter bis 1,5 im Sommer als Peak.
Das sind, ich weiß gar nicht, was da jetzt...
Wenn man in Berlin bleibt, wenn man jetzt mit seinem Wohnmobil unterwegs ist,
dann will man ja nicht im Winter unbedingt nach Berlin, sondern reist man ja
vielleicht in den Süden, könnte ich mir vorstellen. Da gibt es dann schon noch ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, da sind die Tage im Winter ein bisschen länger als hier,
das ist richtig, aber trotzdem hast du natürlich schon den Effekt,
dass du kürzere Tage hast.
Längere Tage heißen halt auch länger Sonne und deswegen kriegst du da halt auch länger Solar.
Und das ist ein Faktor, den darf
man zumindest in unseren Breiten nicht unterschätzen, der ist gigantisch.
Ja, genau. Aber vielleicht nochmal so zur Technik. Was braucht man jetzt eigentlich,
um das alles zum Laufen zu bringen?
Also du hast die Panels, die fangen die Sonne ein.
Jedes Panel erzeugt eine Spannung in einem bestimmten Range,
die so ein bisschen abhängig davon ist.
Wie sie geregelt werden.
Wie sie geregelt werden, aber auch schon, die davon abhängig ist,
von der Temperatur oder von der Einstrahlungsintensität, auch von der Temperatur.
Von einigen Faktoren. Nein, nein, nein. Und genau das ist das,
was an Solarpanels relativ schwer zu verstehen ist.
Und zwar von der Einstrahlungsstärke und der Temperatur hängt im Wesentlichen der Strom ab.
Strom ist nämlich Ladungsträger pro Zeiteinheit.
Jetzt muss man sich das so vorstellen, da kommt jetzt so ein Lichtteilchen an
und haut dir so ein Elektron irgendwie aus dem Kristallgitter.
Und so eine Solarzelle ist im Wesentlichen eine Diode.
Das heißt, der Strom kann in die eine Richtung fließen, aber nicht in die andere Richtung.
Das heißt, wenn das rausgekickte Elektron zur richtigen Seite gekickt wird,
kann es nicht mehr zurück, sondern muss außenrum durch den Schaltkreis,
den du da anschließt, fließen, um wieder auf die Seite zu kommen,
wo es eigentlich hingehört.
Das heißt, eine gewisse Einstrahlung führt zu einer gewissen Menge an Ladungsträger,
die pro Zeit rausgeschlagen werden aus dem Kristallgitter und das bedeutet ein gewisser Strom.
Jetzt ist es aber so, wenn ich nichts anschließe, kann kein Strom fließen.
Wenn ich den kurz schließe, fällt aber wiederum, wie erkläre ich das?
Also der Grund, warum der nicht zurück kann, ist, weil da ein elektrisches Feld ist.
Also das Elektron geht auf die andere Seite, kommt nicht zurück und dadurch
wird die Seite, wo sich die Elektronen sammeln, immer negativer und die Seite,
wo keine Elektronen sind, immer positiver.
Bis zu dem Punkt, wo die Spannung reicht, dass es doch wieder zurück kann,
weil es so stark angezogen wird.
Also von der negativen Seite abgestoßen, von der positiven angezogen.
So, das heißt, die Spannung steigt bis zu einem bestimmten Punkt,
wenn man nichts anschließt und die nicht fließen können, bis die nicht mehr
in der Lage sind, rüber zu hüpfen, weil das Feld zu groß ist.
Wenn ich jetzt einen Kurzschluss baue, dann fließen alle direkt ab.
Aber, und das ist das Problem am Kurzschluss, mit dem Strom kann man da nichts machen.
Weil Leistung, elektrische Leistung ist Spannung mal Strom. Oder die.
Einen Maximum Powerpoint-Tracker. Okay. Der maximiert die Leistung,
die ich aus dem Solarmodul rausbekomme,
indem das Ding immer wieder nachregelt, wie viel Strom da fließen und wie viel Spannung baut sich auf.
Das ist nämlich der eigentliche Trick an der Sache.
Wie die Teile tatsächlich funktionieren, tut jetzt erstmal nichts zur Sache.
Aber wichtig ist, dieser MPPT regelt das Solarmodul so, dass du im Prinzip zu
der Einstrahlung, die du hast, immer das Maximum rausholst.
Und ohne den MPPT passiert gar nichts, zumindest nichts Sinnvolles.
Also dieser Solarregler, wie man dieses Gerät nennt, das ist halt einfach das
Teil, was du ans Panel anschließt.
Und du musst halt einen Solarregler finden, der die richtige Dimension hat und
es gibt da im Wesentlichen zwei Zahlen, die da angegeben werden.
Also du hast halt typischerweise sowas wie 100 slash 50 und das bedeutet,
dass die Spannung, die die Panels liefern,
die muss maximal, darf die bei 100 Volt liegen, das heißt die Zahl und das hat
so ein bisschen was damit zu tun, was sozusagen die Eigenspannung ist.
Also jedes Panel hat so eine Spannung, die es im Wesentlichen irgendwie liefert
und darauf wollte ich hinaus, die variiert so ein bisschen mit der Situation,
aber bewegt sich in einem bestimmten Bereich.
Bei mir sind das so 31 Volt pro Panel und ich habe zwei Panels,
die irgendwie parallel geschaltet sind und die dann sozusagen beide mit derselben Spannung daherkommen.
Also bei meinem Solarregler mit so um die 30, 40 Volt aufschlagen.
Nein, doch. Die sind garantiert in Reihe geschaltet.
Ja, bist du sicher? Aber ich habe mal nachgeguckt, sozusagen die Spezifikation
für ein Panel, das ist auch das, was beide liefern.
Ja, nur was kann dein Regler, sagtest du? 100 maximal. Der kann die 31 Volt?
Nee, 100 maximal.
100 maximal, ja, dann hängen sie sehr wahrscheinlich in Reihe.
Das ist auch das, was du üblicherweise tust, dann addieren sich die Spannungen.
Achso, und was habe ich gesagt?
Parallel.
Achso, dann habe ich mich einfach verdreht, genau, weil ich das immer mache
und das ist halt das Problem, man kommt halt durcheinander, wenn man es nicht
vollständig verstanden hat.
Ist auch eigentlich egal, ich wollte nur darauf hinaus, man kann das sozusagen
so arrangieren, man muss diesen passenden Solarregler haben für die konkrete
Konstruktion, die man da drauf gemacht hat und die sozusagen,
es muss sozusagen zusammenpassen.
Und dieses Teil nimmt den Strom,
regelt die Panels, wie Roddy das beschrieben hat, mit dieser MPPT-Technik und
den daraus resultierenden Strom und das ist dann diese zweite Zahl,
die hier ins Spiel kommt, mit einem maximalen Ladestrom in diese Batterien.
Mit anderen Worten, obwohl ich einen Peak von 760 Watt habe,
kann dieser Solarregler maximal 600 Watt, also 12 Volt, ein bisschen mehr,
macht es wahrscheinlich mit 13.
Also mehr oder weniger eigentlich alles, was diese Panels liefern können,
kriege ich auch gerade noch so in die Batterien rein.
Das heißt, das ist ein Kombigerät, also der regelt sowohl die Panels als auch
macht auch noch ein Batteriemanagementsystem.
Nee, das ist kein Batterie-Management-System. Das ist einfach nur der Läder für die Batterien.
Achso, er hat einfach so und so viel Output, aber du brauchst ja noch ein Batterie-Management-System.
Jaja, aber das ist ja jetzt erstmal egal. Es geht jetzt erstmal nur darum zu
verstehen, ich habe Panels, ich habe einen Solarregler, der schiebt das in die
Batterien rein und das würde ja dann auch erstmal reichen.
Wie die Batterien gemanagt werden, ist jetzt nochmal eine andere Geschichte.
Ich will es jetzt auch nicht zu kompliziert machen. Ich möchte jetzt nur ein
Verständnis dafür aufbauen, wie gehe ich da heran?
Und ich sage nochmal, guck erstmal auf dein Dach, was passt drauf?
Guck mal, was ist das Maximum? Du willst immer das Maximum haben.
Du möchtest einfach, was geht, willst du drauf haben. Panels sind so billig,
die sind wirklich das geringste Problem.
Das gilt auch für Hausinstallationen, sind inzwischen so billig.
Was heißt denn so billig? Habt ihr da mal eine Hausnummer?
Also ich habe jetzt keine direkte Hausnummer, aber das Ding ist,
wenn da eine Firma kommt und vielleicht sogar ein Gerüst aufbaut,
um aufs Dach zu kommen, dann zahlst du schon mehr als für die Panels,
selbst wenn du das Dach voll machst.
Also das ist wirklich nicht der Kostenfaktor. Der Kostenfaktor ist eher die
ganzen Arbeiten rundherum, Leitungen verlegen, im Keller Dinge montieren und so weiter.
Also ich habe jetzt mal geguckt hier einfach so ein normales,
ich sitze irgendwie mal so reingeklickt ins Netz, so ein Panel,
was 425 Watt Peak hat, das ist schon mehr als ich habe, kostet irgendwie 60 Euro.
60? Okay.
Also die Preise sind so im, also Panels kosten nichts. Deine Ressource ist Platz.
Ja.
Wenn du oben viel Platz hast, mach viel Solar drauf.
Mach so viel drauf, wie du nur irgendwie kannst. Dann musst du schauen,
was ergibt das sozusagen in der Summe für Ströme und Volt.
Dann musst du den passenden Solarregler dafür aussuchen.
Da gibt es dann entsprechende Berechnungshilfen im Netz und so weiter,
die dir das dann errechnen, was sozusagen das ist, was du bräuchtest.
Und dann musst du halt schauen, was kannst du bezahlen an Batterien,
wobei auch die Batteriepreise nennenswert gefallen sind.
Also LFP, das ist also die Batterien, die ich vor zwei Jahren gekauft habe,
kosten mittlerweile nur noch ein Drittel davon.
Also das ist völlig absurd. Da gehen die Preise gerade völlig in den Keller.
Und ich denke mal, durch Durch die Natrium-Ionen-Batterien wird das Spiel noch
ein bisschen weiter gehen.
Da hängt es dann eher davon ab, wie viel Platz hast du in deinem Fahrzeug.
Was ist deine Zuladung? Wie schwer dürfen die sein?
Wie groß sind deine Batterien jetzt?
Nicht sehr groß. Ich habe diese relativ teuren Dinger von Victron.
Die sind dafür bekannt, dass sie sehr kompakt sind.
Also das ist wirklich so ein, keine Ahnung, die beiden sind zusammen vielleicht so ein Bierkasten groß.
Vielleicht ein bisschen größer und machen halt diese 5 Kilowattstunden.
Also Natrium ist noch am Horizont, das ist noch nicht hier.
Und die Energiedichte ist jetzt nicht so geil, also ob man sie wirklich für
mobile Anwendungen sehen wird, keine Ahnung, werden wir sehen.
Werden wir sehen, aber die werden halt noch mal billiger sein auf jeden Fall.
Für stationäre Anwendungen.
Ja, und wenn du so ein LKW ausbaust, wo du einfach, wo Platz nicht so das Problem ist.
Zumal die Natrium-Ionen-Batterien gegenüber den Lithium-Batterien noch den großen Vorteil haben,
dass sie während die Lithium-Batterien jetzt so bei 5 Grad dann irgendwann mit
dem Laden aufhören, weil du sie dann bei der Temperatur nicht mehr geladen bekommst,
wenn das Fahrzeug draußen steht, sind die Natrium-
Ionen-Batterien so, die gehen dann auch noch bei minus,
20 Grad, wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe.
Aber sind also deutlich temperaturtoleranter.
Da würde ich abwarten, bis sie tatsächlich im Markt verfügbar sind und was die
Leute dann für Erfahrungen damit haben, weil die Hersteller natürlich auch gerne rumprotzen.
Ja, aber es ist, sagen wir mal,
Von der Physik, von Natrium her ist klar, dass die auf jeden Fall deutlich weniger
temperatursensitiv sind.
Und sie werden billiger sein, das vor allen Dingen. Das ist glaube ich ein großer Faktor.
Und jetzt haben wir sozusagen das Kernsystem. Sonne kommt an,
erzeugt Strom, der Solarregler sorgt dafür, dass die optimal ausgelastet werden
und pumpt diesen Strom in deine Batterie und da liegt es rum. Warum?
Und die zweite interessante, also dann hast du natürlich die ganze Verteilungsgeschichte,
da gehe ich jetzt nicht groß drauf ein.
Die nächste wichtige Komponente ist, du möchtest halt dann doch auch mal Powerstrom haben.
Also du möchtest für bestimmte Sachen, wie zum Beispiel so ein Induktionsherd
oder wenn du mal deine Power Tools laden oder direkt betreiben möchtest oder
halt was weiß ich. Den Sandwich-Maker.
Der Bohrhammer, genau. Der Bohrhammer, der kommt ja mittlerweile auch aus dem Makita-Akku.
Aber die Akkus laden macht man dann doch eher mit einem 230-Volt-Anschluss und
den Sandwich-Maker und das Waffeleisen dann halt auch eher.
Und so auch die Brotbackmaschine, natürlich. Also es gibt Bedarf für 230 Volt.
Allein, wenn man mal nicht den passenden Adapter für 12 Volt am Start hat für
das jeweilige Gerät, weil für 230 Volt gibt es alles.
Will man also haben und dafür braucht man einen Wechselrichter.
Und Wechselrichter ist sozusagen das schwerste und größte Gerät, so oder so.
Speziell, wenn man halt auf ein 12-Volt-System setzt. Und hier muss man vielleicht
auch nochmal generell sagen...
Man muss sich überlegen, was man so an Bordstrom eigentlich als Basis haben
will, weil mittlerweile ist es glaube ich fast sinnvoller, wenn man was Neues plant,
dass man auf 24 oder sogar auf 48 Volt geht, weil das macht dann die ganze Verkabelung einfacher.
Das ist ja sozusagen auch etwas, was man bei Strom begreifen muss.
Wenn du die gleiche Energie mit einer niedrigen Voltzahl, mit einer niedrigen
Spannung übertragen willst, das ist ja immer dieses Gleichnis mit Wasser.
Wenn du einen niedrigen Druck hast,
Wasserdruck, du machst einen Wasserhahn auf und das Wasser tröpfelt nur so aus
der Leitung, weil da einfach kein Druck ist.
Das ist halt vergleichbar mit einer niedrigen Spannung beim Strom.
Da werden also die Elektronen sehr langsam rausgeschoben und wenn du eine große
Energiemenge aber brauchst, dann brauchst du bei diesem Druck einfach ein größeres Rohr,
damit zum gleichen Zeitpunkt mit diesem niedrigen Druck mehr Wasser durch das
Rohr durch kann. Und genauso ist das auch beim Strom.
Wenn du halt mit 12 Volt arbeitest und du brauchst mal viel Energie,
brauchst du einfach ein fettes Kabel.
Und deswegen sind an solchen 12 Volt Batterien in so einem Wohnmobil die fettesten
Kabel, die du je gesehen hast.
So richtig wurstdicke Teile, weil der Strom da so langsam durchgedrückt wird,
dass wenn du die ganze Energie auch abholen willst, die du irgendwo reinjagen
willst, dann braucht die einfach Raum.
Was spricht dagegen 230 Volt.
Dass es Wechselstrom ist?
230 Volt ist halt Wechselstrom. Wir reden jetzt gerade von Gleichstrom in den
Batterien, also Solar und Batterie, das ist alles Gleichstromwelt.
Wechselstrom ist so Powerstrom. Deswegen ist der Alternative current.
Ein Wechselstrom ist insofern interessant, als dass du ihn viel einfacher konvertieren
kannst in eine höhere Spannung oder in eine niedrigere Spannung.
Einfach mit einem Transformator. Das kannst du bei Gleichstrom nicht so einfach.
Gut, da gibt es auch Gerätschaften, die das können. Aber es ist halt nicht ganz
so einfach. Das Problem ist, aus Gleichstrom Wechselstrom zu machen mit einem
Wechselrichter ist schon auch Rechtverlust behaftet.
Und hinterher aus dem Wechselstrom dann wieder Gleichstrom zu machen, weil...
Im Wesentlichen alle Geräte, die nicht das mit der Hitze machen,
machen sowieso hinterher wieder Gleichstrom aus dem Strom.
Also dein Netzteil, was du dann in die Steckdose steckst.
Dein Netzteil, genau. Insofern ist es immer sinnvoll, wenn du dir diesen Schritt
sparen kannst, wenn es wirklich auf Verbrauch kommt.
Guck mal jetzt, kommen aber doch wirklich diese Things I learned today Momente.
Das heißt also, das was hier in meinem MacBook über USB-C ankommt, ist Gleichstrom.
Ach was, na guck, schon was gelernt.
Ja.
Und das, was jetzt irgendwo da in den Kabelschächten von Tim liegt,
ist dann das Netzteil, was aus den 230 Volt, den guten USB-C,
wie auch immer er geregelt wird, Strom ist. Es ist ja auch nicht immer die gleiche Spannung.
Und damit ich nicht so sehr auf Wechselstrom angewiesen bin,
habe ich jetzt auch für mittlere Verbraucher so leistungsfähige USB-C-Dosen,
die an 12 Volt hängen in meinem Wohnwagen,
wo ich auch mal 65 Watt rausholen kann.
Aber da muss ich halt auch zusehen, dass die Kabel, die da hinführen,
dick genug sind, um diese Energie mit 12 Volt auch rüber zu bekommen.
Also nochmal zurück, Solar, Solarregler, Batterie, alles eine Gleichstromwelt
und ich kann diesen Gleichstrom mit entsprechend dicken Kabeln verteilen und
am Ende auch in USB-C Steckdosen umwandeln,
die dann eben auf Bedarf 5,
9, 12 oder 20 Volt mit verschiedenen Strömen liefern.
Das funktioniert ganz wunderbar und dafür brauche ich keinen 230 Volt.
Trotzdem habe ich 230 Volt Bedarf für Powergeräte und für, wenn man mal nicht
den richtigen Stecker und Adapter hat und dann kommt doch noch einer mit irgendeinem Netzteil.
Also 230 Volt ist irgendwie immer praktisch und deswegen brauchst du halt diesen
Transformator, Entschuldigung, Wechselrichter, der dir das sozusagen aus deinem Gleichstrom umsetzt.
Umso niedriger dein Batteriestrom ist,
umso aufwendiger ist diese Wandlung zu 230 Volt und deswegen ist es halt sinnvoll
auch darüber nachzudenken, ob man nicht vielleicht sein ganzes System schon mal auf 48 Volt macht.
Du kriegst alles auch irgendwie mit 48 Volt.
Du kriegst auch deine Solarpanels irgendwie so konfiguriert,
dass du eine 48 Volt Batterie laden kannst damit.
Und dann ist halt dein Wechselrichter in der Regel sehr viel leistungsfähiger
bei gleichem Gewicht, weil er eben nicht so tief Luft holen muss.
Und dann kommt da halt 230 Volt Strom bei raus.
Wenn du trotzdem noch 12 Volt brauchst, kannst du mühelos aus deinem 48 Volt
wieder 12 machen durch entsprechende Verteiler. Das ist gar nicht so das Problem.
Aber der Wechselrichter, so oder so, unabhängig davon, für welche Voltzahl man
sich jetzt entschieden hat,
der hängt halt irgendwo an der Wand und ist ziemlich schwer und groß und brummt
auch ein bisschen, wenn man ihn einschaltet und verbraucht auch schon mal Strom,
wenn er eingeschaltet ist.
Im Idealfall nicht so viel, aber allein, dass du sagst, ab jetzt könnte auch
230 Volt benutzt werden, kostet dich auch schon mal wieder, je nachdem, 10 oder 5 Watt.
Was man in dem Zusammenhang halt wissen muss, ist, der Wechselstrom ist eigentlich
eine saubere Sinusschwingung.
Jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass immer ein bisschen Schmutz drin ist,
ist er, wenn du jetzt ein Oszilloskop an die Steckdose hältst,
siehst du wirklich eine superschöne Sinusschwingung.
Wenn du ein Oszilloskop an so einen Wechselrichter hängst, nee,
das sind dann gerne mal so Treppenstufen, so richtig Treppenstufen.
Ja, nicht jedes Gerät mag das, sagen wir mal so.
Also es kann dir halt durchaus passieren, wenn du da Omas altes Röhrenradio
anschließt, dass du dann ein fürchterliches Brummen drauf hast,
weil sich diese ganzen schmutzigen Treppenstufen durch den Eingang von deinem
Radio irgendwie bis auf den Lautsprecher durchschlagen.
Also insofern, also 230 Volt im mobilen Einsatz sollte man vermeiden, wo es geht.
Ganz ehrlich. Das ist irgendwie...
Weil der Sinus nicht sauber genug ist?
Naja, ich meine, wenn es den Toaster anschließt, ist es egal. Aber...
Einfach die Verluste, die du hast und so weiter und so weiter.
Also es ist natürlich Luxus, aber ich kann dir sagen, das Leben mit 230 Volt
als Option ist dann im mobilen Bedarf.
Das ist einfach gut. Du kannst halt einfach alles anschließen,
was du auch an eine Steckdose anschließen kannst, wenn es nicht zu viel zieht.
Ein Problem ist natürlich, ich habe natürlich versucht, mein Elektromotorrad
von meinem Wohnwagen auszuladen.
Okay.
Geht aber nicht, weil mein Wechselrichter halt so sustained vielleicht so,
naja, so 1200, maximal 1500 Watt erträgt.
Das ist ja mal nicht so viel.
Nee, ist nicht so viel, aber dafür ist es auch eine relativ kompakte Lösung für 12 Volt.
Es ist nicht so viel, wenn du ein Elektromotorrad laden willst.
Achso, das würde ja reichen. Das Problem ist nur, ich kann das Motorrad zwar
runtersetzen auf die niedrigste Ladestufe,
aber das sind dann immer noch 6 Ampere und das resultiert dann in einer 2 Kilowatt
Last und da sagt der Wechselrichter irgendwann,
sorry, aber I'm not specced for that.
Abgesehen davon, dass es natürlich ein bisschen mörderisch ist,
mein 9 Kilowattstunden Akku, den ich im Motorrad habe, aus einem 5 Kilowattstunden Akku,
im Wohnwagen zu laden, aber es war einfach nur mal so, einfach mal eine Kilowattstunde
rüber wäre doch mal geil irgendwie, aber leider kann ich es nicht weiter limitieren. Naja, mal gucken.
Also in dem Zusammenhang, wenn man das alles nicht selber machen aus Einzelteilen
zusammenbauen und fest verdrahten und hast du nicht gesehen.
Ich habe mir jetzt von EcoFlow so eine kleine Kompaktbatterie gekauft.
Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst, also ich habe hier die kleinste
Variante, die sie hatten.
EcoFlow River 2 heißt die.
Achso, so eine tragbare Rumschleppbatterie mit Solarregler drin.
So schlepp ist die gar nicht. Die ist erstaunlich leicht.
Aber ja, also da ist ein Solarregler drin.
Das Lustige ist, an dem Port, wo man die Solarzelle anschließt,
kann man auch einfach 12 Volt vom Autostrom anschließen.
Und dann hat das Ding also einen Ausgang für 12 Volt, auch nochmal so eine Autosteckdose,
hat eine 230 Volt Steckdose und hat,
und das finde ich eigentlich am lustigsten, hat einen USB-C-Port und man kann
ihn auch über den USB-C-Port laden.
Sehr schön.
Der River, EcoFlow River 2, das ist der ganz, nee, noch weiter rechts. Nicht Pro?
Nein, nicht Pro. Wirklich der kleinste.
Könnte ich nicht scrollen, hier ist irgendwie Scrollverbot.
Scrollverbot. Da, nee, noch einen, der ganz kleine. Der ganz kleine. Der hier. Ja.
Ich habe mir gedacht, die Preise fallen und fallen und fallen.
Da hat es jetzt irgendwie keinen Sinn, irgendwie viel Geld auszugeben.
Kaufst du mal den kleinsten.
Und ich Ich muss sagen, ich bin ganz zufrieden mit dem Teil.
Ich habe jetzt keine Solarzelle dafür.
Wie viele Kilowattstunden hat der?
Eine Viertelte.
250.
250 Wattstunden.
256.
Genau. Das reicht aber zusammen mit dem Kühlschrank, den ich auch besorgt habe,
um den Kühlschrank 24 Stunden zu betreiben.
Oder Kühlbox. Und zwar von einem Laden, den ich vorher auch noch nicht kannte.
Die nennen sich Plug-In Festivals.
Und der Plug-In Festivals, diese Kühlbox ist wirklich geil.
Sie ist leise, sie verbraucht wenig und sie hat einen Stöpsel unten.
Also wenn man das Ding irgendwie wirklich, also wenn da sich wirklich Wasser
angesammelt hat, kann man den Stöpsel ziehen und dann läuft das ganze Wasser
unten wieder raus. Und das ist schon wirklich sehr geil.
Link in den Chat bitte, weil sonst fragen mich wieder alle.
Jetzt muss ich kurz gucken, welchen ich den 30.
Das kostet auch nur 220 Euro, das Teil.
Ja, okay, wir kommen schon wieder ab. Ich wollte noch kurz diese mobile Perspektive zu Ende bringen.
Also solche tragbaren Systeme, die schon Solarregler haben, das ist so ganz
geil für das kleine Solarpanel, was man noch so mitführt.
Ich weiß nicht, was man da anschließen kann, wahrscheinlich nicht so viel.
100 Watt.
100 Watt, genau. Also dann kannst du halt noch mal so ein faltbares Solarpanel
mitnehmen, das irgendwo hinlegen in die Sonne und dann lädst du halt auch deinen
Akku mit auf. Das ist auch cool.
Da tut sich jetzt immer mehr in diesem Markt. Also diese dicken Batterien zum
Rumschleppen, das ist wirklich eine interessante Generator-Alternative.
Ist auch nicht für die Anwendung, für die du es hast. Ich habe es wirklich auch nur für die Kühlbox.
Ich hänge das Ding halt an den normalen Autostrom ran, an die 12 Volt.
Hänge dann den Kühlschrank über die 12 Volt an das Ding und dann, ja. Ja, dann hält der.
Schön, wie sie hier auf den ganzen Produktfotos dann,
das Powerbook-Netzteil an die 230-Volt-Steckdose ranstecken,
anstatt direkt aus dem USB-C zu laden.
Ja nun. Gut.
Ich versuche nochmal kurz die Perspektive zu machen.
Solar liefert den Strom, Solarregler regelt das Panel, tankt die Batterie voll.
Der Wechselrichter wird daneben angeschlossen und macht dir 230 Volt.
Jetzt gibt es noch etwas, was man möchte.
Man möchte auch in der Lage sein, den Strom aus dem Festnetz zu entnehmen,
wenn er denn da ist, wenn man an einem Campingplatz steht oder sonst wo in der
Nähe mit einer Steckdose, möchte man ja dann auch die Gelegenheit nutzen,
einmal powermäßig die Batterie voll zu bekommen oder vielleicht für eine Zeit
lang auch direkt daraus betrieben zu werden.
Deswegen lohnt es sich meiner Meinung
nach einen Wechselrichter gleich mit integriertem Ladegerät zu kaufen.
Das bedeutet, dass man eben auch noch einen externen Stromanschluss,
also so einen Campingplug in der Regel, diese blauen Stecker reinstecken kann
und dann werden die 230 Volt direkt auch mit in die Batterie geladen.
Das geht also parallel, man kann mit Solar und mit Netz reinladen,
kannst dann auch einen Generator darüber anschließen, das ist auch noch eine
Möglichkeit und es macht Sinn, sozusagen Wechselrichter und Lader in einem zu haben,
weil du dann auch das benutzen kannst wie so eine UPS.
Also bei meinem System ist es so, wenn ich da den Feststrom reinstecke,
dann ist der Wechselrichter in der Lage im Betrieb unterbrechungsfrei den neuen Strom,
der dazugekommen ist, anstatt des eben noch vom Wechselrichter erzeugten Stroms
durchzuschalten, ohne dass irgendetwas davon was mitbekommt.
Also ein leichter Energieknick ist vielleicht noch zu merken,
aber funktioniert ganz problemlos und das ist eigentlich so ein bisschen das
Minimum, was man haben will.
Also Solar, Solarregler, Batterie, Wechselrichter und eingebauter Lader.
Ja und was ich dann außerdem noch habe, was ich wirklich cool finde und wo ich
jetzt ehrlich gesagt nur für die Victron-Lösung sprechen kann,
ist, dass halt Victron das ganz gut hinbekommen hat mit Einschränkungen,
diese ganzen einzelnen Komponenten miteinander zu verbinden,
wie sie das nennen, über ein sogenanntes GX-Gerät.
Das sind also im Prinzip Datensammelstationen, die all diese ganzen aktuellen
Daten aufzeichnen und dann auf eine SD-Karte schreiben,
aber auch an ihre kostenlose User-Cloud hochladen können.
Das heißt, du kannst da bei Victron Energy in diesem VRM-System dir einen Account
klicken, deine Installation sozusagen dort announcen,
so hier mein Wohnwagen und dann werden die ganzen Geräte permanent gepollt und
in Echtzeit da reingeschoben.
Und ich kann mir also jetzt im Web in Echtzeit anschauen, was gerade in diesem System vor sich geht.
So ist natürlich jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt gerade natürlich keine Sonne,
aber ich sehe halt den aktuellen Gleichstromverbrauch, diese 13 bis 15 Watt,
von denen ich vorhin gesprochen habe.
Ich sehe genau, die Batterie ist gerade halb voll.
Kannst du mal zeigen, was er heute im Laufe des Tages geladen hat?
Da war ja viel Regen, ein bisschen Sonne.
Ja, kann ich hier, das siehst du, wenn du ein bisschen runter scrollst.
Also wir schauen jetzt hier gerade auf das Dashboard, das ist sozusagen,
wie der Name schon sagt, so erstmal Instrumentenübersicht.
Unter anderem sehe ich halt hier für einen beliebigen Zeitraum,
in diesem Fall hier schauen wir gerade auf die letzten 24 Stunden,
sehe ich hier rote Balken ist Verbrauch, gelbe Balken ist, was über Solar reingekommen ist.
Ich kann mir auch so einen speziellen Verbrauchsview anschauen,
wo ich sehe, sind die Ströme aus der Batterie gerade entnommen worden oder ist
das komplett von Solar bedient worden.
Sehe ich jetzt hier mit Blau und Gelb, beziehungsweise würde Feststromanschluss
noch mit dazukommen, würde ich das hier auch nochmal in roter Farbe sehen.
Also dieser ganze Mix lässt sich hier ablesen. Das ist schon mal sehr praktisch.
Also man kriegt hier sehr schnell einen Überblick.
Außerdem habe ich noch verschiedene Temperatursensoren angeschlossen,
die mir von verschiedenen Zonen eine Messung geben.
Also das ist alles in so einem Schrank eingebaut. Da habe ich einen eigenen
Sensor, um zu schauen, wie die Temperatur da mit den ganzen Geräten ist,
beziehungsweise wie die Temperatur an sich ist.
Das will ich demnächst auch noch aufrüsten, noch um einen Bluetooth-Sensor,
den ich in den Kühlschrank lege, dass ich auch da schaue, es gibt überhaupt.
Die coolsten Sensoren, da bin ich gerade noch am forschen. Habe jetzt auch so
einen Tanksensor eingebaut für den Frischwasserverbrauch, um zu sehen, wie es da so aussieht.
Aber wo es halt so richtig nerdy wird, ist, wenn man hier so in den Advanced-Modus schaltet.
Da lacht das Herz des Elektrotechnikers, weil du hier wirklich jedes Detail dir anschauen kannst.
Also du kannst dir wirklich genau angucken, was hat der Solarregler hier an
Volt Und was irgendwie gemacht, in welchem Zustand befinden sich diese Systeme.
Du kannst ja mit der Maus rüber hofern und siehst sofort in den anderen Panels,
was zu dem jeweiligen Zeitpunkt bei den anderen Geräten passiert ist.
Das, was ihr jetzt hier gerade seht, ist nur eine sehr kleine Liste von Dingen,
die man sich einblenden kann.
Man kann hier also tausend Widgets dazuschalten, die irgendwie Relaiszustände, Systemzustände,
Sensoren, Spannung und Ampere-Werte auf allen möglichen Messstrecken,
wo auch immer irgendwas anliegt, von allen möglichen Devices.
Es ist wirklich cool und man kriegt sehr schnell einen Überblick und das mag
ich sehr in diesem Victron-System, dass man also hier schnell sich so einen
Überblick verschaffen kann und analysieren kann.
Also ich hatte schon verschiedene Fehlersituationen, wo ich mich gefragt habe,
was ist denn da eigentlich passiert, die ich also noch Tage und Wochen,
Monate später noch nachvollziehen konnte, bis auf die Minute genau,
was ist da eigentlich passiert.
Um zu analysieren, was eigentlich das Problem war.
Ja, die Holländer, das sind wirklich die Wohnwagennationen. Allerdings. Da sieht man es. Ja. Ja.
Und übrigens zu dem EcoFlow gibt es auch eine App, die zeigt auch Daten an.
Gut, jetzt hier nicht, weil die Batterie ausgeschaltet ist.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen kruder, aber immerhin kann man auch durch die
App irgendwie den AC und den 12 Volt DC ein- und ausschalten,
was eigentlich auch ganz lustig ist.
Und ich meine, aber das hatten wir ja auch schon gesagt, meine SolarEdge-Installation,
die hat ja auch jede Menge Daten.
Ich bin jetzt übrigens bei 25 Megawattstunden über die Lebensdauer der Anlage,
habe ich gerade gesehen.
Wow.
Das ist das, was die Dachanlage bei mir zu Hause über die letzten… 25 Megawattstunden.
Erzeugt hat.
25.000 Kilowattstunden.
Die, wenn ich sie hier aus dem Stromnetz ziehe, mich 34 Cent kostet.
Das ist sozusagen Strom im Wert von 8.500 Euro.
Ja, allerdings ist vieles davon natürlich ins Netz abgeflossen.
Ja, aber nur mal um so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was man da so aus der Luft
holt. In welchem Zeitraum?
In vier Jahren ungefähr.
Vier Jahre hast du 25 Megawattstunden.
Also seit August 2020. Das sind dann, nee, 2021.
Drei. Nicht ganz. Nicht ganz drei Jahre.
Nee, nicht ganz vier Jahre.
21.
21, 22, 23, 24.
Nee, das Erste, wenn das Einzelne losgeht, dann musst du es nicht mitzählen.
Und dieses Jahr ungefähr fünf Megawattstunden.
Ja, aber ich teile das mal durch drei Jahre. sind halt irgendwie 2800 Euro Strom
wert, den du aus der Luft geholt hast. Ja.
Ja. Gut. Also, ich meine, man darf sich jetzt nur so mäßig über Rentabilität unterhalten, aber ja.
Aber ich glaube, viele Leute machen sich nicht wirklich einen Kopf darüber, wie viel da zu holen ist.
Und das halt in dem Moment, wo man viel Fläche hat,
wenn man damit gesegnet ist, dass man für relativ überschaubaren Taler wirklich
eine interessante Option bekommt und damit einfach auch unabhängiger wird von Infrastruktur.
Und das ist irgendwie geil.
Also wenn man das nach Autarkie sieht,
dann habe ich zumindest für dieses Jahr 32% des verbrauchten Stromes kam aus
dem Netz, der Rest irgendwie aus der Batterie oder direkt von der Solarzelle.
Also das ist schon...
Okay.
Das ist schon okay.
Ich würde sagen, das Tutorial können wir jetzt an der Stelle zuklappen.
Ich hoffe, das war für euch so ein bisschen so ein Kick-Off.
Einfach sogar ich, der ich eigentlich keine Ahnung habe,
war in der Lage, sich dann da reinzufummeln und man kann sich mit diesen Komponenten,
die es gibt auf dem Markt,
schnell für die jeweilige Anwendung was bauen und das irgendwie macht auch irgendwie
Spaß. Also es ist irgendwie cool.
Also wenn man es wirklich vertiefen möchte, dann kann man sich nochmal über
Verschattung unterhalten.
Aber das ist, wenn man es wirklich nur dann, wenn man sich da vertiefen möchte.
Das können wir ja dann vielleicht später mal vertiefen. Jetzt haben wir unsere
vier Stunden voll und da machen wir ja immer Schluss nach vier Stunden.
Ja, haben wir eine sonderbare magische Grenze.
Die aber ziemlich genau immer getroffen wird.
Wir haben aber jetzt auch, wenn ich die Liste sehe, alles abgearbeitet.
Ja, haben wir.
Das ist ganz friedlich heute.
Ja, wie auch sonst.
Wir müssen Max wieder einladen.
Ja, Leute. Das war's. Haben wir eigentlich schon einen Termin für die nächste Sendung?
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns gleich nochmal einen ausdenken.
Ich hoffe, da war was für euch dabei. Und wir hören uns bald wieder.
Ja, vielleicht sehen wir uns ja auch demnächst auf eine der Veranstaltungen,
über die ich gesprochen habe.
Oder ich. Oder du, genau.
Und das wäre doch alles super. So, und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur noch uns verabschieden.
Du musst den Outro-Button drücken.
Ja, ich muss den richtigen Outro-Button erstmal finden.
Ah, auf Anhieb.
So, dann verabschieden wir uns mal ganz brav. Ralf, möchtest du dich auch verabschieden?
Aber ja, einen wunderschönen Restabend, Restnacht, Morgen, Mittag,
wann immer ihr zeitautonom diese Konserve euch anhört.
Eher gute Nacht, aber ja.
Also, das war's. Bis bald. Tschüss.